[Music]
hi guys welcome to part two of the
digital marketing full course video by
simply learn in this video we'll be
covering everything you need to know
about digital marketing we'll do this
with the help of our instructor rob
sanders
in this video we'll learn about google
ads google display network google
analytics how to set up goals in google
ads how to set up event tracking in
google ads and google data studio we'll
also be talking about how to start with
social media marketing
facebook advertising tips and strategies
how to rank youtube videos how to create
a youtube channel how to increase
youtube subscribers youtube ads how to
increase followers on instagram and how
to increase twitter followers when
you're setting up your brand and you
need to make sure it reaches the right
audience and provide the best results
there's really only one place to turn to
it's one of the largest online
advertising platforms really in the
world and that's on google and so today
we're going to talk about how to
advertise on google and let's get right
to it and talk about google ads and
its effect with advertising so we're
going to start out with what are google
ads well google ads used to be called
google adwords and it's been around a
good while almost 20 years now so really
google has grown at a really rapid pace
it's become one of google's main sources
of revenue uh you could say probably in
the 90 percentile of its revenue comes
from google ads and when we say google
ads we mean people who pay for
advertising on google.com so google ads
really what it does is it provides
services that fall under the category of
ppc which stands for pay-per-click you
may also may hear google ads or ppc
referred to as cost per click or cpc or
sponsored search really what it comes
down to it's a model so when you
advertise on google.com and somebody
clicks on your ad basically you're
paying google for they click okay so
it's just really a business model where
an advertiser pays google to have their
advertisement on google.com but they
only pay google when they get the click
so that's really in a nutshell how it
works for advertisers if i want to
advertise my business i can go to google
ads and say google place my ad on
google.com and then my ad does get shown
on google.com somebody clicks on it it's
just as simple as i pay google a fee so
google ads is just an online advertising
platform developed by google with which
advertisers can pay to display ads they
can offer up their services there's
video involved there's obviously
mobile's involved so you got all the
necessary devices and platforms
available in google's ecosystem so for
example if i go to google search even if
i type in you know what is google ads
here i can see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what are google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from youtube you
got a knowledge graph here you got
feature snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're going to focus on today we're
going to talk about sponsored search so
you can see here for this particular
keyword query that i typed in what are
google ads really two sponsored search
or pay-per-click ads appeared now if i
happen to click on any one of these two
and go to that particular advertisements
website they're gonna pay google a
specific cost per click so that's how it
looks on google.com it really depends on
your query and what ads show up but the
great thing about your google ads is
they make it known for the user who's
doing the search query what the ad is so
here i can easily pick out what's an ad
a sponsored search or pay-per-click ad
and what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an advertiser
advertising on google.com i'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have that little ad box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have the little ad box you know it's a
paid search ad now why do we want to
advertise on google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so
what i mean by that is you know search
is really a great place to advertise
because you're meeting the consumer
halfway meaning somebody's typing
something in and your ad is there to
help them find what they're looking for
so google ads advertises your product or
service to the relevant audience to
ensure the users perform the action
required of them so it's really a great
way to get quality audience to your
website because if somebody types in
something and you happen to offer what
they're looking for basically your ad is
going to show up somebody clicks on it
you pay google for the click and you get
quality traffic and return so the other
great benefit to being on google ads is
increases brand awareness so it's a
great way to get your product and brand
out there google has a vast network uh
also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search network
itself the search engine itself millions
of people use it every day fact here in
the united states
it's been said or studied that you know
people over the age of 18 use search at
least once a day at least once a day
here in the united states so you can
figure that's millions and millions of
people so it's a great way to get your
brand in front of a large captive
audience okay so top of mind awareness
refers to a brand of product being the
first one that comes to a customer's
mind when thinking about a particular
industry or category so it really does
provide top of mind awareness another
benefit to being on google ads is
retargeting so when we say the word
retargeting in marketing that means you
know showing our ad to somebody who's
already been to our website so we can
use google's display network or we can
run remarketing lists for search ads
right on google.com to ensure that we're
targeting those folks who have already
been to our website and have not
performed a function that we want them
to perform such as converting or buying
something or downloading something or
subscribing to a newsletter or visiting
a certain page okay so if somebody
doesn't do what we want them to do it's
okay maybe they're ready to commit to
our product or service and that's why
google offers up retargeting so it
allows us to reach that audience a
second time so they're going to be
familiar with their product they're
going to be familiar their website
because they've been there and so we can
offer up a very unique specific ad to
that audience so that's a really good
benefit to being on google ads so some
other benefits here increased
intelligence so you know we can
certainly get data about who is coming
to our audience so we can look at what
device what you know browser etc so we
can really gain some information about
who's coming to the website we could
certainly
measure our performance so with google
we're paying cost per click and so based
on that model you know we can certainly
measure
what keywords what ads are generating
traffic to the website and how much
we're paying for that okay and if that
traffic turns out to be a lead we can
measure that against that specific
keyword or ad or campaign so we can
certainly measure our performance all
the way down the keyboard level and can
we measure up against how many
conversions or what we're paying for
those conversions so google ads is a
very highly quantitative approach to
advertising because there's lots of
numbers involved and you're constantly
collecting information about your
advertising on google.com and its
network and another benefit really is
high flexibility so google ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
google ads has
very flexible options in terms of
advertising and we're going to talk
about some of those as we move along
here today so another big benefit here
and this is what i always suggest is if
you're not ranking organically then you
might want to consider google ads
because as we've shown here in our
example if i go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to bid on the keyword what are google
ads why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help and
advertising on google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you can bid on it so
it definitely is a good option if you're
not ranking for particular keyword
organically so it serves as almost an
option i always say that you know search
is like a fruit bowl okay you have
apples and oranges in that fruit bowl
well the orange is organic search and
the apple is paid search they're
different approaches but they share the
same fruit bowl the same real estate so
you can really really help yourself by
using google ads to complement what
you're doing organically so if you're
not ranked organically for keyword you
can certainly use google ads if you are
ranked for specific keywords and it's a
highly competitive industry then you can
use google ads to help you leverage the
amount of clicks you get from that ad so
it's okay to be organically listed and
have a paid search listing at the same
time so if we go back to our example
here we could see wordstream.com has a
paid ad and here we can see just two
spots below organically they're showing
up with an organic listing so you could
certainly be in both positions to try
and maximize your clicks so it's
definitely a good strategy to run with
google ads on top of everything we
mentioned in terms of measurement
flexibility google ads does offer up a
really good incentive to advertise and
let's not lose focus that again search
is really the only medium in which
you're meeting somebody halfway based on
what they're looking for and when i say
halfway meaning your ad is going to
appear for somebody who's looking for
something whether that be food a cafe a
plumber a doctor
or directions search is there to serve
that that person needs there's no other
advertisement platform or another
channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be tv or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps or also known as organic
search but the great thing is google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift focus now and talk about the
various formats in google ads on google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on google search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so jbl headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we call
ad extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones
on-ear headphones those are all site
link extensions meaning they're going to
link to something on your website and so
the purpose of the extension is to help
get the click so the reason why you're
running google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad i'll help you get
that click yes you're gonna pay google
for the click but that's the whole
purpose is to generate the click from
search because remember
search is there to respond to somebody's
need or query and so if you get the
click on your ad chances are it's going
to be a highly relevant visitor to your
website so google offers up a lot of
opportunity for you to write a lot of
information in your text ad on google
for google.com so google also has other
formats and so they also have responsive
display ads so when we say responsive we
mean google can serve up a specific
image from your website based on what
somebody's looking for based on the page
that they went to so these ads are
responsive they adjust their size
appearance and format depending on the
space available so responsive can also
be text text and or image and so the
whole point of response is if you have a
large website let's just say with a lot
of different products and categories
like amazon well it's hard to write
static ads for thousands of particular
categories and products so why not let
google do the heavy lifting why not let
google serve up the images and ads based
on what somebody looked at on your
website and so that's the whole idea
behind responsive ads is it allows
google to you know show the particular
ad that's most relevant to that user so
it's a really a great option when you're
advertising on google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to facebook where you
have a thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on facebook first
says google you have multiple multiple
sizes that you can choose from in terms
of running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so google owns youtube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on youtube so they could
be standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say a pre-roll meaning people are gonna
look at your ad before actually watching
the actual video they went to youtube
for so you have a lot of different
options with video advertisements on
youtube so the other ad format you have
on google are shopping ads and shopping
ads are really a great way to get your
product in front of the right user so
somebody's looking for shoes or running
shoes it's an opportunity for you to run
shopping ads so you could put that
particular shoe with a description with
the price with your brand name in front
of that user and so with a cost per
click model if a user clicks on your
shopping ad then chances are they're
probably going to convert because they
could see the product they could see the
price they could see the product name
they could see the brand and so it's an
opportunity for you to really drive high
quality traffic to your site with the
opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if i go to google search and i
just type in running shoes so my search
results are going to list not only some
paid ads but a lot of different options
on shopping ads so here i could
certainly scroll around and see all the
different brand names i could see the
price point if i hover over it i can
actually see you know some other
information about it like reviews
return policy so if i actually click on
this ad chances are i'm going to buy it
otherwise why would i click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on google search by certainly
really giving google access to your
product inventory connecting in some
reviews connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up google shopping ads within google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also pairs under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if i'm on google search you know i can
go to shopping or i can go to images and
i'll see
those same image ads show up here at the
top and i will certainly see those under
shopping as well so shopping ads allow
you to really showcase your products on
google search to those looking for that
particular product so it's really a
great option with google you also have
call ads so when we say call ads really
call only ads are great for mobile so
when you run advertisements on google if
you have a phone number associated with
your business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number they click on your number they're
actually going to call your business and
google can track that they can track how
many people click on your number and
even turn that into a conversion for you
so if you have a phone number associated
with your business it's wise to go ahead
and set up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the ad because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
google showing your ads i showed you an
example of google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
google search network so google search
network really allows you to advertise
on google search so with google search
if i go back to google search and i go
to all i typed in running shoes okay
here i can see shopping ads here i can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show at the top and if you're not
at the top then google will place you at
the bottom so really depends on the
keyword that somebody's querying in
google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what google does if i didn't have any
shopping ads here google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and i would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on google with a text
ad you want to make sure you're always
at the top so let's have a look at the
different types of search networks that
google ads is affiliated with so
the first is google search okay so let's
focus on google search and so basically
when we say google search or search
sites we really mean google.com or all
google search engines for that matter so
if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions of
people use it on a daily basis and so if
you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device as well so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
google search so if we go for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above
some featured snippets and the organic
search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again i've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if i scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again i can see the
logo add here okay so i can see simply
learn using three headlines i can see
simply learn using there are two
description lines here and i could see
simply learn using some other extensions
with the ad now all of this is geared
towards getting the click so when you're
on google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on google search if you're
on google search you have the
opportunity to be at the very top of the
search result or in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if i change my search query and
typed in coffee in san francisco
my search results are going to be
completely different i'm going to see
local listings here okay so this is tied
to google my business not google ads
okay so this is completely different so
don't don't mix this up with
running ads on google search so google
my business is tied to local listings or
google maps and again with desktop which
is what i'm showing you the search
result on you're going to see likely
google local listings above organic
results okay and if i go back to my
previous query of classes on digital
marketing i'm going to be able to see
paid search results above local and
organic listings so in other words if
you're running ads ads are going to
trump any other type of results on
google search if you can be in positions
one through three now in addition to
google.com google also has something
called google search partners so if you
set up an account and you set up a
campaign in google ads you have the
option to choose google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
google search partners sites and so some
of their search partners can range so
basically these are sites that have
partnered up with google that's allowing
google to
show ads on their site so the sites can
range anywhere between youtube to amazon
to new york times let's take a look at
an example it could even be another
search engine so if i go to say ask.com
and type in classes on digital marketing
it's a completely different search
engine but i can see the same ad for
simply learn so i can see same i could
see a different headline here actually
but i could see the description and i
could see some site link extensions and
so
notice the ad is still at the top in
this case it's in position one and i can
see multiple companies running
advertisements why because they could
see ad next to it and i could see those
over
over organic listings so these are
google search partner listings so you
can opt in to be on other partner sites
that google or other sites that google
has partnered up with so you have
options outside of google search and
that option is display network so
display network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of google
search and if you're going to advertise
on google's display network you have
more ad formats available to you
including image and including video for
example your ad can be found on a
specific
website if you choose to advertise on
the new york times dot com or webmd or
marriott.com you could certainly do that
okay you just need to tell google hey
this is the site i want to advertise on
so some of the advantages of being on
the display network so if you don't want
to advertise on google search okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so
you're basically reaching out to a large
number of people on google's display
network and giving them an opportunity
to see who you are as a brand and giving
them an opportunity to see what your
product is all about so for me the
display network is a good opportunity to
get your product and service in front of
a lot of people because this way the
display network works is it's a millions
of websites who want to have advertising
on their site and so you can really pick
and choose a specific site where your
audience is going to be and get your ad
in front of that audience so you can
really retarget to potential customers
so
retargeting as we said earlier is really
reaching out to people who have already
been to your website and didn't perform
a particular function that you wanted
them to perform meaning somebody came to
your website from paid search on
google.com and they went to page a and
then they left so you really wanted them
to go to page b add a product to a
shopping cart and check out and purchase
that product however if they didn't do
that you could certainly
run ads knowing that they've been to
page a and page b and you can offer up
that specific ad to that person who's
been to your website and so that's what
retargeting really is all about and you
can retarget on google's display network
so remarketing your product to people
who previously visited your your website
or even your app allows you to really
get your ad in front of a qualified
audience and so you could take advantage
of analytics so google's ads has all the
information you need so let's actually
take a look at some of these options in
google ads for the display network so if
i actually go to google ads and i
actually go to display campaigns i can
see i have a lot of different options
available to me so if i click on
keywords for example okay i can choose
keywords for my display campaign so what
google does if you choose keywords
basically what they're doing is they're
going to contextually place your ad
based on the keyword okay so that's an
option for you if you're not sure what
websites to be on with the display
network you can certainly just add
keywords and based on those keywords
google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the splake network
you can say hey google i only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and so based on that
google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the display
network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if i just choose a particular ad
group now i have specific topics that i
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals and so under each one of these
topics i can get really specific so if i
go under science i can see subcategories
under the topic science i can see
chemistry and physics and scientific
institutions and equipment so i can
really pick and choose specific topics
where i want my ads to be shown as i
mentioned already you can pick and
choose specific placements okay so if
you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on you can
certainly let google know okay you can
also advertise on gmail you can also
advertise on youtube so you can really
pick and choose where you want your ads
to be shown so you have all these
different options available to you to me
one of the best options for advertising
on the display network because when you
tell google you have a specific audience
you want to target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
re-target them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in google ads so when i actually pick
and choose how i want to target i can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or demographics for example if
i go back to demographics i have all
this data that google's collected on my
advertising so i can see for example by
age range based on my campaign how many
clicks how many impressions impressions
are how many times my ads been seen
click-through rate meaning the rate at
which people see my ad and are clicking
on my ad how much i'm paying per click
cpc is cost per click total cost and
conversions how many conversions am i
getting so i could see all this data
available to me in google ads so it's a
very powerful platform for measuring
performance okay let's talk about how
you can create a google ad okay so
first thing you want to do is you want
to set up your campaign and you want to
align and go with that campaign just
like we talked with ads related to
facebook you always want to align a goal
with your campaign just like we talked
about there we want to do the same thing
here on google so we have a number of
different options at our disposal so
when you run a campaign why are you
running the campaign so if you're in
just to drive traffic or you're trying
to generate brand awareness okay great
you can still set up that campaign
you're just going to choose the display
network okay the display network allows
you to get your ad out there on millions
of websites so that people can actually
see what your brand product or service
is all about
now if you're into direct response
meaning you're in it for sales and leads
then you probably want to choose
potentially google search partners as a
network okay not display but google
search and the partner sites okay on
google search so by choosing google
search as your network it's director
response so somebody's typing in a
keyword query and you're responding so
that's the whole idea behind google
search is we want to meet somebody
halfway we want to be able to offer up
the product or service they're looking
for so if sales and leads are what your
campaign goal is all about then you want
to go search network with the option to
choose google search partners okay again
if you're into you know driving brand
awareness or product and brand
consideration then maybe you should
choose the display network the bottom
line is you need to figure out what the
goal is of the campaign that's the very
most important very first step and most
important step is to figure out
what the goal is of the campaign and
once you've decided that then it's on to
setting up the campaign and in google
you're always going to have at least one
ad group and what makes up an ad group
keywords and ads so ideally when you set
up a campaign on google search network
you're going to choose keywords and
those keywords should be tightly knitted
or tightly themed or in other words be
all relevant to one another in an ad
group so that's what an ad group is
keywords that are relevant to one
another okay in that ad group you're
also going to have an ad so when you
choose your keywords you're going to
write an ad for those keywords so step 3
is after you set up the ad group and
choose your keywords you're going to
create an ad so let's take a look at how
that looks in google ads so if i go to
google ads i can see i already have an
account set up i have a couple campaigns
so let's just say i have this campaign
set up here i'm just going to call it
industrial campaign okay and if i choose
industrial campaign okay i'm going to
then be asked to set up an ad group now
if i set up an ad group already in that
ad group should be keywords and ads okay
so remember when you set up an ad group
you want to choose your keywords first
paying this keywords should be all
related to one another so for example i
could see an ad group here called fig
concentrate well if i click on this ad
group and i look at the keywords they
should all be related to fig concentrate
so here we go we can see a few keywords
in this ad group in fact i have 10 of
them all related to fig concentrate so
it's very very important from a quality
score perspective if you remember when
we're talking about quality score
quality score is based on landing page
experience expected click through and
the add relevancy to the keyword so if
you can choose a ad group and have all
your keywords related to one another
like i do here with fig concentrate then
it's easier to write an ad okay so here
i have 10 keywords all related to fig
concentrate so now if i go to ads and
extensions in the google ads platform we
can see here i already have a couple of
ads going okay so
ideally if i wanted to i can run more
than just two ads as a best practice as
a best practice you want to have at
least two ads why because these two ads
are going to be served up against each
other and ideally the whole idea of
running more than one ad is what google
can do is start serving up the ad that
is performing better in terms of
click-through rate or in terms of
conversions okay so it doesn't hurt to
even add one or two more ads so here i'm
going to go ahead and add one more ad
here okay if i click on that plus button
i have a bunch of options here i'm going
to go ahead and choose text ad because
i'm running this campaign on the search
network and my goal is to get sales not
lead sales so i want sales i want
somebody to click on my ad go to my
website and purchase some fake
concentrate so that's my goal and so if
i'm on the search network i can only
have text ads so i'm going to choose
text at and once i choose text ad then i
have the option now to go through and
create a new ad okay so what google
actually does is they populate the ad
from previous ads and so this gives me
an opportunity to tweak one of the ads i
already have in place so here you can
see i have a final url and that's the
url that the traffic is gonna go to when
they click on your ad okay so if
somebody clicks on the ad that's the
page they're gonna go to call that the
final url now i have an option to create
up to three headlines so here i could
see headline one up to 30 characters i
have my brand name headline two i have
something related to the keyword i'm
bidding on so what am i talking about
fake concentrate okay again up to 30
characters now that includes spaces so
if you happen to go over 30 characters
your ads not going to get approved so
here you can see 32 over 30. i'm two
characters over
i just get rid of that the add is okay
so you got to be careful to stay within
the boundaries of the character limits
including spaces so here i got headline
two is fig concentrate now i'm gonna
write headline three this is new so this
is recently implemented by google and i
highly recommend that all the fields
available to you you use because the
more information you can put in an ad
the better it is for not only your ad
but for the end user because if
somebody's searching and looking for
fake concentrate and you provide them as
with as much information as possible
then the chances of them clicking on
your ad are going to be greater and
that's what we want if we're going to
advertise we want to advertise so that
people can see our ad and click on our
ad that's the whole point isn't it to
get people to click on our ad because
they're looking for something that we're
offering in this example fit concentrate
so
here i have headline three i'm gonna go
ahead and put something in a headline
three maybe a promotion let's just say
i'm offering up twenty percent so i can
say up to twenty percent off through
april and may now you see i'm running
into character count so i'm just gonna
go ahead and keep it at april so up to
20 off through april now i can create
another ad and maybe change the headline
to say up to 20 off through may so you
want to take advantage of all three
headlines now notice when i added the
headline here i can see a preview of it
on mobile and i can see a preview of it
on desktop now underneath that i have
what they call the display path so what
google does is they take your domain in
this case valleyfig.com and you can
basically customize that domain with
what they call a path so you have path
one path two and the whole point of this
is for you to
customize it based on the keywords you
were bidding on so i'm bidding on fake
concentrate i'm going to put fake
concentrate in here now remember when
somebody actually clicks on my ad
they're not going to go to valleyfig.com
figs concentrate they're going to go to
the url up here under final url so you
want to make sure you put a path in here
ideally what i would do is put in
something related to the keyword i'm
bidding on in this case fig concentrate
now i have an opportunity to add a new
description a second description this is
new and i have up to 90 characters so i
can go ahead and add some content so
remember with description 2 i have up to
90 characters so i'm just going to go
ahead and borrow some copy from the
website if i'm not actually sure what to
write and
so here you can see fit concentrate is a
natural product containing no
preservatives or additives so that's my
second description so now i can go ahead
and
save and create extensions so i'm just
going to go ahead and push the button
save and create extensions and when i do
that i'm going to be prompted to go
ahead and create some ad extensions and
so ad extensions allow me to add in
links site links underneath the ad just
like you see here so when you've added
your site link extensions and other
extensions you save it you'll be able to
see your new ad here here we can see the
ad we created okay notice it's got the
three headlines now this has got the two
descriptions and if i want to edit i can
just click edit add and go ahead and
edit it if i don't want to edit it then
i don't have to i can always go back so
you can always edit it ad after it's
been created okay if not no big deal
notice when you actually create your ad
in some cases google is going to review
it to make sure it fits within google's
guidelines and policies uh but once it's
approved you'll see it under uh you'll
see approved under the status column and
that's pretty much how you would go
ahead and create a text app okay so when
it does get approved it's going to be in
the rotation with the other two ads and
so what google's going to do is serve up
each ad equally and then eventually the
ad that is performing best will get
served up more and that way you're
putting your best ad always in front of
the user who's looking for the product
and service you're offering so now let's
talk about the metrics so associated
with these keywords these ads these ad
groups and campaigns so there are a lot
of metrics
in google ads a lot of metrics and we're
not even going to cover most of these
metrics we're just going to cover what i
deem the most common the most important
metrics to get you going so if you find
yourself advertising whether that be on
google search network or google's
display network you're going to have
some common metrics and here are the
metrics that we're going to focus on
today so you have impressions cost
clicks average cpc
conversions cost per conversion ctr or
click the array and quality score so
let's go through these metrics here and
talk about what they are so impressions
really it's the number of times your ads
been shown on that particular network
whether it's google search or display
and so an impression is just how many
times somebody actually seen your ad
okay whether they actually physically
seen it or not if your ad is showing up
on that network then an impression is
going to counted so here if we're
looking at ads we can see
we have over a period of time certain
amount of impressions okay so that's how
many times this particular ad has been
shown so this particular ad here the
first one at the top has been shown 557
times over this period of time which is
year to date okay so that's an
impression how many times your ads been
shown so if we talk about cost cost
refers to the amount of money we've
spent so any time your ad gets clicked
you're going to pay google x amount so
if i go back to google ads i can see
what my total cost is and not only can i
see what my total cost is i can see what
my average cost per click is and so
there's a lot of factors that go into
what you actually pay and some of these
factors are who else is advertising
where you're advertising what network
you're advertising on what time of day
what particular keyword and so there's a
lot of factors and so here i can see on
average year-to-date i've spent 1.80 per
click on this particular ad for a total
of 32.33
so i can really see how much i've
actually spent and so clicks is just
refers to
how many times somebody clicked on your
ad so if your ads been shown you need an
impression and when somebody sees your
ad they're going to click on your ad so
the whole idea is to get the click
remember you want to be in positions one
through three so i want to make sure
that my average position is between one
and three and so if you're looking in
google ads at metrics and you don't see
average position well you can always add
that as a column so if i click on
columns here and then i go to
competitive metrics and i click on
average position and i'm going to move
average position all the way to the top
here so if i click uh move average
position all the way at the top i'm
gonna be able to see what my average
position is over that particular period
of time so here i can see i'm in
positions one through three and that's
where you wanna be you wanna be in
positions one through three so if you're
in positions one through three that
means you're at the top if you're on
google search or that means you're in a
problem position on the display network
so if your ad is shown meaning this gets
an impression then likely somebody's
going to click on that ad and somebody
clicks on that ad it's going to generate
a click which in turn is going to
generate cost and so ideally what you
want to do is you want to measure the
rate at which people click on your ad
based on how many times it was shown so
here i can see 28 clicks over
3549 impressions that's a 0.79
click-through rate so ideally the higher
the click-through rate the better the at
and the higher the clicker rate the
chances are you're going to get more
traffic to your site so we want to be
able to measure clicks and we want to be
able to measure click through rate and
we also want to measure cost per click
which is really the total cost divided
by the number of clicks so if i go back
to google ads here i can see you know
17.57
over 28 clicks that averages out to
about 63 cents per click so that's how i
get cost per click now your class per
click is going to vary a little bit okay
so it's going to vary based on keyword
it's going to be based on where you're
advertising what position etc so there's
a lot of factors involved with cost per
click but that's how you would actually
calculate it but google ads actually
does the calculation for you for
collector rate and cost per click but in
case you want to know you can always
divide clicks into cost okay so
conversions probably one of the most
important metrics you're going to use in
google ads because you're paying google
and if you're paying google for
advertising you want to make sure you're
getting return on your investment so
conversions are added when a user clicks
on your ad and performs an action that
you've defined such as purchasing
something downloading something viewing
something signing up for a newsletter
etc so you want to make sure that if
you're in google ads that you're
measuring conversions and so you simply
want to go to tools so if you go to
tools and then click on conversions you
want to make sure that you're running
conversions ideally what you want to do
is you want to run conversions from
google analytics but you can certainly
set up conversions within google ads as
well notice i also have call from ads as
set up as a conversion so you have an
opportunity in google ads to add a
number a different conversions and the
more conversions you add really the
better off you are because you want to
measure up all your campaigns against
conversions if i go back to campaigns i
want to be able to see what campaigns
are driving conversions and if i can
measure that and i have a campaign
that's really driving conversions that
i'm going to continue to advertise on
google okay so here over this particular
period of time i can see one campaign
has driven nine conversions at 128.67
cost per conversion and so how do i get
cost per conversion well i get my total
cost divided by the number of
conversions and then i could see my
conversion rate the rate at which people
convert so
really if i have 241 clicks and 9
conversions that's 9 divided by 241
that's 3.77
conversion rate so i can measure
conversion rate cost per conversion and
conversion just by setting up
conversions in google ads and so ideally
if you're going to pay google for
advertising you want to be able to
measure return on investment via
conversions so again see cost per
conversion is just really the total cost
divided by the number of conversions and
then click the rate again just as a
reminder the total clicks divided by the
total number of impressions and then one
other metric we're going to talk about
here today is quality scores so quality
score is really google's way of
measuring how well
your keywords are are compared to
the ad associated with it the expected
click-through rate and the landing page
so quality score is the backbone of
google ads so if i go back to google ads
and i click on keywords quality scores
something you want to measure and if you
don't have it in your columns you could
certainly just click on columns and add
it and so here i can see my quality
score and quantity score is a
measurement between one and ten and so
if you have a good quality score
google's gonna score you higher because
your keyword is relevant to your ad it's
relevant to the landing page and you
have a good expected click-through rate
if you don't have a good quality score
google's gonna let you know why you
don't have a good quality score so again
your three categories that make up
quality score are landing page
experience which means really google
looking at the landing page you're
sending people to and they're seeing if
the page loads well fast does it have
ads does it have good content is it a
good landing page will the end user have
a good experience they also look at the
ad relevance okay is the ad relevant to
the keyword and they'll also look at the
expected click-through rate okay so
based on other advertisers and their
click-through rate are you achieving the
same click-through rate and so those
three factors make up quality score
quality score is a metric assigned to
keywords so if you don't have a good
quality score you need to fix it because
the repercussion is you're going to have
to pay more so having a good quality
score likely means you're going to pay
less per click so you want to make sure
that if you bid on a keyword that the
keyword goes to a relevant landing page
the ad itself is relevant and you're
getting a good click-through rate so
quality score is the backbone of google
ads and how it works so you want to make
sure you have a good quality score so
optimizing your ads so what if you don't
have a good quality score what if you're
not getting conversions well there's
things you can do so remember we want to
make sure that we're adding extensions
whether that be call site link review
app add extensions to your ads because
it's going to increase the click-through
rate so you can also
really hone your ad copy if you're
selling products and you're running
promotion maybe you want to add in a
little sense of urgency to help people
you know realize hey if this this
promotion's ending maybe i want to click
on the ad and take action okay with
google ads you can always run a b
testing on ads and so what you could do
is run two ads in one ad group and see
what ad is performing best in terms of
click-through rate or conversion rate
and whatever ad is running better you
can always run that ad and then continue
more testing so that way you're always
putting your best forward in terms of
advertising in the ad copy whether that
be text or display you always want to
use call to action you want to get
people to click on your ad when somebody
clicks on your ad it's going to improve
click-through rate click-through rate
improves quality score so as i mentioned
several times already you want to make
sure your ads are placed at the top
between positions one and three on
google search so you can measure ad
position in google ads and if you're not
rank between one and three you want to
increase your bid okay you can also
optimize for local search so local is an
ad extension that you can add to your ad
you can also advertise at a time when
your audience is online or you can
advertise on during business hours only
so you can adjust when you advertise on
google ensure some of your ads you know
capitalize on some particular events
that are related to your industry so you
can capitalize on that okay you can
certainly ask google to accelerate your
ads okay or you can do standard delivery
so google can spread out your clicks and
show your ads throughout the day google
search is all about keywords so you want
to be able to pick and choose the right
keywords first you can also add negative
keywords so
if you're bidding on a specific industry
let's just say you have software and you
want somebody to sign up for your
particular piece of software uh but you
don't offer a free trial then maybe you
want to add free as a negative keyword
so if you don't offer anything for free
free should be a negative keyword so if
somebody actually does type in looking
for free software then your ads not
going to show up so that's the whole
idea behind negative keywords okay you
can use dynamic keyword insertion into
your ads meaning you can ask google hey
i want to dynamically insert a keyword
into my ad that somebody uses to make
your ad more relevant so relevancy
increases click-through rate and
improves quality score so as you can see
there's a lot of things you can do
here's some more things you can use
branding keywords you can use particular
match types in google so let's talk
about match types for a second so you
have different match types if i go back
to google ads here i could see my
keywords that i'm bidding on so by
default if you actually bid on a keyword
it's going to be broad match and so if
i've been on the keyboard medical
computer if somebody typed in something
related to medical and included the
keyword medical but not computer then my
ad may show up however i can make an
exact match so somebody can type in
exactly only medical computers so if i
click edit and i can change the match
type for that particular keyword to
exact then that means that somebody that
types in only medical computer my ad is
going to show up i can basically do
phrase match so somebody types in
looking for
something that's going to help me with
medical computers okay that's a long
tail phrase work keyword query but the
keyword medical computer is in that
order so my ad is going to show up okay
so with phrase match your ad is going to
show when somebody types in that keyword
you're bidding on in that order you also
have broad match modifiers so if you
have a plus sign in front of the keyword
then that means that somebody actually
has to use that keyword in the query in
order for your ad to show up okay so you
could change the match type of any
keyword so if you use an exacto phrase
then chances are you're going to have
lower volume of queries but probably
higher relevancy if you use a broad
match then your ad could show up for any
combination of search queries so you
really want to be careful on the match
type that you choose so keep an eye on
quality score remember google has
quality score between one and ten the
higher quality score the better you are
so really if you have a quality score i
would say anything below four you
probably want to pause the keyword okay
so you can measure quality score at the
keyword level so if i go back to google
ads and i have keywords that are say
three chances are i'm going to have to
pay more for the click and it might not
be worth it so i may want to end up
pausing that keyword and try other
keywords that are more relevant that i
can send traffic to a more relevant
landing page or i can have an ad that's
more relevant to that keyword in order
to help with the quality score okay you
can ensure that your landing pages are
mobile friendly so that's another thing
you want to keep in mind that most
people start their search on mobile so
you certainly want to make sure that
your landing pages are optimized because
if somebody starts to search on mobile
likes your products or service chances
are they're coming back via desktop or
even going into the store most searches
start on mobile so you want to make sure
those pages are optimized and there's
plenty more things you could do to
optimize your ads you want to make sure
you group and organize your keywords
into relevant ad groups why because you
can write relevant ads for those
keywords so if i go back to google ads i
want to make sure if i go to ad groups
that the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to one another so what's my
ad group name well if it's medical pc if
i click on medical pc i want to make
sure the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to medical pc i want to
structure my campaigns and ad groups to
target more ads effectively so you want
to be able to you know organize your
campaigns and ad groups and the rule of
thumb here is you should organize your
campaigns and ad groups based on the
site architecture of your site so the
way your website is laid out in the
navigation is how you should likely
structure your campaigns and ad groups
focus on your budget okay so you want to
put more budget to campaigns that are
converting okay you can use automatic
bidding for ads to maximize results so
meaning that google has
what they call artificial intelligence
so google can do a lot of the bidding
and a lot of the managing for you that's
really a great benefit to running your
ads on google so their machines are
learning behavior from your keywords
that you're bidding on and so ideally
when they learn what's converting
they're going to bid more and try and
help you get the conversion for the
keywords that have historically
converted and so ideally you can use
some of the automated bidding features
that google ads has to offer in order to
improve performance and today we're
going to talk about google display
network so thanks for joining and let's
get started so i want you to imagine
having the world at your fingertips
especially when it comes to advertising
imagine having the entire world at your
fingertips for advertising so just
imagine you have the ability to
advertise your brand to any website in
the world can you imagine that well
imagine having
that entirety at your fingertips the
entire world so it's not really an
imagination so no need to imagine
anymore because google ads has come to
the rescue so no need to imagine the
world is at your fingertips and why is
it at your fingertips because of google
and specifically google display network
okay so we're gonna talk about what the
google display network is so let's start
out by asking the question or answering
the question what is the google display
network so google has two networks
basically one the search network one the
display network so you as an advertiser
if you want to advertise on google you
have a choice can i go with google
search or can i go with the display
network well the search network is for
google search only so if you want to
advertise when somebody types in a
keyword query and you want your ad to
show up that's the search network so it
looks something like this somebody types
in a keyword data science and lo and
behold ads show up and here you can see
the first ad from simply learn why did
that ad show up because simply learn was
bidding on the keyword data science and
so that's how the search network works
you bid on keywords somebody types on
those keywords and your ads show up in
the search engine results at the top
above organic listings so that's the
search network and it just simply
comprises
of ads that respond to what people are
querying okay the display network is a
little bit different so that's the
search network today we're going to talk
about the display network okay the
display network is a little bit
different so imagine you're on the
lookout for a new shoe on amazon as an
example but you don't have end up buying
the shoe you're looking at shoes you
don't buy it well you might have noticed
in the past you've done something like
that whether it be shoes or shirts or
coats or belts or cars or radios or
headphones or phones it doesn't really
matter you might have been looking at
something and then notice an ad show up
it might have been exactly that same
product or might have been something
similar to the product you were looking
at but on the same website so why does
that happen well it happens because
google's display network specifically
remarketing which we'll talk about so on
google's display network you have the
option to advertise that somebody's been
on your website so that's one of the
powers and one of the features of
google's display network and that's
remarketing or retargeting somebody
that's looked at your product so let's
take a little bit of a deeper dive into
how the display network works so if
you're a customer you go to a website
and
you leave that website again from a
remarketing perspective
your product can appear on another site
okay so that's remarketing so you can
retarget that person who's been to your
site so that's again one great example
of how to use display network in google
terms we call it remarketing and again
somebody goes to your website they leave
in this example not buying something it
could be a technology company where we
want somebody to watch a video or
download a pdf okay whatever they do
that that you want them to do but they
don't actually do it then you can go
back and retarget them so if they
actually go to a page and look at your
product but don't buy that product then
you have the opportunity to advertise to
them again so the whole idea is if you
advertise them again wow that person can
say okay i remember that i was in still
interested in that product let me go
back and purchase that product so they
go back to the site and make the
purchase so that's again the power of
the display network you can reach people
who have been to your site before so
let's take another look here so
retargeting evolves around adding a
piece of code or pixel on your website
which uses browser cookies to add
website visitors to your audience so let
me just summarize that for you so if you
want to use display network and you want
to target people who've been to your
website well you need to add a simple
script or pixel if you will to your
website that's all and so when somebody
comes to your website they're gonna get
cookied and that cookie is stored in
their browser and so that's an important
piece of the whole process because
that's how google determines who that
visitor is so without that cookie then
google won't know to show their ad your
ad to them again so that's the first
piece in all this so when somebody does
get cookie they're going to be added to
that audience and so when we say
audience we mean you as an advertiser
defining who you want to retarget to so
in this example we're talking about
people who have looked at a product and
didn't purchase that could be a whole
audience in itself people who look at a
product and don't purchase it could be
everyone who comes to your website it
could be only returning users it could
be only new users you define the
audience but however you define that
audience they're going to get cookied
and placed on a list and when they're
placed in that list they're going to get
shown the ad again so past visitors will
see your product ads when they're
browsing the web watching videos on
youtube going through news sites and so
on so if that's your audience list past
visitors that's where they're going to
be able to see your ad because google's
displayed network is much more than just
websites it's also youtube it's also
news feeds it's also social networking
sites so there's a lot involved with
google's display network so the network
involves several websites that are
partnering up with google along with the
likes of youtube
along with the likes on millions of
other websites in fact these websites
together tally up to more than 2 million
that encompasses more than 90 of the
internet so you can imagine google's
display network is just made up of a
bunch of websites including youtube okay
so you have the opportunity to really
reach somebody that's been to your
website before so again if they're past
visitors and they looked at a product
and they didn't purchase it you have an
opportunity to really put your ad in
front of them on a lot of different
websites so that's just an intro about
the display network remarketing is just
one benefit but let's take a step back
so we dove into the deep end with
remarketing let's just separate out the
two again just so you're clear on what
the display network is versus the search
network well let's go
through some of the differences so
display network on the left search
network on the right so the display
network as we just discussed is great
for retargeting people who have been to
your website whether they're new users
returning users users who looked at a
product users who added a product to
your cart users who looked at a specific
page whatever that behavior is you're
defining that now the search network is
usually for top of funnel why do we say
top of funnel because users are actively
searching for something they're looking
for a product they're being active so
they're going to search and seeing who
has that product okay the display
network we know remarketing is a benefit
but usually it's bottom of funnel like
brand awareness so if nobody knows who
your brand is or what your brand is or
what you have to offer what your
services are then the display network
remember made up of millions of websites
you have the opportunity to put your ad
out there okay so display bottom of
funnel search network top of funnel
somebody actively looking for something
let's take a look at some other
differences here so display network
easier to advertise products that don't
satisfy an immediate need this is true
because again if you have a new product
you want to get that product out there
you want people to just know about it
some people may not be ready to buy that
product but at least they're going to
know what the products about on the
search network on the other hand if
somebody's looking for something like a
particular product that you're offering
then they could type in a keyword that
describes that product and wham your ad
can appear at the top okay remember top
of funnel so products and services
usually fulfill a particular requirement
now the display network can be used to
familiarize users to your brand so again
going back to remarketing somebody comes
to your website they really don't know
who you are well you can reach back out
to them on the display network with
another ad retargeting and that's how
you get users familiar with your brand
where on the search network users are
showing ads based on what they search
for so
it doesn't really matter if they know
your brand or not hey
if they're looking for something and
they're ready to buy and you have that
product at the right price then the
chance of them converting are pretty
good so you're at the right place at the
right time where the display network's
all about familiarity retargeting to
people with your brand getting your
brand out there getting your product out
there in front of millions of people now
on the display network users are shown
these ads in over a million different
websites so with the display network you
have the opportunity to kind of hone in
and pick and choose those websites where
on the search network users are shown
ads in google apps and on the search
engines so you have the opportunity to
place your ads not just on desktop
search but also on mobile and also on
apps whereas again the display network
is made up of much more it's made up of
websites youtube apps etc okay the
display network has a multitude of
different formats okay when we say
different formats we mean text ads image
ads rich media ads meaning ads that have
some functionality to it like movement
okay and then video ads where the search
network is really only text ads and i
say really only text ads well you can
have image ads those are called shopping
ads but mainly it's text ads where
display network you have an option
between text image rich media or video
ads so you can see the differences here
really there are big differences between
the two networks where search you're
just really responding what somebody's
looking for they're really active and
ready to go display hey you're trying to
reach out to these people you're trying
to introduce them to something and in
some cases with remarketing you're
reaching out to them again okay you're
trying to get them familiar with your
product and brand and you're trying to
do that via video via rich media via a
regular image ad via text ad so you're
trying to do it in a multitude of
formats so again bottom of funnel for
display top of funnel for search now
we've already mentioned display ads can
be found in a number of different
formats so that's important to know so
for example text ads so we know what a
text ad looks like on the search network
very similar on the display network so
you have a headline you have some text
you have a url so that's a text ad so
text ads on display are very similar to
how they look on search rich media ads
so these type of ads enable more user
engagement with videos animation
text combinations and more so you
usually have some movement going on here
with rich media ads some animation
something that you're going to likely
engage with okay so with display you
have the opportunity to serve up rich
media ads the whole idea is you want to
really grab somebody's attention because
display is bottom of funnel we're trying
to introduce our brand to somebody so
putting something engaging in front of
them is going to get them to take notice
of your product and brand okay we have
regular image ads so these ads let you
use relevant images layouts and
different backgrounds and colors so you
can use a static image with some
messaging with it again there are some
best practices involved here with image
edge you're really you're trying to
introduce your product and brand to
somebody you want to make it stand out
and pop and then of course video ads so
video ads are served up on youtube and
across a multitude of websites on
google's display network remember
google's display network is made up of
millions of sites some sites allow for
video advertising so it's not just
limited to youtube it can be used for a
multitude of sites across the display
network so that's an intro to the
display network those are the
differences between
search and display now let's go through
the steps of how to set up a
campaign in google ads using the display
network as our option so here i am i'm
in google ads i'm in an account and i
want to set up a campaign on the display
network so you can see here if i'm in
google ads i've selected display
campaigns i can already see i have some
display network campaign set up in fact
they're all remarketing campaigns and so
remarketing remember is targeting
somebody who fits a list or description
okay so it could be somebody looking at
a particular product they get cookie
meaning that text file is going to sit
on their browser and then they're going
to see your ad the next time they're on
google's display network wherever site
they may be so we're reaching out to
somebody who fits a particular
description okay so if we're going to
set up a display campaign meaning a
campaign on google's display network we
want to go to campaigns and we want to
click on the plus button here and we're
just going to say new campaign now we
have the opportunity now to pick and
choose what our goal is for that
campaign and so most of the time with
display you're going to choose brand
awareness and reach okay so here you can
see the campaign types for brand
awareness and reach display and video
usually when it comes to sales or leads
or even just driving traffic okay you
might go with the search network but if
you're just really trying to just
promote your brand you may go with
display because remember you have the
option to get your ad in front of
millions of websites we're gonna choose
brand awareness and reach okay and we're
going to choose the campaign type so
here you have display we want to run
different kinds of ads or we can run
just video okay we want to run if we're
running video we can reach and engage
viewers on youtube and across the web
meaning other websites okay let's choose
display here so
we're gonna go ahead and just put our
website in there so our businesses
website
and when that loads up we're gonna have
a number of different options available
to us so here we can name our campaign
okay so here you can see brand awareness
and reach is the name of our campaign
and for now we're just gonna protest now
we have the opportunity to choose our
location here we're going to choose the
united states we have just like a search
campaign we also have languages and
options so with search you have
locations and languages same thing on
display so we're going to target english
as our language and what are we trying
to do what are we focusing on well we
want to get a product out there so we're
going to choose impressions viewable
impressions that's really what we want
to focus on we want people to see our ad
okay so an impression is the number of
times somebody sees your ad okay so we
have viewable impressions that's what we
want people to do we want them to see
our ad and if you take a peek over here
on the right side you can see your
targetings reach so we can reach over 10
billion plus in impressions meaning
that's a lot of eyeballs the number of
people looking at our ad right now is
over 10 billion plus okay so that's just
gives you the scope and some idea of how
big google's display network is so just
like search we could set a budget i'm
just gonna choose a hundred dollars for
now and i can choose how to deliver that
budget just like on search i have
standard accelerated i can ask google to
speed up the spend or i could just do
regular standard which means they're
going to spend my budget evenly over a
period of time over the course of the
day now remember with display network we
have different options on ad types we
have text ads rich media ads regular
image ads and video so we can rotate our
ads how we like so we could say hey look
i want to run my best performing ads
okay so that means i want google to
optimize for me meaning if i have an ad
that's performing better than some
others then i'm going to let google run
that one more and that's the one i would
recommend but you do have other options
here you can just have them rotate
evenly you can say hey optimize for
conversions but it's really remember our
goal here for the display is to get
impressions eyeballs we're not
interested in top of funnel conversions
in here we could say rotate evenly and
that's not supported for display so
really our best option here is prefer
best performing ads we want our best
performing ads to run okay we have an
option to schedule them we have an
option to start and okay and we have an
option to set a cap how many times we
want somebody to look at that ad so we
can limit how many times our ad is shown
to the same user okay so we're gonna let
google optimize how often your ads are
shown however we do have the option to
set that limit okay so we could set the
limit to x times per day for the entire
campaign or it could be for a particular
ad or aggro okay so we could set the
limit ourselves and we can let google
optimize for us here we have some
exclusions okay and then we have the
opportunity to set up our ad group now
the ad group is the same as the search
network the ad group on display is where
your settings are going to be your ads
are going to be located in your ad group
and now the important part we want to
get to audiences so if we're remarketing
we're going to choose our audience and
if we're not remarketing we still have
the opportunity to choose our audience
so if i'm a tech company and i just type
in tech then google is going to give me
some options here so here i can choose
some tech companies technology client
products new inventions etc or i can
choose some ideas that google has in
mind for audiences like they have an
in-market audience so this is based on
network systems and services network
management so the bottom line is google
is giving me suggestions on who i can
target my ad to okay that's what really
what this is choosing your audience now
you don't have to choose anything here
in fact you can just clear all and be
done with it now you can go down to
demographics now i can pick and choose
based on gender i can pick and choose
based on age parental status and
household income really depending on who
you're advertising to that's really what
it comes down to it okay so you have
demographics and you have audiences
audiences are really for remarketing so
again you can go with some of google's
recommended audiences or you can create
your own audience and we're going to
talk about that here in a minute but
this is all part of the setup for the
campaign so i'm saying hey these are the
demographics and these are the audiences
but if you're not remarketing you don't
necessarily have to go with an audience
okay once that's done you can set up a
bid just like you want on the search
network and then you have the option to
choose your ad so that's part of the
campaign setup so when you actually
choose your ad again you have different
options image ad okay rich media ad
video or text once you choose your ad
then you pretty much have your campaign
set up now we're gonna tweak it after we
set it up but that's pretty much the
steps in terms of setting up a display
campaign very similar to search in fact
minor differences really are choosing
your audience and choosing the ad type
that's really the main differences
between setting up a campaign on display
and setting up a campaign on search the
main differences now there are other
subtle differences but those are the
main ones so we talked about remarketing
to people who have been on our website
so going and showing our ad to somebody
who fits a particular description
meaning they looked at a product or they
looked at a particular page so if you're
gonna retarget the people then as a best
practice i would set up the audience in
google analytics so google analytics
talks to google ads in fact you can link
up the two in analytics so regardless of
whether you're creating a display
campaign or search campaign you want to
link up analytics with google ads so you
can see we've done that here okay now
that we've linked the two up we could
set up an audience in google analytics
for use on a remarketing campaign on
google's display network so here you can
see i have audiences set up if you want
to just create a new audience you can do
that so if i click new audience here
here i can choose choose returning users
or new users these are audiences that
google has set up by default i can
create a new one if i want so i could
say hey i want to target you know 18 to
24 year old males who
speak english for example
and who came from mobile so if i go here
technology i'm going to say including
mobile so that could be my audience so
anybody who fits that description of 18
to 24 year old coming to my website from
mobile who speaks english i'm going to
retarget them and you can go ahead and
save this so if i go ahead and click
apply i'm going to name my audience 18
24 year old male english mobile one
thing about remarketing on the display
network is you can choose how long
somebody stays on your list meaning how
long is that cookie gonna live so
depending on your funnel if they're
buying a car the funnel may be
six months long if they're buying a pair
of shoes then the funnel may be seven
days long maybe even shorter so really
depends on your business the default is
30 days so if you go with 30 days and
that means any 18 to 24 year old male
who speaks english and comes from mobile
is gonna get cookied and that cookie's
gonna live for 30 days so if i click
next step i can go ahead and publish it
i can say i want this to be available
in my google ads account so i'm going to
go ahead and pick my account and it'll
be available in that account so i'll
choose my account and then go ahead and
click publish so now this audience list
is going to be available for me to use
in my display campaign when i go to
choose my audience so if i go back to
google ads so google ads and google
analytics talk to one another why
because they're linked and so now when i
go to actually set up my ad group and
i'm choosing remarketing i can go ahead
and choose that audience list so for
example this campaign that's already set
up i can go ahead and choose to set up
another ad group with that particular
audience list so if i choose new ad
group and now i'm going to search for
the audience i just set up so here you
go i just did a search and here's my
audience i'm going to select my audience
and i'm going to now use this audience
in my ad group for my remarketing
campaign so now all i need to do is
align the right ad with this audience so
that's how remarketing works you choose
your audience list you set up your ads
remember you have different ad formats
video rich media image and text and the
whole idea beyond remarketing is you
know who your audience is you know what
you want to say to them so your ads
should really encompass that message the
message of what you want to say to that
particular group in this case 18 to 24
year old male who speak english who came
to your site from mobile so if you don't
really want to retarget somebody who's
been to your website you could certainly
still use the display network to your
advantage remember bottom of the funnel
the goal of our campaign is just get our
ad out there so that people recognize
our brand our services our product so
when you actually go to set up an ad
group you don't have to choose an
audience to retarget to you do have
other options so if i look at this ad
group here you can see i have image ads
already set up so where do i want these
image ads to appear so i do have options
available to me in the display network
so if i choose keywords then that means
if i go ahead and add a keyword then
what google is going to do is
contextually place my image ad on a
website that fits the description or
matches that keyword so if i add one or
two or three keywords then what google
is going to do is going to look at that
keyword and it's going to map
a website on the display network using
those keywords so that's keywords now
you got to be careful here because it's
a broad way of advertising meaning your
ads could appear on sites that you don't
necessarily deem relevant to those
keywords so you're allowing google to
match the website with the keywords you
choose so that's choosing keywords
audiences again audiences are there if
you want to retarget so if you're
retargeting you can
set up your audience in analytics in
fact that's the best practice so again
if i go back to analytics and i go back
to admin under my property audiences i
can go ahead and choose my audience to
be used in google ads so that's using
audiences on a display campaign on
google's display network when we're
setting up our campaign we had an option
to choose demographics
so we can exclude a demographic if we
wanted to we can always go back and
exclude a demographic just by removing
them from the ad group notice if we
choose all demographics we can actually
then see over a period of time in google
ads how many people based on this
particular age group or gender or
parental status or household income saw
our ad but not only saw our ad that
would be impressions but clicked on our
ad and how much they spent per click and
how many conversions so you have all
that data available to you in the
display network okay so that's
demographics i can also use topics so i
can take i can choose a particular topic
to advertise on so if i choose topics i
can choose a particular keyword find a
particular topic or i can drill down on
google's topic categories and
subcategories so here you can see
online communities if i choose that one
i can see there are other sub categories
under online communities okay i can
choose the whole category of science or
i can drill down to see what
subcategories are under science so i can
do that for any one of these topic
categories and if i choose a category
notice that's where google is going to
place my ad whatever i select again
notice upper right here i can take a
sneak peek at how many eyeballs
google is expecting to see my ad so here
by choosing astronomy and science i have
310 million impressions that's how many
potential eyeballs can look at my ad so
if you're setting up a display network
campaign you can choose keywords you can
choose demographics or you can choose
topics now if you decide not to go with
a topic then your last option here is
placements so i can pick and choose a
specific placement if there's a
particular website that i want to
advertise on let's just say
newyorktimes.com
or or
latimes.com or webmd.com
remember there are over two million
websites on google's display network so
i can pick and choose specifically where
i want my ads to be displayed now when
you're done choosing your audience or
your keywords or your demographics your
topics or your specific placements you
can always then go to your placements
and then click on where ads showed and
so now over this particular time frame
i'm going to be able to see where my ads
have been shown and so now i can see my
ads have been shown my mobile apps and
on particular websites now if you don't
like any of the particular websites that
your ad is showing on you can always
select it and you can always exclude it
can exclude it from the ad group or the
campaign okay so that's how you manage
where your ads are showing up on
google's display network again you can
go ahead and go to where ads are shown
under placements and over that
particular period of time google's going
to show you where your ads have been
shown and if you don't like that
placement then you can always just
exclude it or if you don't like the
performance meaning you're not getting
many impressions or you're not getting
many clicks or the click-through rate's
very low you can go ahead and exclude it
so this is an opportunity for you the
advertiser to take control over
where your ads are shown so in summary
when you set up a display campaign on
google's display network you have
options if you're remarketing you're
going to choose your audience you're
going to choose your audience using a
list you created in google analytics if
you're on the display network not
remarketing you have the option you can
choose a keyword and have google place
your ad on a website that fits the
description of that keyword you could
choose specific demographics you could
choose a topic or subtopic category or
you could choose a specific placement
okay those are all the options available
to you when you run your ad on google's
display network now let's go back and
take a look at some of the advantages of
the google display network so i just
went over with you how to actually
create a campaign in an ad group i
actually went over how to set up a
marketing campaign and set up a
marketing list and analytics and i went
over all the differences between the
search network and display but let's
really hone in on those advantages here
so with the display network we can
provide advanced targeting meaning i can
particularly point to a specific website
that i want to advertise on so that's
what i mean by advanced targeting or if
i don't want to advertise to 18 to 24
year olds or 25 to 34 year olds i can
exclude them or i can really pick and
choose a specific audience that i want
to remarket to so those are all examples
of advanced targeting and that's all
done within analytics or google ads so
advanced targeting enables you to target
the people that didn't engage with
previous campaigns and get in front of
people with look at like audiences that
can be created based on the audience you
usually advertise to so
in other words we can really hone in and
pick and choose who we want to advertise
to another advantage is relatively low
starting cost so what we mean by low
starting cost is normally on the search
network you're bidding on keywords and
some keywords can be very competitive
whereas on the display network you can
pick and choose who you want to
advertise to and pick and choose where
you want to advertise so you can really
advertise on websites that get a lot of
traffic may not have a lot of
competition and therefore may not cost
as much so if you compare it to
traditional forms of advertising like tv
or radio
display advertising reaching a large
broader audience is a lot cheaper okay
you can do advanced tracking meaning
when we talk about perform advanced
tracking we're talking about again
remarketing we can really pick and
choose who we want to remarket to and
cookie them and pick and choose how long
they are going to be cooking so we talk
about advanced tracking that's what
we're really talking about so we can
also talk about how many times our ad is
shown to somebody we really can pick and
choose how many times we want somebody
to actually see our ad on a site based
on performance okay let's take a look at
some other advantages the ability to
advertise your brand to a broader
audience and google has over 2 million
websites so we can pick and choose where
really where we want our ads to show up
again it could be by topic it could be
contextually via keywords or it can be
specific websites so we can create
demand for our product and what we mean
by that we can create really cool ads
remember rich media ads video ads these
are all engaging type of ads those are
ad types on the display network we
create engaging type of ads it's going
to appeal to somebody and they're going
to engage so we have that opportunity
just based on the different ad types of
course increasing web traffic we can't
say that enough if you're advertising on
google's display network you have the
opportunity to get your ad in front of
millions of people getting from our ads
in front of millions of people we have
the opportunity to get a lot of clicks
and we do have that wide range of
formats search network only has text ads
here we have text we have rich media we
have image we have video so all these
types of ad formats allow us to really
get our ads out there in a number of
different ways again we're marketing our
products and services of the big big big
advantage using google's display network
that's how we started today's webinar we
started talking about remarketing
because it's such a key feature so
somebody comes to our website and
doesn't do it we want them to do we can
cookie them and we can retarget them
with a more specific ad tailored to that
audience and today we're going to talk
about google analytics i'm very excited
to be with you today because google
analytics
is one of my favorite google platforms
and my favorite topics so let's talk
about what we're going to cover today
and we're going to start out with how to
set up a google analytics account and so
we're going to talk about everything
that entails including creating your
google analytics account we're going to
talk about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the prerequisite here when it
comes to setting up a google analytics
account is to have a google login and id
so when you actually go to google
analytics you need to be able to sign up
or sign in and so once you actually sign
in then you're going to go walk through
a series of steps but really that's
really all you need to get the account
going is a google id and login so if you
have a gmail account
or an other email account that you use
for other google products then you're
good to go that's all you need to do so
when you actually go to sign up for
google analytics you're going to be
asked to set up a new account and these
are the series of steps you're going to
walk through or go through to set up a
new google analytics account so you're
going to choose an account name and then
you're going to choose a property name
okay so the account name can be anything
you want it to be the name your company
your name whatever you want to name it
the property name is really the website
name so what website are we talking
about so here i'm going to set up a
fictitious website name for now it's
called demo simply learn so the url for
this website demo simply learn is going
to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
and analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the
most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and i'm gonna talk about why that's
important here in a minute and then
you're gonna choose your time zone and
the time zone is also important because
that's when the day starts in analytics
and the day ends based on that time zone
so the data that google analytics
collects starts and ends with that time
zone so very important to choose the
time zone your business is located in
okay and then you have some additional
options here okay so you have some
settings and so the first setting is to
allow google products and services so if
you opt into this then basically what
google is going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
i would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by google
it doesn't hurt to hear from google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what google
is going to do is share your data that
it collects on your website in this case
demo.simplylearn.com
it's going to share that data
anonymously
with others in the industry in this case
jobs and education and because you've
opted in it's going to do the same exact
thing for you it's going to share
anonymous data on other websites in the
same industry and the benefit of that is
we get to see
what other websites or how other
websites are performing compared to ours
what's the benchmark in our industry and
so the benchmarking to me is important
and i'm gonna go over that in a few
minutes when we go over the different
reports but to me i would always opt
into benchmarking because this is the
only report google provides in analytics
about how others in your industry is
performing versus your website okay so
it's a way to compare your website
performance against others in the same
industry the other options here
technical support and account specialist
i would also recommend you opt into
those because then it allows you to
basically
google allow google access to your
account and they'll be able to help you
if you occur or run into any issues so
these are the options in setting up a
google analytics account it's very
simple very easy to do you're just
entering in a few fields note that we
talking about a website right now so i'm
talking about demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
id now i'm going to accept the terms of
service i'm going to accept another
terms and service in relation to data
protection i'm going to click accept
once i accept i'm going to be able to
get some tracking code the tracking id
is the id associated with your account
and so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account id
starts with ua and it's gonna be this
number here now the dash one is the
property you set up so in this case i
set up
demo.simplylearn.com if i wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then i can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property i set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
etc depending on how many properties i
set up so by default i set up one
property so my first property id is dash
one if i set up a second property the
same account number is just gonna have a
dash two and that's important because
that id that account and property id is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking id up here
notice the tracking id in the snippet of
code now this snippet of code needs to
go on every page of your website that
you want to track and you don't have to
put it on every page but if you want to
track website behavior on every page
your website then it needs to go on
every page of your website so if you're
using a you know platform like drupal
or joomla or even more popular platform
like wordpress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
google analytics plug-in to wordpress
for example and then just simply plug in
in the id now there's an alternative to
adding the google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's google tag
manager so google tag manager is the way
i would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with google tag manager i would
recommend watching the
youtube video we have on google tag
manager you can just go to youtube type
in simply learn google tag manager and
this will give you a nice overview of
what google tag manager is and how it
works but basically this is the way i
would go and i would recommend that in
addition having google analytics you set
up a google tag manager account and then
that way you can put the tracking code
in google tag manager so if i go to
google tag manager and i just go into an
account on tag manager i can just simply
put in the google analytics id right
into tag manager and so if i have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way i don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if i
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
google analytics id associated with tag
manager if you can associate it with tag
manager then that's the easier route to
go versus putting code on your website
okay so again take a look at the video
we have on youtube for google tag
manager that's the route i would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
google tag manager or through a plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to
basically understand how google
analytics works then i would recommend
getting access to google analytics demo
account and so if you just type in and
search google analytics demo account
basically what you're going to do you're
going to choose the first listing there
and you're gonna go to demo account so
if you have a google analytics or google
login then all you need to do is click
on access demo account and so what
google's gonna do is put this demo
account into your account and so it's
going to look something like this so if
i click on demo account here it's going
to add to my google analytics account so
i'm going to have then access to the
demo account from google and google
analytics so i would recommend going
this route here if you're not familiar
you're not sure what you're getting
yourself into so think of the demo
account as kind of a test drive you're
test driving google analytics before you
even add any code to your website so
again all you need is a google account
and if you have a google account and you
add the demo account to your google
analytics account you're going to be
able to see how analytics works okay and
so that's what i would also recommend so
if you're not ready to start adding code
to your website then what you can do is
just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around google
analytics to see the different types of
reports it has to offer now when you do
actually set up a google analytics
account you're going to have some
settings that you're going to want to
pay attention to so when you set up the
account you have the account name and
then you have a property so under each
property you have by default you're
going to have one view and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learned so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings in
future webinars for advanced google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to google analytics anything
from adding users to your google
analytics account your google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up google ads
you can
you know set up remarketing lists
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to google
analytics but so no those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you can
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in google
analytics so if i'm an admin and i'm
looking at the google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
i click on the real time report and i
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users i actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here i can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here i can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring source if they came from
say search or social i can see the
source there and i can see what pages
they're active on and then here i can
see what locations where they're located
and so if i want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview i can
certainly do that if i go to locations
under real time i could see a majority
of my users are coming from the united
states okay where are they coming from
i'll just click on traffic sources and
here i could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's google
it's either paid search or organic
search so i can see here it's organic
then i can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so i
could see currently have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the google's women's white tee page
so forth and so on now most importantly
if you have event tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if i click on
events i'll be able to see what events
are firing so here i can see we have
event tracking set up and i can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here i can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and i could see
that these are the current events that i
have currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if i
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes i can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now i can see
i had one active user who entered the
checkout so that's goal number four so
in analytics you can have up to 20 goals
and so here i can see we have goal
number four has already had one active
user and so if i look at the last 30
minutes i can see i still have only one
goal over the last 30 minutes and that
was somebody who entered the checkout so
that's real time reporting in summary it
just gives you an idea of what's
currently happening on your website and
so for me ideally if i'm launching a
campaign or let's just say you do a new
website redesign and you want to see how
users performing and behaving then real
time is a good option for you so you can
see how things are happening in real
time now let's jump down to audience
reporting so if i click on audiences
it's just right underneath real time i'm
going to see a number of different
reports available to me under audience
and so
let's click on the audience overview
report so
audience reporting basically allows us
to get a sense of who is coming to our
website when i say who is coming to our
website it doesn't necessarily have to
be a specific person in fact google
doesn't allow personally identifiable
information in google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information etc however we
can still paint a nice picture on who is
coming to our website meaning what
country
city or state did they come from what
language what device did they get to our
website from how old were they okay were
they male or female or other what
interest did they have what browser did
they use so we can paint a nice picture
based on all this information that
google analytics is providing us under
audience so if i go to audience overview
here i can see i have all these
different options available to me to get
a basic understanding of who is coming
to our website so for example i could
see a majority of the people coming to
our website speak english and are from
the united states okay in fact that
represents 61
of the users and so google analytics
does a great job of giving me an overall
percentage so if i have a 100 of the
users i could see 61 percent of those
users represented english-speaking users
from the united states seven percent
represented english-speaking users from
great britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the google analytics tracking
script to your website what's going to
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're going to get
cookied if it's the first time they've
been to your website what google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking in analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here i can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here i can see april 6
through april 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here i can see about 23 24
are returning users okay so i can get a
good breakdown of what type of users are
coming am i driving new traffic am i
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay i can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if i skip down now to demographics i can
click on overview and when that report
loads i can see now under demographics
overview i can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here i can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if i
want to change this date range i could
simply do that i can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and i can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year i'm
going to choose the last 30 days i'm
going to click apply now i'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here i'm looking at the last 30
days and i can see almost 47 percent of
my users were in their age range of 25
to 34. now when it comes to gender i can
see
66 percent represent males so i can get
a breakout of gender and age as well as
interest i can click on interest and
look at the overview there
and see what the interest is of the
users who are coming to my site based on
in-market segments or affinity i can
also choose language and location so if
i want to know exactly where my users
are located when they're coming to my
website i can click on location and here
i can get a breakout 43 percent of the
users of the last 30 days were from the
united states more importantly i can
align
my audience with goals and we'll talk
about goals here in a minute but here i
can see if i have an e-commerce website
i can see of those 43 percent 0.29 of
those converted or purchased something
and that equates to 94 transactions so i
can get a good sense of not only how
many users are coming from a specific
country but are those users converting
if i click on mobile and mobile to me is
one of those reports i tend to spend a
bit of time on because i want to know
what devices users are coming to my
website and so for my website here or
this is the google demo website i can
see mobile represents approximately 27
of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic so
for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile is definitely a
majority of what people use nowadays
that's how people start their day that's
how they transact via mobile whether
that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on behavior so google
analytics is telling me that yes i have
approximately 27 of my traffic of the
last 30 days came from mobile
how are they interacting with my website
so if i look across this report i'm
going to be able to see different
metrics so if i'm measuring specific
metrics against my dimension in this
case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile i can see that the
bounce rate is approximately 48 percent
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case from mobile landed on a page
they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an ecommerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48
mobile in desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41
now if i look a little bit further at
engagement i can see how many pages on
average do mobile users look at so
versus desktop it's a little bit lower
you can see 3.86
on desktop it's 4.5 now if i look a
little bit further in engagement i want
to be able to measure how long somebody
from mobile stays on the website if
they're bouncing at 48
but they're also looking at 3.8 pages
3.9 almost four pages per session then
that means in this report analytics is
telling me they're spending about two
minutes on the site and interestingly
enough i can see that mobile over the
last 30 days had more transactions so 51
transactions versus 34 transactions from
desktop and interestingly enough the
commerce conversion rate is at point two
nine percent that's higher than desktop
at point zero seven it's lower than
tablet but it's higher than desktop and
mobile has the most transactions and
since they have the most transactions
they have the most revenue at 2 380. so
yes the engagement isn't exactly as
great as it is as desktop but we can see
that people are still purchasing with
their mobile devices so it's something
to keep an eye on and mobile is
something i definitely look at in fact
since it's such an important report one
thing you can do in analytics is if you
actually like a report and you think
you're going to look at that report
multiple times then you can simply just
go ahead and click save at the top here
so if i click save i'm going to enter a
name for this report i'm just going to
call it mobile report and click ok and
then what's going to happen is it's
going to be located under save reports
and save reports is located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if i close that
up you can see audience real-time
customization if i click on
customization if i click on save reports
i should be able to see my save report
here and i do so here i can see mobile
report if i click on it i can simply go
to the report i was looking at before i
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics because it allows
you to quickly access a report that
you've saved in the past so let's take a
look at one more report under audience
and let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we were setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and i recommended you do so
and so if you did actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see
how your site compares to others in the
same industry so if i click on
benchmarking and then click on channels
what i'm actually able to do now is
compare my website with others in the
same industry so if i go back to say
jobs in education and i choose education
all education as my industry vertical i
should be able to see websites that are
in the same particular industry and how
i compare with those websites so i'm
choosing all countries i can narrow that
down if i wanted to i can just search
for the united states i can choose a
specific state and then i can choose a
particular site size so here i'm
choosing sites by daily session so these
are sites that have an average of 5 000
to almost 10 000 sessions a day and so
in this vertical education in the united
states sites that have 5 000 to
99999 sessions per day that means that
there are approximately 310 web
properties contributing to this report
okay based on this criteria i chose now
if my site is similar meaning if i'm in
the united states if i'm in education
and i'm receiving 5000 to 99999
per day then i'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now google's
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular industries and verticals
and so now i'm looking at a channel
report so if i want to see how i compare
to others in my industry then i can go
ahead and see by channel for example am
i driving as much traffic as others in
my industry and you can see i'm not in
fact i'm 76 77 percent worse in terms of
the amount of traffic being driven from
organic search so anything in red is
going to show as a negative result a
negative comparison whereas something in
green is a positive comparison so if i
look at engagement i can see that i
might not be driving as much traffic but
i can see that the pages per session are
better than the site average or the
industry average i can see if i go over
again looking just at organic search i
can see the bounce rate is better than
the industry average so the channel
report under benchmarking allows you to
measure how you compare to others in
your industry and you could do so by
looking at location and devices so if
you opted into benchmarking when you set
up your account then you'll be able to
compare your website against others in
your industry
in your country region and based on the
size of your website in terms of how
many visitors or sessions you're getting
per day so let's go from audience to
acquisition so if audience is who is
coming to your website acquisition
allows us to see how the traffic was
driven to your website so how did these
users get to our website and so under
acquisition if we click on overview
we'll be able to see an overview of how
users whether they're returning or new
came to our website and so what
analytics does by default is they have a
number of default channels and when we
say channels we mean analytics is
grouping different channels based on how
users got to your website meaning how
did users get to our website did they
come via organic search meaning did they
type something into google and find you
in the organic listing analytics also
groups users based on whether they came
to your site directly meaning did they
type in the url directly into the
browser or did they bookmark your
website and come back via the bookmark
so they're grouping users under direct
they also group users under referral
meaning do they come from another
website they group users by social do
they come from a social media platform
like twitter or facebook if you're
running paid search
meaning if you're running paid search on
say google then do they come from paid
search ads now if you're running display
ads on say google's network google's
display network that's a default channel
so analytics will group users there so
if they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default google analytics groups users
on how they came to your website via
these default channels and so i can see
how many users came to the site from
each channel now if i want to drill down
on this report i can click on all
traffic and then if i click on all
traffic i can go to channels i can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now i can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users i can see
that number is about 56
so 56 of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so
just like we looked at with the
audience reports when it came to mobile
we can also look at engagement by
channel so just like mobile we looked at
bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how google determines the
conversion rate they basically take
the number of transactions and divide
that by sessions so that means that over
the last 30 days organic search drove 38
123 sessions and of those 38 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in revenue so i'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
i can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by channel you'll
also get a summary so here i can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so i could see over the last 30
days i've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that at those 54 000 users i had 70 000
sessions i could see my average bounce
rate was 43
the pages per session were just over
four and the average session duration
how long did somebody stay on my website
on average about two minutes and 55
seconds the average conversion rate was
0.14 and at a total 97 transactions
totaling 5500 dollars okay and that's
all over the last 30 days so any report
you look at in analytics is going to
have a summary and note that any report
allow you to save it so if it's a report
you think you're going to go back and
look at at a future date then you simply
just have to click on the save button
conversely if you don't want to save it
you can simply just export it so you can
export it as a pdf if i click on pdf
it's going to allow me to export that as
a pdf now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
google sheet you can export it as an
excel or you can export it as a comma
delimited file so here you can see i can
save it as a pdf if i want to and if i
click ok it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my choosing and
then i can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running google ads note that you
can connect google ads to analytics and
this is key because now i can see how
many people are coming from google ads
to my website and are they converting
now this is important because with
google ads i'm actually paying for the
click so you can see here i'm running a
report based on campaign data so i could
see what campaigns are driving traffic
how much i'm paying per click and you
can see on average i'm paying 34 cents
per click and then more importantly i
want to be able to see if they're
converting so you can see i've spent 810
over the last 30 days and received 858
in revenue so you want to make sure that
you link up your google ads account to
your google analytics account for this
very reason you want to be able to see
how your google ads campaigns perform
once the users get to your website and
so i want to see if they're engaging and
i want to see if they're converting so
there are all sorts of reports under
google ads so you can look at it by
keywords by search queries by hour of
the day if you're running display
campaigns you can look at display
targeting so there's all sorts of
reports under google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if i go to
campaigns i can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
facebook whether it be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say twitter or
instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you run an e-commerce platform or if you
have goals set up so you'll be able to
look at how your campaigns are not one
not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
behavior reports are going to actually
show you
how users behaved once they got to your
website once they landed on a page on
your website how did they behave so when
we looked at audience we got a sense of
who is coming with acquisition we get a
sense of how the traffic got to our
website did they come from organic
direct social etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behave once they landed on a
page on our website and so if i go to
overview under behavior now i'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many page views i've had and a page you
is simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here i can
see in this graph how many page views
i've had again over the last 30 days and
if i look further at my overview report
i can see the specific pages and how
many pages they've had and i can also
look at some other metrics okay the
average bounce rate the average time on
page i can look at the exit rate which
means how many people actually exited or
the percentage of people who exited from
that page so i can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if i click on site
content and i click on all pages then
i'm going to look at a report by page
this is my dimension this is what i'm
measuring my page and now i can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other pages then every page that user
looks at is going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to a to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page for you but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where page uses accumulation of how many
times the page was viewed in the same
session so in other words you're always
going to have more page views than
unique pages okay so this gives me a
sense of how my page is performed so
again i can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low
if the exit percentage of exit rate is
high then you probably want to do
something with that page now these are
all pages but if i jump down to landing
pages my landing page report is showing
me how many people actually landed on
that page and so here i can see under my
landing page report i can see the home
page had 36 000 17 sessions in the last
30 days that's how many people landed on
the home homepage so
here i can see 71 percent were new
sessions meaning that i had a lot of new
users who landed on the home page in
fact 25 000 or 52
of the people who landed on the homepage
were new i could see the bounce rates
about 42 percent but of those who didn't
bounce they went on to look at about 4.5
pages per session and spent about three
minutes on the site and the one thing i
like about the landing page report is i
can also see whether that particular
page in this case the home page did it
help contribute to a goal or conversion
and in this case i can see of those 36
000 sessions i had 22
transactions totaling 1200 in revenue
and that's an e-commerce conversion rate
of 0.06
so the home page over the last 30 days
contributed to
0.06
of the revenue so this gives you an idea
of when somebody lands on your website
and they land on a page is that page
helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed's
important because what google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
i would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
not have the best infrastructure you
name may not even be on the best
internet network meaning you're on a
cell network or the wi-fi is not that
great or you can be on a page that just
has a lot of images or a lot of code
that may slow it down so there are other
factors involved and so what google
analytics does is show you what those
factors are so here i can see by browser
what the average load time is if i want
to look at country i could see what
country is contributing to the low time
now the great thing about the site speed
report is if i go to speed suggestions
okay what speed suggestions is going to
do is it's going to show me the page
load time by page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where i can
actually click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example i can look at this particular
page here this google redesign shop by
brand slash youtube page line number
five if i look at line number five i can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
google is recommending seven total
suggestions so if i click on 7 total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another google report
called page speed insights and page
speed insights is going to give me some
information about what i can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so look at this
site speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load times very important it's so
important that i'm even going to save it
so i'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click ok and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in google analytics because
what the conversions reporting allows us
to do is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website and so in google analytics we
have the opportunity to set up goals now
you have the opportunity to set up 20
goals in your google analytics view and
so to set up a goal okay so you're going
to click on admin and under the view
you're going to see goals and so if you
don't even have goals the first step is
to create goals and so you have four
different goal types and analytics so
you have pages per session so how many
pages per session is so if your goal is
set to say three or two if somebody
actually looked at two or three pages
per session it's going to count as a
goal okay so if i look here i could see
i have pages per session set at 10. so
that means that if a user came to the
site looked at more than 10 pages per
session then it's going to count as a
goal another goal type is destination so
destination means that if somebody
actually went to a specific page then
it's going to count as a goal and in
this case i can see here that the goal
is set to this particular page here and
so when somebody actually lands on that
page it's going to count as a goal now
there are two other goal types we can
look at one is duration so just like
pages per session in our previous
example if somebody looked at 10 pages
per session it's going to count as a
goal with duration it's based on time so
in this particular case if you set up a
duration goal and the duration is set to
say one minute and 30 seconds then that
means if a user comes to my website and
they spend at least one minute and 30
seconds then it's going to count as a
goal okay and then the fourth type of
goal in google analytics is an
event-based goal so when you set up
event tracking you could turn that event
into a goal so if somebody clicks on say
the submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you could
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's gonna count as a goal so you
have four different goal types in google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if i look at goals overview i can be
able to see how many total goal
completions i've had so if i want to
look at it by goal i can just choose the
goal option here so if i want to look at
for example
goal 2 engaged users this was the pages
per session i can see that i had a
conversion rate of 10
meaning that i had 7 000 of all the
users who came to the website 7 000 goal
completions meaning 7 106 users looked
at 10 pages or more on my website and so
that's how you want to be able to
measure whether users wherever they're
coming from whoever they are whatever
pages they look at you want to be able
to look at the conversion reports to see
if they're actually converting based on
the goals you've set up whether that's
pages per session
duration destination or event goal
conversion tracking reports can help you
measure
who is actually converting and the great
thing about google analytics here is
that i can actually see
by segment so the default segment in a
segment is just looking at a specific
user set so the default segment is
always all users however i can choose a
different segment so if i want to choose
instead of all users if i want to choose
mobile traffic i can select mobile
traffic hit apply so i'm actually now
looking at a subset of data i'm looking
at mobile traffic so if all the mobile
users have come to my site i can see
1400 engaged or looked at 10 pages or
more okay and that's a 7
conversion rate so the great thing about
google analytics is you have the
opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rate of each goal
but you can also change the segment of
that particular goal to see who exactly
converted okay another report i like
under conversions is the multi-channel
funnel report so if i click on
multi-channel funnel basically what this
allows me to do is see how different
channels work together to convert so
remember the channel reporting we looked
at under acquisition here i can see now
how different channels work together to
drive the conversion so if i look at
three channels direct organic and
referral i can see all three together
drive two percent of the conversions if
i look at direct and referral twelve and
a half percent if i look at direct and
organic twelve point two four percent so
i can see how different channels work
together and so if i look at top
conversion paths as an example i can
actually see
what channels how channels work together
to drive the conversion so in this
example i can see over the last 30 days
that my top channel grouping was direct
times two meaning that somebody came to
the website directly meaning they typed
in the url in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
convert it so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure
if that channel actually did contribute
at a later point and in this case we
could see organic search drove traffic
that didn't convert but that traffic
came back a second time via direct and
did convert so that's our second best
channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only a channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance now if you have any comments
or questions about any of the reports we
covered feel free to comment underneath
this video we're definitely going to
have more webinars in the future about
specific analytics settings that we
didn't get to today and other types of
analytics reports and features that we
didn't get to today today we're going to
talk about how to set up goals in google
analytics so
for this particular webinar we're going
to jump into google analytics directly
and spend all of our time there because
it's about learning practical
applications so
goals are important goals uh let me just
say this goals are in analytics
something that should be aligned with
your business and
we call goals that are aligned with your
business kpis are key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in google analytics because if
you're using google analytics you want
to measure everything against a goal so
without further ado
let's jump right into google analytics
so if i go to google analytics and i log
in okay what i want to do
is go down to admin click on admin here
and admin will take you to basically a
screen that looks like this where you
have a account column you have your
property column and then you have your
view column now the view column is where
you're going to go to set up goals okay
so every view
in every property has up to 20 goals
okay so by default in analytics you're
going to have at least one view for your
property so if i have a property i'm
gonna have at least one view but if i
happen to set up multiple views like you
see here then i know for every view i
set up i have 20 goals to work with so
where are those goals so under the view
i'm going to click on goals and now i
could see i have 20 at my disposal now
you can see here
by clicking on the recording column i
can see i have in this particular
property this particular view i have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation at least
have one goal again when you set up a
goal you're gonna measure everything in
analytics against that goal okay so
in this case we have five particular
goals we're measuring so we have five
active out of 20 total so
if i don't no longer want to use a goal
i could simply just turn it off if i
want to continue using it just turn it
on okay it's that simple you could turn
on and off goals so here i already have
five set up so if you want to set up a
new goal the one thing you need to know
in google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level i would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure
whoever is in charge of google analytics
for your organization or if you're in
charge okay you simply just want to go
to user management and user management
you want to make sure the email address
you're using to log into google
analytics has at least edit permissions
so you're going to need edit permissions
to add new goals so
i have edit permissions i'm going to go
to goals and i want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal do you have an e-commerce site
is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that i'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red cta button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or
reading review downloading something
sharing something you could choose all
of these options here what i normally do
is choose custom ninety-nine percent of
the time i'm just going to choose custom
it doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so
we already have in mind what type of
goal we want to set up so for example if
somebody goes to
fill out a form submission and they go
to a thank you page after that well
what's the url of that thank you page we
want to be able to track how many people
go to that page because we know
if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if i go to continue i'm going to name my
goal first so i'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an id so notice this is goal
id 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
10 11 through 15 16 through 20 into goal
sets so for example goal 16 through 20
is part of goal set four and why does
google analytics combine these goals
into different goal sets well because
it's easier to ma measure and look at
data by goal sets so for example if i
jump into any report here if i go to all
traffic channels and i want to measure
how many goals by channel i can look at
it by goal set so if i have goal set 1
selected then i know any goal i have
active in there between goal id 1
through goal id 5 i'm going to be able
to see those goals in goal set one and
now i'm going to be able to measure
every goal i have active and goal set
one against the channel so if i choose
goal set 2 whatever goals are active
there goal set 3 etc notice i don't have
any goals 16 through 20 active that are
in goal set for therefore i don't have
that option available to me so back to
admin bottom left navigation again goals
okay we want to measure somebody going
to the thank you page we have edit
access we're going to choose custom as
our goal set up we're going to type in a
goal name i'm just going to say thank
you okay this is goal 15. now this is
the important part google analytics has
four different goal types destination
duration pages per session or screens
per session so screens per session is
related to mobile because google
analytics measures mobile app activity
and then you have an event so we're
going to cover all four of these but for
the sake of this simple example i'm
going to choose destination why because
if somebody goes to that thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page as the goal the goal url
so for example destination is my choice
i'm going to click continue now this is
where i'm going to put the url so if my
url is just simply thank you.html i can
just go ahead and put thank you.html
or if it's just thank you then i can
just do thank you depends on the website
depends on the uri structure so whatever
that url is that's what you're going to
put in and when you're done you can
verify it so what google analytics does
is actually
will verify over the last seven days if
anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see zero percent conversion rate so
that tells us that if this is the
correct url then we've had zero percent
people go to that page this is just an
example however if you didn't see a
conversion then you might want to make
sure you check the url here that you put
in and if you do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so google
analytics actually has options so
we're saying thank you is equal to so
the destination url is equal to thank
you or thank you.html or thank you.esp
or whatever that thank you page is okay
you do have options so if you have a
long url you could say begins with and
you could say begins with say thank you
so this is the logic we're gonna say hey
if anybody goes to a url that begins
with thank you then count it as a goal
or you could say
equals to so if anybody goes to a url
that equals two thank you then count it
as a goal you have one more option here
regular expression so google analytics
understands the language of regular
expressions so regular express
expressions are just special characters
used to communicate with google
analytics in order to hone in on exactly
what you're trying to track so we can
always say you know starts with or ends
with so we can you know use characters
like the dollar sign ends with or begins
with so we can always do that so you can
use regular expressions as well if
you're familiar with regular expressions
if you're not then you don't have to use
them but there are special characters
where that you can insert in that are
used as regular expression so if you're
not familiar with regular expression
don't choose that option you can choose
the other option of equals to or begins
with now note that on all three of these
options i didn't put the domain so if my
domain is ama dash foundation.org
slash and then thank you i don't need to
put the domain because analytics is
already knows what domain we're tracking
so you don't have to put in the domain
here when you're entering in in this
case the google url so you can omit the
domain so when you put in that url
you know that you have three options to
work with and then you always always
want to verify
that goal url you always want to verify
it because if you see zero percent
conversion and in this case of the last
seven days then that should tell you
something either your goal is not set up
correctly or you just don't have any
conversions either way you want to
double check that now when it comes to
the destination url goal you do have an
option here for funnel so if i turn on
funnel then that means i have the
ability to track how people went through
my funnel so if i have a
cart and i want to be able to check how
many people go in and out of the cart
then i have the option of adding
specific pages as part of the cart so we
could say you know step one
which is basically cart we could say
step two
is
billing information that could be slash
billing we could see step three is
shipping information slash shipping and
then step four could be
you know confirm and that could be slash
confirmation so whatever your url
structure is for your cart and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all i'm doing is putting a
series of steps with urls as each step
and why do i want to do that because i
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that i've created okay
so here i could see this is my funnel
that i've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination url so the
funnels available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step require so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if i turn that off then i'm measuring
the funnel through each step meaning
that i can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then i'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert okay
google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need to add a value
but in this case let's just say your
non-profit organization and you're
collecting donations and on average over
the past year every donation that
somebody contributed was equal to five
dollars well you can just go ahead and
put five dollars in there as the
value for that goal so that means that
if somebody did go to in this example
slash thank you and convert analytics is
going to count it as a goal and then
assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're not
e-commerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your b2b and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination url goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all goal types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination url is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination url goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel
information well you want to get out of
admin you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization so based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because i could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here i can see the first
step is the store front page so
over this particular period of time i
had 84 sessions enter the storefront
page so out of those 84 i can see 21
left the storefront page 63 went on to
the next step in the final which is the
cart page i can then see 24 people went
on to the cart page directly and five
exited the site altogether okay so that
gave me 87 total and from 87 i saw that
82 went on to the next page with the
next step what analytics does is they
give you a percentage so in the first
step we had 63 move on to the car page
out of 84 that's 75 percent so from the
cart page to the create your account
page we had 94 percent move on so
we didn't have anybody entering the
create your account page we didn't have
anybody leave the create your account
page so if 82
82 create your account and then we have
82 move on to the payment page so that's
okay we have one exit so if it 81 that
proceeded to be on the payment page
which was purchased so 81 of 82 is 98
and we started with 84 so that gave us
plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so that gave us a 75 percent
funnel conversion rate so 75 percent of
the people who entered in the funnel
went on to purchase okay so don't be
confused with the overall ecommerce
conversion rate so 75 is the funnel
conversion rate the overall conversion
rate for this particular goal is
18.45
over this particular period of time why
because that takes into account all
sessions that have won to the website so
of all traffic went on to convert but
those that did go into the funnel 75
converted so
that's a look at the funnel so if you
set up a funnel that's what it's going
to look like you have the option to
measure everything from step one and on
or measure as traffic goes in and out of
the funnel so the purpose of this is
we're gonna be able to see where traffic
drops off how effective our funnel is
what pages we need to address in that
funnel okay so that's the whole point of
the funnel and the funnel is available
with the destination url goal so if i go
back to admin if i go back to goals
under the view i can actually see what
that funnel looks like so here we chose
regular expression so this is what the
url is okay you can see our funnel in
each of the steps we have set up notice
we're using regular expressions here and
then if we verify this goal we could see
over the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination url goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about
is pages per session so if you're not
sure what type of goal to set up for
your website at the very least you
should try and set up either duration
related goal or pages per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session so basically what this
goal is going to allow us to measure
is for example if we set the goal to
three pages per session then we're going
to be able to measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if i
open up the goal here i can see three
pages per session is what we're naming
it so basically what we're asking
analytics to do is anything greater than
two pages which would be three and
beyond count as a goal so if anybody
comes to the site looks at more than two
pages three pages or more then it's
going to count as a goal and so here we
can verify it so if we verify it over
the last seven days we could see a four
point one two percent conversion rate
and that tells me that four percent of
my traffic over the last seven days
looked at at least three pages or more
so
you're probably asking yourself well
what number should i put in for the
actual
variable so in this case we see two well
what you want to do is you want to look
at
on average let's just say year to date
you want to make sure you have
statistical significance so you want to
look at a period of time so if you go to
analytics go to audience okay and then
if you go to overview and if i change my
date range to year to date i could see
on average right now i have 1.21
pages per session so that's on average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically
measure
at a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do
is get people to stay on the site longer
look at pages
more
during their session so look at more
pages and so
we want to be able to see
what segment of the audience is looking
at more pages what channels driving
traffic that's looking at more pages
what pages are contributing to more
pages per session so the whole idea is
you want to hone in on what your goal is
and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea behind google
analytics is to improve website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just two it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're gonna choose three now you can
choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 i
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and i probably wouldn't choose
two so i'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session
we can measure how long somebody stays
on the website and we could set up a
goal for that so in this case i have a
goal set for one minute 30 seconds so my
goal type is duration so if i click
continue then basically i'm asking
analytics in this case anybody who stays
more than one minute and 30 seconds on
the website count it as a goal and so
before you actually put in the number of
hours minutes and seconds you want to
look at that average so if you go back
to audience overview here i can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here i can see over the last
seven days if i verify this particular
goal i can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stayed greater than
one minute and 30. and so the whole
point is you can hone in because this is
a goal i can go in this is goal okay
this is a goal here
and so i could see that this is goal 13.
so now i can go
to acquisition as an example i can go to
channels as an example since this is a
goal this is gold 13 so that would be in
goal set three
so i can actually see what channel
is basically driving that goal okay in
other words what channel is driving
traffic that is staying on the side at
least one minute and 30 seconds
and so that's the whole idea behind
goals so likewise for pages per session
we can go into channels and here i can
see
we've have a
over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here i could see
for example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here i can see
social media has a 10 percent so i could
see that or people coming from organic
search are staying on the site longer or
they're looking at more pages than any
other channel so
just like duration or destination or any
goal you set up you can measure that
goal against any dimension just because
it's engagement doesn't mean you can't
you absolutely can and so the whole
point of engagement really goals is to
figure out what's driving traffic to the
site but what traffic is engaging so you
want to be able to pinpoint that so you
can improve website performance now the
fourth goal type available
in google analytics is an event so if
you click on new goal you close custom
click continue you have the option to
choose an event so
an event is something that you can
measure on your website
that analytics can't measure by default
so if you want to measure pdf downloads
or clicks on buttons or clicks on play
buttons on a video or click on a submit
button or click on an external link i
mean you can measure pretty much
anything with an event
then you want to be able to turn that
event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event
so if i go to for example
this particular website here and i want
to measure how many times
somebody clicks on the donate now button
well if i met i can measure that as an
event so when you set up an event in
analytics you have to actually assign a
category and an action for that event so
that's the first thing you need to do
when you identify an event related goal
first you need to set up the event in
order to set up the event you need to
assign a category in action okay so once
you identify what you want to track as
an event on your website you're actually
going to go in a tag manager or have
your webmaster go into tag manager and
set up a tag and in that tag they're
going to assign that particular category
in action and so here you can see we
have this set up our category is named
donate now and our action is click and
that's what we want to do we want to
measure how many people click on that
donate now button so anytime somebody
does that then the category donate now
is going to appear in analytics with the
action click so when you actually do set
up an event you can go into analytics
and
you can test that event so if i go to
the website and i click donate now okay
the reason why i have this as an event
is because i'm taking to
a third party website to handle the
donations so here i can go into
analytics and now i can see a category
is being fired for header donate with
the action click so that's my category
and that's my action so that category in
action is what is firing after somebody
clicks on the donate now button so if i
want to turn this event into a goal i
can easily do that now that i've set up
the event now that i've identified the
category in action i want to go back to
admin and
set up the event with these parameters
in place so just turns out we already
have the goal set up so let's go through
how this goal was set up so first we
chose custom we chose event we gave it a
name so as a best practice when you
actually set up a goal as an event or
turn an event into a goal i would add
the prefix event colon to it and then
that way when you're identifying goals
and you're reporting you know it's an
event so i'm going to click continue
and now that i've actually have set up
the event already in google tag manager
i've given it a category i give it an
action okay see here you can see we have
a regular expression set up so anything
with the header donate or donate is
going to fire this goal so over the last
seven days i have a 0.81 conversion rate
okay i could have easily put in
equals two and put in whatever the
action what or the category which is
donate now
or i could have put action equals click
i could have done that as well so let me
show you another example here so if i do
this
custom continue event donate now here's
my goal id
it's going to be an event so all i need
to do is put in the category in action
so donate now and then click so that's
all i have to do and that's my goal so i
can verify it okay to see if anybody's
fired it and basically that's what i
need to do to turn that event into a
goal okay so you need to set up for an
event first you need to identify the
event set it up in google tag manager
which is another platform and once
you've done that
then you have your category in action
once you have your category in action
you're again going to go into analytics
and then simply put in that category and
action into the appropriate fields to
set up your event related goal now all
events don't have to be turned into a
goal if you actually do set up an event
and you're not worthy of a goal meaning
it's not a kpi or doesn't align with
your business goals well don't fret you
can always just go to behavior okay you
can always go to events
you can always go to overview and
measure your events that way so here you
can see
all of our events that are fired now we
do have this one turned into a goal so
if it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under behavior so the
point i'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is that
category all you need is that action and
so
so one final note on that event related
goal
just like any other goal you can add a
value okay so
if i have an event set up i can choose
to add a value here or
in google tag manager if i've assigned a
value to that event so if i go back to
the actual event in google tag manager
you can see i have a value set up for
one dollar then i can just go into
analytics and say you know what i
already have the value added so go ahead
and use the value added in google tag
manager okay so i'm going to choose yes
now if i choose no i have the option to
add the value here just like i would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related goal you can
add the value right into the tag in
google tag manager just as i've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and
measure any dimension against that
particular goal so here i can see e
newsletter sign ups by channel
i can go into another goal set here i
can see contact form submissions okay i
can see
what particular channels driving contact
form submissions okay so just know that
you can align a goal against any
dimension so if you have e-commerce you
don't have to set up for goal for that
that's separate but if you want to take
a look at your goals and analytics on
its own you can just go to conversions
goals overview here i can actually get a
good sense of how my goals are
performing over a period of time so
again if i choose for example year to
date now i could see based on the goals
i've set up how many total goal
completions value which takes into
account the value we've added into these
goals okay the total conversion rate and
here i can see it broken down by the
goal i actually have set up and i can
see it by
page or i could see it by source and
media so i could see google organic is
driving the most gold completions then
google cpc direct and then i could see
some others in here as well contributing
to goals now i do want to point your
attention to another report in google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if i go to
assisted conversions i can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions i've set
up and so what do we mean by assisted
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if i have the ball and i pass
it to my colleague and my colleagues the
one who scores because they had the ball
last well they get the credit for the
point i.e the conversion but i get an
assist and so analytics works the same
way they're always going to give credit
to the last click or direct conversion
but they will give credits to the
channel in this case that assisted with
the conversion so that's under assisted
conversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if i want to hone
in on say to donate clicks only then i'm
going to be able to see what contributed
to
that particular goal so there's another
report in here top conversion pass that
i think is important so after you set up
your goals you can actually see
what channels in this particular example
help to drive conversions again this is
year to date so i can see all the
different combinations of channels that
work together
to
contribute to a conversion so again i
can choose a specific goal or
i can choose all my goals so those two
reports are under multi-channel
funneling there's also another report
that i think is good that's time lag
meaning how long did it actually take
somebody to
convert so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but i could see i did get some
conversions a day later two days later
etc so you have time lag top conversion
pass assistant conversions they're all
under multi-channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and i'll take you to
the gallery and you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up
now if you want more information about
how google analytics works you can
always take a look at a webinar we did
earlier this year google analytics
tutorial for beginners we go into more
detail about analytics and the overview
of analytics and we definitely talk
about goals so take a look at this
webinar and
you know get some more insight about
not only goals but how analytics works
in general today we're going to talk
about how to set up event tracking in
google analytics so welcome and let's
get started so many of you out there
have a website similar to the one i'm
looking at now this is a non-profit that
i work with i'm a foundation and
like this website and probably like your
website you probably have some
interactivity on there that
needs to be tracked for example buttons
uh if you have buttons like this one
that says donate or newsletter sign up
or there's a pdf download or
a video that needs to be you know
tracked based on the amount of people
who click on the play button so i mean
all sorts of inter activity on a website
have you ever wondered how to track that
well there is a way to track that
because by default google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to attract
well you're going to need event tracking
and if you're in analytics and you're
always wandering around the data and you
happen to find yourself under events
well if you want events on your website
and you want data to populate under
behavior top events you're going to need
to set up event tracking so event
tracking is a two-part process and we're
going to talk about that two-part
process the first part of that is to
identify what you want to track okay so
if we go back to our example website
here i'm a foundation again we noted
there's a lot to track here we gotta
donate now bob we got a newsletter sign
up we have some social icons okay we got
a donate now button here we got a play
button here got all sorts of
interactivity you know we got a button
here that says you know purchase tickets
for an upcoming event i can go
throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
google analytics by default is only
going to track pageview data meaning how
somebody got to your website what page
they looked at how long they stayed on
that page what page they left from more
or less their timing how long somebody
stays on the website and what pages they
look at so there's more to a website
than just how long somebody stayed on a
page and so in this example we want to
be able to track everything here not
just the donating album but everything
because once you get the hang of event
tracking then it's very easy to set up
okay so step one identify what you want
to track okay so there's a lot we want
to track we're just going to use one
example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate now button okay
so
this donate now button we want to track
now we have a newsletter sign up we have
facebook and and that's fine you could
track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the donate now
button let's focus on the donating now
but and then we'll come back and start
tracking these other things but this is
what we want to track to start out with
okay so step one identify what you want
to track now when it comes to tracking
events on a website you want to identify
those events so we did that by choosing
this donate now button now once we
identify what we want to track we need
to assign
two parameters
for that event so with event tracking
you have three parameters but one is
actually optional so you have two main
mandatory parameters that you have to
assign to everything you want to track
on your website and that's the category
and then the action so event label or
label is the third parameter but again
that's optional okay so basically when
we identify an event on our website we
want to assign it a category and an
action okay so why do we want to assign
it a category and an action because when
we're in analytics under behavior under
events top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if i click on any one of these
dimensions i'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters i've entered in
for previous events i'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case i have this
donate now button sitting in the header
okay in fact i have a lot of things
sitting in the header so
if i wanted to and i want to track all
these buttons i can create a category
called header and then if i track all
these buttons all these buttons can sit
in that same category if i wanted to or
i can create a separate category for
each of these buttons it's up to you how
you organize your categories because
basically all you're doing is giving a
name to what you're trying to track and
the name is equivalent to a category so
in this case the donate now button's
very important i'm just going to call it
category header donate now i need to
give an action to each category and so
in this case i'm just going to say click
because that's what the action is doing
it's it's somebody's taking the action
of clicking now
if it's a video and it's a play button i
can assign an action of play it's up to
you whatever you name these parameters
you just need to be organized and
methodical about what you name it that's
all and so in this case header donate
and then click okay and so that's our
category in action and so that's clearly
step two so step one identify what you
want to track step two assign a category
action and or label but remember label
is optional so if i go back in analytics
here i could see some categories and if
i click on action i can see some actions
that i've named now step three so we've
identified in step one what we want to
track we've assigned a category in
action so step three is going into
google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
google search for google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview of tag manager here that you
can watch so tag manager basically is
what we want to
use to set up event tracking now tag
managers use for a lot of different
things but the main thing we're doing
here is setting up an event for our
website and so i'm logged in to the same
email address i'm using for analytics
okay so now i'm in tag manager and i
want to set up my event for this donate
now button so what do i need to do well
for every event i want to set up i need
to set up a tag okay so if i go to tags
i can see i already have some tags set
up and some of these are events and so
when you actually set up a tag i
recommend having a naming convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it ga
event dash whatever it is we're trying
to set up and so in this case we want to
set up a new tag for the donate now
button on our website so we're in google
tag manager because tag manager is
what's gonna fire that event so if i
click on new okay and i click on tag
configuration i'm gonna choose google
analytics and then i'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page view we're tracking an
event and so
now remember in step two you identified
what you want to call that category you
identify what you want to call that
action and you have some optional
parameters like label so first things
first header donates the name of our
category and our action is click and if
you want to add in a label
and a value so if you want to assign a
value you can if you want to add in a
label you can okay those are optional so
you just need to focus on category and
action and then the last setting here
that's probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so
this is automatically set to false and
why is it set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if i land on this page here
and i click on that donate now button
that i'm tracking as an event and i
actually leave the site because i have
my settings set to false i want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to count a bounce
if i change it to true
so from false to true then that means it
is going to be a non-interaction
if somebody lands on the page and if
somebody clicks on the button so i don't
want it to be a bounce i want it to be
an interaction so
my advice is leave it set to false we're
going to choose google analytics as our
setting here this is our variable for
google analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property id and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label end or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one any time that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to fall so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do
to set up the tag in google tag manager
now if somebody else is setting up the
tag for you then again you want to
revert to step two you want to be able
to give that person the appropriate
category action and or label and or
value why because you're the one that's
going to be going into google analytics
and you're the one that's going to have
to go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular act category in
action and or label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case i'm going to go ahead and choose a
variable
for
my label parameter and why do i want to
do that because in tag manager i have
something at my disposal called
variables and variables allow you to see
specifically things that are being
tracked so in this case i choose page
path okay so page path is a url and why
did i choose page path as my variable
for the parameter label because if
somebody does click on the header donate
button and the header donate button on
our website is on every page if i go to
the children's page i'm still going to
see that header donate button and so for
me i want to be able to see what page
somebody clicked on that hit or donate
button and so this allows me to actually
see in google analytics what page
somebody clicked on the header donate
now button and so now if i go back to
gtm google tag manager i have a category
i have an action and i have a label
which is a variable okay so note that in
google tag manager you have a lot of
different variables at your disposal and
variables are there to help you identify
specifically
what is being tracked so take a look at
all the variables at your disposal in
tag manager in this example i'm using
page path so now once you set up your
tag pretty straightforward again tag
types google analytics track type is
event you are assigning the category
action end or label and or value you're
changing or leaving the default in place
for non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for google
analytics which is your property id so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here i'm going to
look at a trigger i've already set up
for this particular event and so if i
click on it i'll be able to see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some links
i'm actually saying hey
google tag manager fire this event when
the click id equals header donate button
now it just so happens that if somebody
did click on this donate now button
they're gonna go to
another website in this case
networkforgood.com
so in tag manager i could have set the
trigger to equal url equal instead of
click id i could have said
url equal
networkforgood.com
so that could have been my logic for my
trigger in this case i decided to go
with the click id and so in this case
that button has an id associated with it
called header donate button so if you
wanted to use click id for your event
for your button you could simply just go
to the website you can right click on
that button and click inspect element
and so when i actually inspect the
element i can see now the button here
you can see it's highlighted in the
upper pane and in the lower pane i can
see where it's linking to it's linking
to networkforgood.com
but here you can see if i hone in a
little i could see id equals header dash
donate button so that's the click id
notice there's also a class i could have
set the trigger to equal this class or
again i could have set the trigger to
equal the url or the page that this
button is pointing to i could have
chosen any one of those but i decided to
go with the id so this is the id i chose
and that's the id i have in my trigger
okay so that is what's going to fire
that event so if somebody clicks on a
button that equals header dash donate
dash button it's going to fire that
event which is going to equal category
header donate action click and then the
label is going to be page path so now
that we've set up our event we want to
test to see if it actually works so
there's two ways to go about testing an
event and the first way is through
google analytics so if we go to google
analytics
and then we go to real time okay we can
go to events and here you can see one is
already fired so let's go ahead and go
to and test this and go to the website
so if i go here for example and i click
on amagar alumni okay so if i click on
that you can see i'm under our family
and if i click on that button then go
back to analytics and look at real time
i should be able to see this event fire
so if i click on it i'm gonna go to
network for good now if i go back to
analytics here in real time under real
time under events per second i can see
that event firing category equals header
donate the action equals click now if i
click on
the category here i can see the label
the label remember was page path and
here you could see this event fired on
the r family page which was the page i
was just on so that's one way to test to
see if your event works and in this case
analytics recognized the event so it
works it fired and so therefore it's
going to show up under behavior under
events you can go under overview or top
events okay and what am i going to look
for in this case i'm going to look for
header donate okay if i click on header
donate as my category i'm going to be
able to see my action and if i click on
action i'll be able to see my label in
this case home page and then later on
when the data propagates in analytics
i'll be able to see under label
the page that i clicked on that hit or
donate button which is slash our family
okay the second way in which you can
test to see
if an event fires is if you preview so
if i click on preview and tag manager
okay i'm going to go into preview mode
okay and preview mode allows you to see
in analytics and tag manager and on the
website what tags are firing so here i
could see
i'm in preview mode now so i'm going to
go to the website and i'm going to
refresh
and in my browser same browser i'm using
for tag manager i can see the tags that
are being fired on this page already
okay because i'm in preview mode so here
i could see
remarketing i could see page views i
could see google optimize i could see
some tags that are already firing on
this page now if i click on this button
here by holding down my shift command
and then click on that button i'll be
able to see that the tag fired in
preview mode there's my event header
donate and i could see it fired so now i
can see it fired in the preview mode so
in addition to google analytics in
preview mode i can see that that tag is
fired and i know that it's working so
there you have you have two ways to test
to see if the event fires again you have
real time and analytics okay so in real
time if you just go up to real time all
you need to do is go down to events go
to your website click on the button if
you see it firing in real time then you
know it works the second version or
second way to test your event is through
the preview mode okay if you see it
firing in preview mode then you know
it's also working okay so let's rehash
our steps first step is we want to be
able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a cta button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it ga event that way you
can see in your list of tags in tag
manager
what event tracking you have already set
up so when you set up your tag you set
up your trigger your trigger is based on
logic that can be a url it can be a
click id it can be a class id whatever
you want to use to fire that event and
then once you do that you want to test
it you could test it in gtm or you could
test it in google analytics if it
doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing i would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website as a best practice what i
would recommend is set up a spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note what's firing what
are you doing to fire it could be in
this case when somebody clicks on the
donate now button in the header you want
to put the tag name in here the type
okay then you want to record your
category action and label and then the
great thing about events is you could
turn those events into goals
and that's as simple as going back into
analytics okay so if i go into analytics
and i go to admin and i go to goals if
you set up a new goal okay all you need
to do is choose custom click continue
you're going to choose event as your
goal name and then from a naming
perspective in google analytics for your
goal i would definitely put event first
and then click on header donate okay so
if i click now continue
what is my category it's equal to head
or donate my action is click and so i
can verify
to see if this is working and here i can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 0.22 conversion rate so that
tells me that the goal is working and i
can turn this event into a goal and when
you turn something into a goal and
analytics then you can measure it across
all dimensions that's what i would
recommend if the event is equal to
a kpi or business goal or it's of
importance it's something you really
want to measure okay if it's just a
click say on a facebook button i
wouldn't recommend setting that up as a
goal okay so once you've set up your
event you've recorded it in your
spreadsheet it's firing you want to be
able to then go back into behavior back
into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if i choose my date range
here i can just go to year to date so
here i can see my header donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that
somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same
session so if i go to the ama foundation
website okay i can click on that donate
now button three or four or five
different times in the same session so
what analytics is going to do is
actually
in that session count it once but
accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because
in some cases users may click on the
button more than once in the same
session and so
here i can see total events unique
events and if i added a value to that
event i should be able to see it here so
if i added a dollar as an example to
this particular event because it had 164
unique events i should be able to see
164 as my value but since i see zero
that means that i did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average i have per
event so it's taking into account the
number of or the value the total value
divided by
the total number of unique pageviews or
sessions and so because i don't have
value i'm not going to have average
value but here you can see because value
is optional here i can at least see how
many events
or how many clicks i receive for a
particular button again it could be a
video if i clicked on this video as an
example i can see
how many people actually started it i
could see the unique and the total
events and if i click on label if i have
a label assigned then i'll be able to
see what page triggered that event so if
we go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form etc so
what you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here i could see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in google
analytics under behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're gonna go to
analyze the data so if you need more
information on google tag manager i just
briefly showed you how to set up an
event and how to look for an event in ta
and google analytics so if you need more
information check out this youtube video
we have on google tag manager it'll give
you all the direct insights into what
tag manager is all about he even talks a
little bit more about event tracking
this is rob sanders from simply learn
and today we're gonna go over data
studio
so buckle up and let's get going with
some data studio from google
and so the first thing you'll need is a
google account okay so if you have a
google account if you're able to get
into analytics or google ads then you
should be able to use that same email
address to get into data studio and all
you really have to do is just go to
datastudio.google.com
or you could just google data studio and
get the link but if you're using your
same email address you should be able to
get into data studio and when you're in
data studio
you'll be able to see
some templates at the top that you can
work with when you're setting up a
report or you'll be able to see some
existing reports that
you have either set up or somebody has
shared with you okay so
here if you just click on shared with me
i'll be able to see
all the different reports that have been
shared with me in the past okay so here
if i click on recent i can see all the
reports that i've recently opened so
let's just take a sneak peek at one of
those reports so if i open up a report
that i actually created then what i'm
going to be able to do is look at some
data over a period of time just like i
would if i was in google analytics okay
so the great thing about data studio
here is that it works just like any
google drive document whether it be a
google sheet a google doc or a google
slide okay you could share the document
with anybody you choose to anybody with
a google account okay or if you just
want to share a link okay you could just
click on can view or edit copy the link
and then you can message that person or
email that link to whomever you want to
see this report okay if you want to
invite somebody to edit it or just view
it you can certainly just type in their
name or email address so that's the
great thing right off the bat with data
studio is it's shareable so if multiple
people have added access to the same
report then multiple people can go ahead
and edit that report even at the same
time so that's the great thing about
data studio we're going to cover a lot
of different benefits to data studio i
definitely like using data studio over
analytics and since we're talking about
the comparing the two this in my opinion
replaces if i go to analytics and i go
to say customization and i go to
dashboards this replaces the old
dashboard reports and if you see here at
the top google is even persuading you
to move over to data studio because
dashboards and custom reports are very
limited in nature whereas data studio
not limited at all okay you basically
are creating reports that suit your
needs so just continuing on with some of
the top level okay benefits to data
studio is if we like a report we see we
can easily just make a copy of it so i
have to do is click on that copy and i'm
just going to copy over everything over
so i'm going to copy the data sources or
i can change the data source and
basically what we mean by data source is
where is google pulling the data from
now keep in mind and i'll go over this
more specifically with data studio you
can pull pretty much data sources from
anywhere in any source whether that be a
spreadsheet a database another google
product another platform like facebook
you could certainly pull it from
analytics so you could pull data from
any data source so if you go ahead and
make a copy you just have to make sure
you know what data source you're pulling
the data from because basically all this
is is a report with dimensions and
metrics and those metrics are data
points associated with that dimension so
we could certainly refresh data okay
again we can get the report link just by
clicking on the report link and copying
it it's a bit of a shortener here i can
go ahead and schedule an email delivery
so if i want to go ahead and have this
report sent to somebody i can certainly
do that here and i can have it sent to
them either
daily weekly or monthly and then you can
also download the reports if you
download the report okay i can choose
all pages or select specific pages so in
this report i have two pages set up now
in data studio you can have as many
pages as you want okay so here i can
choose just one page okay some
additional options um i can add a link
back to the report i can password
protect the report okay i can ignore the
custom background color if i wanted to
i'm just going to go ahead and download
that and i'm going to download it in pdf
and so when it downloads i'm going to be
able to then you know view this report
or send it off in pdf format and so
those are some of just the top level
features that you have available to you
in data studio now let's take a step
back okay this is if you're just viewing
the report and you want to share it or
download it or send a link to somebody
what if you actually want to create one
so that's what i'm going to walk through
here i'm going to go ahead and create
one now remember we can just go ahead
and copy this if we like it we can copy
it we could choose certainly choose
different sources of data so i'm going
to go ahead and just play around and
choose different sources of data i don't
know exactly what those sources are but
i'm going to go ahead and choose them
anyway then i'm going to go ahead and
copy that report so i copied it and
basically what it's going to give me is
a duplicate of that report except the
data is going to be different because
i'm choosing different data sources okay
so now here we can see the report and
it's going to load up and it's going to
load up with different data sources now
if i don't see any data that means the
data sources i chose don't have any data
that align with those specific metrics
and dimensions and that's exactly what i
see here so what i'm going to have to do
is go ahead and choose different data
source so let me select a different data
source here i'm going to go ahead and
choose that one
or i can go ahead and create a new data
source so let me just do that so i'm
going to click create new data source
and now
if i don't want to use one that i've
used in the past i can go ahead and
choose from all these different data
sources available to me so there's no
limit on what we could connect so you
see bigquery sql okay you can see data
from google's marketing platform display
video 360. google analytics google
sheets google search console okay keep
scrolling down basically what data
studio does is partner with third party
products like super metrics for example
so that super metrics is the
intermediary
plot program that pulls in for example
facebook ads or google my business pulls
it into data studio for you here you can
see adobe analytics okay you have all
sorts of connectors that you can connect
to so i could choose any one of these to
connect it now if i choose one with say
super metrics i'm going to need that
super matrix account now if you choose
any one of these direct google
connectors like i'm going to choose
google analytics then you don't need a
third-party intermediary like super
metrics you can go ahead and based on
the login that you have set up or that
you're using to log into data studio
you're going to be able to see all the
other google analytics accounts you have
access to so i'm just going to go ahead
and choose
an account here i'm going to choose a
property and i'm going to choose my view
then i'm going to click connect okay so
that's how you basically will connect a
new data source now when you actually
connect that data source what's going to
happen is
data studio is going to give you the
option and it's going to give you an
option to make changes to all the
dimensions available dimensions are in
green and if i keep scrolling down i can
have the opportunity to
change any of the metrics metrics in
blue and i can change it to
the type of metric i'm getting whether
it be just a numeric or currency a
percent okay or i can change it to
aggregate
auto i can change it the description of
it hey that's making changes to
something i can even just delete it or
remove it or i can go ahead and add my
own metric or dimension okay just by
clicking on add in a field and so here
i'm going to go ahead and choose some
available fields or put in my own
formula so this is kind of that first
step when you create your source or your
second step if you will your first is
actually choosing the source in this
case we chose google analytics the
second step is
having the opportunity to change out or
edit or add dimensions and metrics now
if you're a novice or beginner to data
studio then i would say let's skip this
step uh if you're not comfortable
editing or adding dimensions and metrics
and go ahead and just skip it and click
on this blue call to action add to
report okay so i'm going to add it to
the report and now that it's been added
now i'm still seeing no data why am i
seeing donations so if you copy report
you don't see any data chances are it
probably has a filter because i copied
it and here you can see i have a filter
so i'm just going to go ahead and remove
the filter and voila i see data so
that's something you need to be aware of
when you actually copy over an existing
report you have to choose the
data source but keep in mind when you
copy over an existing report you're also
copying over filters and segments so if
you're familiar with google analytics
you know that in google analytics
if i go back into analytics here and
let's just say i go to
acquisition
and i go to
uh all traffic and i go to channels what
do i have the opportunity to do in these
standard reports well i have an
opportunity to add a segment i also have
an opportunity to
add a table filter
you could do the same thing in data
studio okay because i copied the report
basically i copied over all of those
filters table filters and segments that
go along with it and so you just need to
be cognos of that as you're building out
this report now that's if i copied it so
you can see i copied it and everything
else that goes along with it the the
color scheme the
the logo etc now this is if you not
familiar with data studio it's good to
copy report play around with it etc
that's probably what i would recommend
so again if you're not familiar with day
studio you want to get comfortable then
go ahead and even choose one of the
templates if you don't have access to an
existing report so let's go ahead and
just choose i'm going to say one of
these templates that data studio has
provided okay you can see looks pretty
good layout looks pretty clean i got all
my important metrics in here what's
going to happen is if i want to use it
i'm going to click use template now same
thing that occurred when i copied a
previous report i'm going to have to
choose a data source so i don't want to
choose google analytics
sampling of data or sample set of data i
want to choose some actual data so i'm
going to have to go in and choose an
existing i can choose an existing data
source here or i can connect to a new
data source okay so
let's go ahead and just choose one of
these data sources i already have access
to and i'm going to go ahead and copy
this template so it works in the the
same way as if i copied an existing
report i'm just copying a template okay
so here you can see i'm copying the
template now okay the only thing that's
missing here is the ability for me to
edit the dimensions and metrics so if
you anytime you add a new data source
you're always going to be prompted to
have the ability to edit dimensions and
metrics if you don't if you're not
comfortable with that then just go ahead
and add the data source just like i've
done here and so now i could see
basically the same report i could just
see it's just pulling in data from a
different data source that's all now i'm
in edit mode okay so if i want to view
the report just as anybody else would
view it if you gave them a link to view
it i'm going to click on this view
button here and so now i can see i have
some drop downs here and so this drop
down is basically allowing me to choose
my own analytics account if i wanted to
so i can go ahead and just choose any
one of these if i wanted to change the
data here i get another pull down and
this is my date range selector so i can
change the date range if i want to do so
if i change the date range then the data
is going to change now if i want to edit
anything here in this report i'm going
to have to go back and click on the edit
mode so just click on the edit button
there and now i'm going to be able to go
in and edit this existing template now
i've already established a data source
but i could change the data source if i
want to all i have to do is just go here
click on any one of these tables or
metrics
and
change out the data source just by
clicking on this icon here okay where it
says edit data source
so i'm going to have the ability to
make changes
to any of the dimensions and metrics or
i can just get rid of that data source
and choose a new data source now in data
studio you have the option to change the
layout you have the option to change a
theme so you can go from a simple theme
to say a simply dark theme you could
change any aspect of the report if you
want to so just know that anytime you
click on any of the data points you have
the same options available you have a
chance to edit the data or you have a
chance to style it so when we talk about
styling you know you can basically
add labels you can hide labels you can
compact the numbers you can style it any
way you want based on the particular
table and so that's the great thing
about data studio is really really
customized to what you need so for
example here what are the top countries
by sessions well
i don't have to show legend if i don't
want so i'm just going to get rid of the
legend i can change the font okay i can
change the color scheme on it i can go
ahead and do a lot of different things
here so once i've made changes after i
view it i'll be able to see those
changes in full effect okay so just know
that in data studio whatever report
you're looking at that you have edit
access to you have the ability to make
changes to anything in that report now
here you can see
i see a lot of different data great what
i can actually do too is add a page and
so let's go ahead and click on add a
page and now we have two pages to our
report and now i have a blank canvas on
page two so now what do i want to put on
page two well the best practice to me is
organizing your data okay so just like
in analytics analytics organizes their
data between audience acquisition
behavior and conversions as a best
practice that's probably what i would do
here maybe stick all your mobile on one
page or your acquisition on one page all
your maybe your organic search on one
page now it's okay to have a summary
page just like we have on page one but
if you're going to have multiple pages
then perhaps think about organizing it
based on the multiple pages that you add
so here let's go to page two blank
canvas so the great thing about data
studio again it's just very easy to
start populating okay so i'm going to go
ahead and click add a chart okay which
type of chart do i want to add well in
the spirit of visualization you probably
always want to choose something visual
start with an easy pie chart here i'm
going to go ahead and select pie chart
and i'm going to place it to where i
want okay now i can go ahead and
increase the size if i want to make it
smaller make it bigger etc voila i have
a pie chart now if i want to edit this
pie chart again i have my options
available i have my data and i have my
style so i know it's pulling from this
data source here okay i want to change
my dimension dimension is what we're
measuring so let's just maybe change it
to source
and maybe i want to go from page views
to let's just say
goal conversions so i can just go in and
start typing in the metric and
here i can see
gold conversion rate let's choose that
okay now i can see source by go
conversion rate now if i don't want
source let's change that back to default
channel grouping so now my dimension is
default channel grouping by goal
conversion rate so now if i'm looking at
my data i could see that referral has a
51.8 percent goal conversion rate
followed up by organic search with 19.5
okay so again it's very easy
to
edit the data points on any chart now if
i want to style it i'm just going to
click on style here i can go with a
single color dimension values okay i can
slice it up in different colors i can
choose a background color i can add a
border customization is really endless
here i can change it from 10 to say 12
slices if it's available maybe go down
to
the top three it's as easy as it gets i
mean it really is fairly intuitive to
use you just got to learn what
dimensions and metrics you want to use
now i have my pie chart the great thing
about data studio just like powerpoint
for example i can go ahead and just copy
this pie chart command c then command v
and voila i now have a copy of it okay
well
maybe i don't want two pie charts so let
me go ahead and change one so i can go
ahead my upper right here and go from
say a pie chart to let's just say a
trend line if it makes sense or maybe
a combo chart so i have my sessions
along my goal conversion rate now i can
again go ahead and change that i don't
want sessions maybe i want you know go
completions or something so let's go
ahead and add that in there goal
completions so now i can see goal
completions and then go conversion rate
by my default channel grouping so again
i could style it you know if i don't
want red bars i can go ahead and choose
a different bar okay it's really that
simple now if you find you're running
out of real estate okay you can always
scroll down and change the height so if
i change it from 1200 default to 1800
pixels i can get more real estate to
work with likewise on the width so now i
can make it really wide to work with now
when you make those changes to the page
you're probably going to see the same
effect happen on page one in fact you
will so back to page two okay so if we
go to page two here what we could do is
go ahead and add more charts or we can
copy and paste existing charts and go
ahead and change them up okay just by
command c and command v now what you
want to do if you create more pages here
is maybe add in your date range so if i
go click on my date range symbol here
i'm just going to drag and drop that
enlarge it a bit now i can make a
default date range i can say
i want to show data for this month so
anytime somebody goes to the page the
data that shows is going to be for the
month the month to date now again if you
want to customize it what you can do
is you can just copy and paste so ctrl c
or command c
go back to page two command v so this
gives you the ability to just start
customizing now the one drawback to data
studio being a little bit nitpicky is in
powerpoint if you're copying from slide
to slide it tends to paste it in the
same exact location i know it sounds a
little bit nitpicky but in data studio
and you copy and paste something it
doesn't necessarily always paste in the
exact location so i've noticed that uh
being the issue but it's a small issue
nonetheless so you have the ability to
copy an existing report you have the
ability to go ahead and choose an
existing template and like i said going
back to data studio you have the ability
to just start with a blank canvas so
again just walking you through the steps
here blank report brand new canvas i
need to choose a data source so you can
see existing data sources if you don't
have existing data sources to choose
from you can always just click create
new data source okay when you create new
data source you're going to choose from
a list if you're new to data studio
start with something easy like google
analytics if you choose google sheets
then great you're going to be asked to
look for data in google sheets likewise
with google ads if you choose google ads
you're going to have to choose a google
ads account so start easy start with
google analytics okay i'm going to
choose analytics i'm going to choose my
account my property i'm going to choose
my view i'm going to go ahead and
connect because this is a new data
source i have the ability to go ahead
and edit my existing dimensions and
metrics if i want i don't have to then
i'm going to go ahead and click add to
report it's going to confirm the
connection to the data source now i have
my connection to my data source i am
free to start doing what i need to do to
the report whether that be get somebody
else involved immediately by sharing it
with them go ahead and start adding
pages and organizing it you know adding
my date range adding a logo adding a
logo simply just clicking on image
selecting my file or my images it's a
best practice anytime you
create a table i would go ahead and put
a text box above it maybe put a title so
you could say
channel in this case channel by
conversion rate okay so let's make that
a little bit bigger as a best practice
that's what i would do now it's you're
free to do whatever you want in data
studio the whole point of data studio is
really to customize the report any way
you want and what i mean by customize is
adding the dimensions and metrics that
are important to you and so data studio
gives you the opportunity to copy an
existing report or again you can use
existing template or start with a blank
report the options are all there for you
data state is fairly easy to use again
you could share it okay you can download
it you can schedule emails you can send
a link to people okay there's really no
limit to what you can do with data
studio okay again you can rearrange
things add pages organize them add
filters ad segments i mean basically
anything you can do in analytics you can
do in data studio a lot more features my
recommendation to get started you know
go ahead and choose that blank canvas
and just start playing just start
playing by adding charts okay once you
add charts okay the data is going to
populate and again you're just then free
to start playing around with dimensions
and metrics so that's the way to get
started with data studio practice makes
perfect once you get more comfortable
then you're going to have full-fledged
reports to work from just like i use for
my clients there's no limit on what you
can do and what you can see and again
customization makes the report look good
obviously the data and improved data is
going to make your report look good as
well so keep all those things in mind
apply some of the best practices but
more importantly play around get
comfortable and then eventually you're
going to start using data studio as your
main source of data over google
analytics the world we live in now it's
highly digital place but that wasn't
always the case until four years ago so
if we rewind letting people know about
your products was a little harder then
so even if you go back say five or ten
years promoting your products wasn't as
easy as it is today i mean people had to
resort to you know good old-fashioned
newspapers putting in an ad or those big
thick books called the yellow pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton i mean those were the ways to get
your product and message out there a lot
of advertising in those yellow pages
then you have billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then fax fax
ads uncommonly known way to advertise by
the way who has faxes now but people did
advertise via vfx just a few decades ago
so these were all the ways in which
people had to get their product and
service out there it seems like so
archaic looking at it now but back then
that was legitimate that was the way to
do it and then one thing made our lives
a lot easier so if you're a marketer
you're thinking yourself man i'm glad
i'm a marketer in today's day and age
because it's social media marketing
social media marketing has made
everyone's lives better from the company
that's selling the product or service to
the marketer promoting the product and
service to the end user who wants to see
that product or service and engage with
that product or service so social media
is a good source of getting your product
and service out there and it just makes
everybody's lives a heck of a lot easier
so we're going to answer that million
dollar question and what's that million
dollar question it's how can you rise
above the rest and so today's session is
going to be how to start with social
media marketing so you can rise above
the rest leveraging this great platform
that we all take advantage of today so
let's start by asking the question what
is social media marketing social media
marketing involves increasing website
traffic it centers around engagement it
offers you the ability to increase your
brand awareness and it has other
marketing goals you know so you can
create various forms of content for
different social media platforms so
that's really in a nutshell with social
media marketing so again if we want to
increase our traffic or we want to
increase our engagement like likes or
comments then look no further than
social media marketing if we want to
engage with our users our customers our
potential and prospective customers we
can really put a personalized experience
in place using social media marketing we
want to create different forms of
content like videos and blogs and
infographics and other types of graphics
with the potential to actually go viral
by viral is spreading like wildfire one
user sending it to another as rapidly as
can be and before you know it you get
you know millions of views and millions
of likes i mean that's the power of
social media marketing so why do we want
to do social media marketing and i think
we just answered some of those questions
but let's dig a little bit deeper we
mentioned in our definition of social
media marketing that we have the
opportunity to
really build our brand awareness and
that is no more truthful than with
social media marketing more so than any
other digital marketing channel social
media marketing allows us to really put
our brand in a good light in a good
position in front of the right eyeballs
so it allows us to really improve our
brand by pushing out the appropriate
content in front of the appropriate
people social media is a great channel
for that we can look to conversion rates
so if we are pushing a product and
service in front of the right eyeballs
and we are building up a funnel of
prospective customers who then turn into
customers who then turn into loyal
customers who then turn into lifetime
customers we could see it every step in
the process that our conversion rates
may increase we can certainly leverage
social media marketing for seo for
search engine rankings it's about
off-page seo it's about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there is some
inherent benefits to working seo and
social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on twitter or facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say google or bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by
your target audience okay your target
audience goes from seeing your brand for
the first time to
getting to know your brand a little bit
more to maybe buying a product or
service from your brand then returning
to buy another product and service and
then continuing to buy that product or
service i mean that's increasing the top
funnel traffic and not just the traffic
but the conversions so at every step in
the process social media allows you to
build that funnel depending on where
somebody is whether they're seeing your
brand for the first time or actually
returning to purchase the product or
service again so that's the inherent
benefit these are the inherent benefits
of social media marketing now we talk
about social media marketing what are
the channels used for social media
marketing how can we use them it's
really social media marketing is a
channel in itself so let's take a look
at the platforms involved with social
media marketing now there are some
really popular platforms so if you can't
tell just buy these logos then you
probably have not used social media
marketing or or social media platforms
before or taken part in social media at
all but you know one would like to think
that the majority of your users out
there today know what facebook is what
the logo looks like what it does same
with instagram which is owned by
facebook linkedin b2b platform it's
youtube great very popular
video sharing platform and then twitter
which is considered microblogging but
still social media so these are the most
popular popular platforms out there but
there are hundreds of social media
platforms in fact when we talk about
social media marketing it can be
anything from micro blogging to
video sharing like youtube to b2b
networks like linkedin to say
bookmarking sites like stumbled upon
content sharing sites like reddit q and
a sites like cora so there's plenty of
different types of social media
platforms out there in fact if you folks
have any popular or you think valid
social media platforms that these
listeners here should really get to know
and understand and use then go ahead and
put that in the comments section
underneath this video i'm always
interested in knowing what social media
platforms are out there and what people
are using how platforms are trending
what's popular what's not and ideally as
a digital marketer where my target
audience is so these are the most common
but there are hundreds out there
hundreds so let's talk about the most
popular social media platform and that's
facebook so
facebook has an average of
2.27 billion monthly active users now
that number is fluctuating because we're
talking about billions billions billions
of monthly active users and that number
is probably trending up 88 of all users
are on mobile so what does that tell you
that tells you that facebook has an app
and the app is very popular in fact i
tend to use the app more than i use the
web page for facebook okay so i don't
necessarily log on via the internet on
my laptop i go right to the app it's
just easier easier to disseminate
information easier to add friends
comment respond etc so it's no surprise
that 88 of all users use mobile now 66
percent of mobile monthly users use
facebook daily so a lot of recurring
users going back on a day-to-day basis
two-thirds so it's an addiction more
than it is anything else because what
facebook is is really you're getting
information from the people you trust
care about like work with share a group
wish or common interest with partake in
the same organization maybe have the
same running group same passions i mean
that's what facebook is it's a
commonality amongst people and if you
build up a network of that commonality
it's going to be addicting to take part
in that you know the closest network you
can ever get to is your family so if
your family's on facebook then likely
you're going to be on facebook
communicating with your family via this
platform especially if you don't live
close to your family or especially if
you don't live close to your friends i
know in the united states you know
people move a lot for work or people
travel a lot for work and so facebook
bridges that gap between distance and
you you know you do feel like you're
part of somebody's life on a daily basis
being on facebook so that's what makes
it the addictive part so if you think
about it from an end user's perspective
it makes total sense now if you wear
your digital marketing hat and you're
thinking hey two-thirds of monthly users
are using it daily and there's billions
of active users then whoever i'm
targeting has to be on facebook now if
we look closer at the demographics we
could see that a lot more seniors age 65
plus are using facebook so 60 plus
percent of seniors are using facebook so
facebook is trending older however 35 of
the audience is below the age of 25 so
it's not just trending up it's also
trending down so a lot of young people
are still using facebook and then
facebook you know is pretty evenly
matched between males and females now if
i'm either slewing old feeling older or
skewing younger on my target audience
and half female half as male then i know
somewhere in there whoever i'm targeting
is going to be on facebook just based on
these numbers here so your demographic
is likely going to be on facebook again
depending on your industry depending on
your product or service but considering
the number of people and how it's
skewing older and younger and everybody
in between facebook has something for
everyone now facebook allows for video
content so you can post videos all day
long so if you have youtube videos you
can share those youtube videos on
facebook in fact video just like on most
platforms tends to provide better
engagement and the industries that can
really capitalize on facebook tend to be
food and beverage news and media and
e-commerce meaning you're selling a
product facebook has you know plug-ins
and that allow you to really accentuate
what you're trying to sell and when i
say that accentuate i mean really
incorporate an opportunity for people to
use the facebook platform to not only
just engage not only to share but to buy
taking that process a step further so if
you're selling a product you can more or
less set up a facebook shop if you will
and sell your product there so that's
why it benefits those that are in the
e-commerce industry selling a particular
product or in the food and beverage
industry now some of the most liked
pages on facebook spans across many many
brands but let's just take a look at
coca-cola for example and coca-cola just
pretty much pinpoints everything great
about what you could do on facebook i
mean you could see here they have their
opening page is a video and so you can
see they're posting different content
about you know this is about a grant how
they're helping the city of atlanta you
know they're talking about recycling so
to me these are community-based posts so
they're not necessarily just pushing out
their product per se they're trying to
use facebook to build up brand awareness
so a huge fortune 500 company like
coca-cola is not necessarily just using
facebook just to push e-commerce to push
a product they're out there you know
pushing what they're doing for the
community
so this is a good example of you know
how you can really leverage facebook
taking advantage of everything facebook
has to offer and that means brand
awareness community building you know
sharing you know updated information not
only about the company but in this case
coca-cola is situated in atlanta georgia
in the united states so you know what
are they doing with the community okay
so this is a good example of course it's
a big example because coca-cola is a big
company they're worldwide but the great
thing about facebook is you can always
take a peek at what other companies are
doing whether you have a million plus
people liking your page or a hundred
plus people liking your page you can
always get ideas
as to how they're leveraging facebook
now if you do have a company you can
create a facebook page for your business
just like coca-cola so you want to be
able to separate out your business from
your personal pitch and like everything
you do whether that's writing a blog or
creating a video you want to have
original content that's relevant to your
audience you want to use facebook for
some promotion but every post doesn't
necessarily need to be promoting your
product or service you saw what we just
witnessed on the coca-cola page it was
about what they were doing to
you know benefit the earth with
recycling or what they're doing in
conjunction with the with the city of
atlanta so they're more community-based
posts and so to me that's original
content positive content that isn't
necessarily pushing their product per se
now you could argue hey it's coca-cola
they have the biggest brand in the world
and that's true but just think about
your product and service think about
your brand if you're trying to build
brand awareness what does your brand
stand for and if your brand stands for
say
the
the globe the ecosystem the environment
then you probably want to be pushing
outpost in that direction if that's what
you stand for as a brand then you want
people to know that because like-minded
people are on facebook and those
like-minded people are going to be the
ones who like your page who engage with
your content and tell other people about
it so you always want to go original you
always want to be true to yourself and
true to your brand and then you could
take advantage of user generated content
like sharing a user's experience of
using your product so in other words if
somebody's engaging with you or they've
posted something about your brand and
product you can reciprocate you can
certainly post something that is similar
to what somebody's doing with your
product or brand so that's a good way to
create some original content by taking
advantage of what the users have
generated so these are just some
examples of how to take advantage of
facebook i mean there's lots of things
you can do on facebook plenty of things
if we float back to coca-cola page you
know you can see they have you know
careers they have different videos they
have reviews they have community so
nowhere in here do i see an e-commerce
platform now if you are selling t-shirts
then hey you can put something in there
to help you sell that t-shirt but
coca-cola's strategy is hey what can we
do to help build up our community what
can we do to fundraise so if we click on
fundraise you can see they have you know
an aids campaign here if you look at
simply learn just as another example you
can see what simply learns done as well
you can see they have information about
us they have different events they have
a community link as well and so you can
see what they're posting as well and
they're you can see they're posting
visitor photos so there's lots you can
do on facebook you can post polls you
can put your instagram feed in there you
can add testimonials so there's a lot
you can do on your page you just gotta
get creative and take advantage of
everything facebook has to offer be true
to yourself and before you know it i
mean you're gonna have you know a number
of likes on your business page as well
so some other tips about facebook when
it comes to content you want to schedule
your content okay you don't want to just
continue to post back to back to back to
back you want to space your content out
and the another great advantage to
facebook as i already mentioned about
social media marketing that's
advertising so facebook owns instagram
they have a great tool for communicating
called facebook messenger and so you can
advertise leveraging facebook messenger
you can leverage instagram and what you
need to do is if you go to facebook's ad
manager and you create a campaign when
you go to create a campaign you're going
to click on placements and depending on
what you're trying to do let's just say
you're trying to build brand awareness
you can actually hone in on you know
facebook you can hone in on instagram
you can do a number of different things
within facebook you have different ads
available to you from single image ads
to video ads to carousel so you have a
lot of options and the biggest option on
facebook when it comes to advertising is
your audience who are you targeting so
remember facebook has old young and
everybody in between between men and
women and so you can specifically target
interest you could specifically target
gender an age a location so facebook
really allows you to hone in on who your
audience is if you're advertising and so
that's the great thing about facebook
they have a lot of users and
you're you have an opportunity to hone
in on a segment of that user base now
facebook also has
metrics that you can look at to really
understand how people are interacting
with your ads how inner people are
interacting with your post so let's take
a look at that so if we go to facebook
when you go to your page you can click
on insights and you can actually see
some insights on posts that have been
posted on your page you can get insights
into how many people viewed it how many
people liked it how many people engaged
how many people you reached with your
post okay you have information about
videos followers facebook provides
recommendations so this is all part of
facebook insights so if you're posting
on facebook facebook will give you
feedback as to how your posts are
performing now if you're running ads on
facebook you can simply just view
metrics related to how your ads are
performing so you could see how many
people clicked on an ad how many people
the ad reached how much you've spent
okay you can look at it by demographic
you can even see cost per result so you
can get a lot of good insight into how
your ads are performing as well so if
you're running a campaign targeting a
specific audience on facebook you can
look at the you know stats and metrics
surrounding that campaign and again for
your facebook page you have facebook
insights so if you have any questions
you know feel free we have a video
called uh facebook advertising uh tips
and tricks so feel free to you know take
a look at this video on simply learn's
youtube channel for more information
about facebook and if again if you have
any comments to share about facebook
feel free to put them under the comment
section okay let's turn our attention to
one of the platforms facebook actually
owns instagram so
instagram is a place where you can
actually promote your brand product or
service through the power of imagery or
video and so the average number of
monthly users on instagram reaches 1
billion and 32 percent of all internet
users are on instagram so a lot of users
using it it's very easy platform to use
you just the only prerequisite you need
your mobile phone so you open up that
app it's as simple as just uploading
uploading an image that's why instagram
is so popular because it's just a simple
tool to use to go ahead and just post an
image with some hashtags so 68 of all
instagram users are women so unlike
facebook it does tend to slant more on
the female side and 59 percent of the
audience is a bit younger between age 18
to 29 so slants more women and slams
more younger and so if these particular
demographic and age groups tend to
fit your target audience then instagram
is a place you probably want to be for
social media marketing so as i mentioned
content that works best are photos or
videos i would always slant towards
videos if you have them available with
photos you know the rule of thumb is
photos always tell a thousand words a
thousand stories a thousand
interpretations images are just always
the best way to go as well i mean if you
don't have the videos hey nothing to be
sad about if you fall back on imagery so
you can really put your brand in a good
perspective and a good light by posting
images and as you can imagine if 18 to
29 year old women are on instagram you
know that's skewing towards a certain
demographic but in terms of industry it
is open to most industries but the ones
that tend to be most successful are
beauty food and beverage and e-commerce
now food beverage always tends to work
well when you have video and imagery
likewise beauty but e-commerce if you're
selling that t-shirt or shoe you know
instagram allows the platform to
work in a way where people can purchase
that product right within the platform
so that's why it tends to work well with
e-commerce okay there are lots of
channels just like on facebook lots of
channels on instagram i mean some of the
most followed brands are chanel
starbucks nike i mean if you have a
product or service that you want to push
out there then instagram is the way to
go just for brand awareness if you're
selling shoes then why not take images
of and photos of their shoes and get
them posted on instagram like i said
it's very simple to use all you need is
some hashtags to go along with that
photo of a shoe or photo of that cup of
coffee and instagram kind of takes care
of itself i mean photos do
accentuate the product if you have them
so leverage instagram if you're really
trying to build up some brand awareness
for a particular product some best
practices here on instagram is you know
have a compelling bio a good profile
picture you know add a link to a landing
page and you know leverage emojis if you
have to so set yourself up nicely on
instagram you know if you're in a
particular industry like food and
beverage follow other food and beverage
brands like coca-cola like starbucks
depends on what it is you really want to
be related to so just make sure they're
relevant get hashtags can't stress that
enough you know when you post a photo
there's some hashtags in there you can
see what other people are hashtagging on
instagram and you can ride that wave of
what's trending or you can create your
own unique hashtag i'd probably have two
to three hashtags per photo and don't be
afraid to use both photos and videos
videos do tend to work well on pretty
much any platform they tend to work well
on websites and blogs so why not use
them on social media where people can
engage okay so videos and imageries both
work well on instagram okay you can also
get shout outs from other influencers
plenty of influencers on instagram
especially in beauty especially in food
and beverage fashion tends to be another
industry that has a lot of influencers
so feel free to reach out to them
reciprocate see how you can work
together where they can actually you
know give you a shout out on your
particular product you want to keep your
instagram account updated and you can
update those with instagram stories it's
basically
you showing off a particular product you
know over a span of a few seconds or
even a minute that's an instagram story
they're very popular uh easy to use you
can even run contests to boost
engagement so
for example if your particular product
is a particular food like a hamburger
you know hey post a contest about you
know allowing your followers to post the
best good looking tasty you know
hamburger as an example or it could be
something else in terms of fashion hey
what's your best outfit on a friday
night before you go out for the evening
you know there's always things you can
do to spur engagement especially on a
platform like instagram where people
like to post photos and then i mentioned
this earlier with facebook ads you can
run instagram ads to give a particular
post to boost so if we take a little
snapshot of what we have available in
facebook ads manager you can choose
instagram as the particular platform so
if you just want to
advertise on instagram when you go to
your placements you could choose just
instagram either the feed or the stories
okay so you can choose one of these two
options if you want to want to boost
your posts get some more eyeballs on
that it's a cost per click platform so
anytime somebody clicks it's going to
cost you but you know just like facebook
you know the cost per click tends to
slant a little bit lower it really
depends on what you're trying to post
when you're trying to post it and who
else is posting but hey the instagram
feed and the stories could be a good
option if you're really trying to draw
attention to a particular product okay
let's turn our attention now to the b2b
platform called linkedin linkedin is a
very powerful popular business to
business platform it has 260 million
active users monthly and
unlike instagram where instagram slants
more towards women linkedin slants more
towards men 57
so a majority of the users are men but
still you have a lot of women involved
in on linkedin so a nice you know nice
mix between both genders 38
of the user base are millennials you
know a lot of young people older people
a nice mix from a business lots of
different different business segments
different levels of business different
business industries and verticals are on
linkedin so don't be you know shying
away from
linkedin if your demographic or target
audience tends to be older just because
38 are millennials doesn't mean anything
it means that everybody's using it just
that means that hey you know more than
one-third of the users are millennials
are younger now linkedin is a b2b
platform so if you're in
the business of generating business
leads then linkedin is the place for you
to go there's opportunities for you to
advertise on linkedin okay there's also
opportunities for you to post lots of
different content on linkedin so content
that works on linkedin could be a blog
it could be you know particular news
article you know tips and best practices
i've posted videos on linkedin you know
it's good for jobs there's a lot of
content on linkedin so if we take a
sneak peek at linkedin if i just go to
linkedin here you know and i just go to
my home uh the start news page you know
i could see the types of content that's
been posted so somebody just posted
something with an image you know then
you got an article
down here okay you got you know uh an
influencer like richard branson posting
so you got a lot of different types of
posts that you'll be able to see and
you know leverage if you want to meaning
when i say leverage if you see somebody
like richard branson posting something
hey stay fit and healthy you know that's
an image that's something about not
about business per se but you know
something interesting and unique so you
can see all sorts of different types of
content based on who you're following on
linkedin and who you're connected to
some things about linkedin you always
want to create an engaging profile when
i say engaging well first things first
make sure it's complete i mean there's
lots of opportunities so if you sneak
over to my profile here you want to be
able to
post a lot of information about yourself
so about what you're affiliated with
what jobs you've held what groups you're
associated with what your interests are
what certifications you have so you want
to be able to
you know complete your total profile you
can create a company page for your
business so if we go back to linkedin we
can just do a search for say simply
learn and let's take a look at you know
their business page so if i just do a
search for simply learn here so i select
their page you can see just like your
profile page if you have a business page
set up on linkedin you want to make sure
it's complete you want to put
information about the company what jobs
are available and you want your company
to
associate with that business page
anybody who does you know follow that
particular business page part of the
organization is going to be listed under
people so and you want to be able to
post just like on your personal profile
if you have a business page you want to
be able to post unique content i mean
you can see here simply learn is posting
you know some of the accolades that they
have but they're taking it a step
further they're also posting you know
information about you know upcoming
events and webinars so they're posting a
mix of different content and that's
ideally what you want to do on any
social media platform is mix it up and
just like you can on facebook just like
you can on instagram you can you know
boost a post per se okay so you can get
that post in front of some additional
eyeballs now of course you want to
optimize your company page for searches
so it really does come down to
how many people are following you but
when you say when we say optimize your
company page just make sure it's
complete with some compelling content
and then increase the number of
followers you have so the great thing
about linkedin that i like the most is
that you know you can you know simply
look at other people if i go back to say
the home page you can actually see who's
following what and you know linkedin
does give you
opportunities to connect with people
okay so if i go to your if you go to
your profile you'll be able to see
other people that have viewed your
particular page and you can connect with
them okay or connect with people who are
like-minded or similar or connected to
people that you know so linkedin does a
good job of presenting other people you
can connect with so it makes it easier
for you to increase the number of
followers so having an engaging profile
personal profile you know having an
engaging company page making sure both
your personal and the company page have
all the content necessary have all of it
completed and then increasing followers
posting unique content i mean that's
really the key to linkedin now again
with linkedin you can use different
media you can use videos slideshare
presentation images and you can boost
content as i mentioned before you can
boost content on linkedin so if you want
to get that content in front of eyeballs
you can do that so let's take a look at
an example of a campaign and what you
could do on linkedin in terms of
sponsored content so if you go to
linkedin's campaign manager when you
have an opportunity to put your ad in
front of a particular audience so really
depends again on who you're trying to
target just like facebook which slants
more towards personal linkedin is going
to slam more towards business so with
linkedin you have an opportunity to
target a particular industry a
particular company a particular job
title okay so you could target
everything business related on linkedin
so you can go ahead and create an ad the
ads have imagery to support the ad and
so basically when you set up your ad you
set up your target you can choose your
placement you're going to be able to see
you know who it is you're actually
targeting and you can go ahead and great
thing about linkedin is you have
different ad formats and again you can
get really creative with who you want to
target and just like facebook you know
linkedin has you know some metrics that
you can measure and figure out how your
particular campaign performed by
impressions by click click-through rate
even conversions cost per conversions
and how many leads so linkedin has
built-in platform for measuring campaign
success and so the differentiation
between facebook and linkedin is really
just the type of demographics that you
have to choose from you know with
linkedin you do have you know different
options available based on business like
your job title or job level or industry
or vertical so you have a lot of
examples available a lot of options
available to you on linkedin in terms of
advertising okay let's talk about
youtube now so youtube has 1.9 billion
active users if it was a search engine
it'd be the second most popular search
engine the highest number of monthly
active users in decreasing order starts
at the united states brazil russia japan
and india all big markets all like to
use youtube but youtube's popular across
the world just like facebook where the
app is popular the app on for youtube is
very popular so 70 of all views are
generated from mobile so with youtube
being a video platform you never
definitely need videos now there's a lot
of industries on youtube a lot of
industries um in some of the most
successful brands on youtube you know
range from logo to coca-cola you know
pretty much to every brand if you're a
brand you want to be on youtube because
of the massive reach that youtube has to
offer coupled with video and how great
video is in terms of engagement it's
like just a great combination okay so
some best practices here for youtube you
want to optimize your video for seo to
get views and so we have a video that
we've created at simplylearn how to rank
youtube videos so if you watch that
video you'll get some really good tips
and strategies about how to you know
optimize your video for youtube the very
least you want to make sure that you're
using right the right keywords and the
title description and hashtags so that's
a start when we talk about optimizing
your videos you want to upload regularly
and fix a schedule for your videos
because if you're starting to get
followers on youtube or subscribers
they're going to expect you to produce
more video especially if you're
producing engaging unique relevant
content for that target audience so
we're not saying you have to have a
video once a day or once a week start
small and build up and get on a regular
schedule and then you can organize your
videos in the playlist so you know if we
look at simply learn you know simply
learn does a good job of organizing
their videos into a playlist so all you
have to do is go to i'm a founder and
ceo simply learns uh youtube channel and
you can see how it's broken down into
playlist now youtube also has the
ability because it is global you do have
the ability to provide translations so
if your target audience is from another
country it probably wouldn't be a bad
idea
like facebook and instagram or like
linkedin you can advertise on youtube
you would just need to do that through
google ads so with google ads you're
going to say google i want to advertise
on youtube and you have plenty of
available options to available to you
anything from you know pre-roll to
showing up in the middle of a video to
showing up you know before or excuse me
at the end of a video all the way to
native content marketing where you know
your ad is showing up next to a video so
you have plenty of options for
advertising on youtube and then just
like on instagram there are influencers
on youtube you know feel free to reach
out to these influencers and see if you
can collaborate in some way where maybe
you post their video on your channel
they post your video on their channel
and vice versa so you want to be able to
maybe collaborate somehow to get some
views on your video okay let's talk
about twitter now so twitter is a micro
blogging platform and so when i say
micro blogging i mean limited in
characters limited in how much you can
actually post but it's very popular it
has 326 million active users per month
and it does tend to slant a lot towards
millennials so a lot of young people use
twitter and a lot of people use it to
get their news so no longer are the days
of grabbing that newspaper no longer the
days of going maybe to a media news site
online you can quickly go to twitter and
get all your news right there in a feed
an easy feed let's take a peek at
twitter here you know i can get
everything from you know somebody
posting something specific about their
dog you know all the way to a particular
job you know all the way to
industry news you know all the way to
basically an advertisement all the way
to a specific news article so it's all
here on twitter in your feed so twitter
does offer videos so videos do work well
so if i go back here you can see you
know here's a video of antonia brown
he's posting a video of his news
conference and another promotional video
so industries that capitalize on twitter
as you can guess if a lot of people go
there from their news you'll probably
see a lot of news in media and
entertainment on twitter so that doesn't
necessarily mean that you can't use
twitter for your brand it really comes
down to target audience some of the most
influential brands are slanted more
towards you know news and media but you
know you got cosmetics you got gaming
companies you got everybody's on twitter
okay it just comes down to does this
platform have your target audience and
given the nature of twitter you know how
can you get your particular brand
product or service out there and so many
characters okay some other advantages
and
best practices you can use on twitter so
i would recommend implementing twitter
cards and really all twitter cards does
is allow you to attach rich photos or
videos and different media experiences
to tweets so when you can attach you
know rich media like videos and images
to tweets it can help drive traffic and
engagement to your website all it's
going to take is just a few lines of
markup to your web page and then users
who tweet links to your content will
have a quote unquote card added to the
tweet that's visible to their followers
so that's how it works i would certainly
look to get twitter cards implemented if
you are going to use twitter as your
platform or choice for social media
marketing so it does enhance the
experience for the end user and because
allows you as an advertiser or as
somebody leveraging social media to
really enhance your tweet and it just
provides a better experience for the end
user who's looking at your tweet and so
like linkedin you can really take a look
at
who's trending what's trending on
twitter so twitter makes it easy for you
to you know follow so here they'll list
a who to follow so these who to follow
are similar to what you've been posting
or similar to your industry and then
here you can look at trends you can look
at what hashtags are trending and so if
you click on a particular hashtag you
can you know follow a particular you
know person who or an organization who
tweeted something um so you always are
reminded in twitter who to follow and so
it makes it easier for you to pick and
choose who to follow and build up your
following fairly quickly because twitter
actually provides you with opportunities
on who to follow just like linkedin just
like youtube just like instagram there
are influencers out there people who
have a large number of followers who
tweet on a regular basis who tweet
original content who get high engagement
these are influencers and these are the
people you want to engage with so look
for those people on twitter follow them
i mean the rule of thumb is if you
follow someone on twitter you know
generally they're going to follow you
back so if you can engage and follow
influencers you have an opportunity to
see not only what they're tweeting but
the ability to communicate with them and
engage with them as an influencer so
maybe they can retweet one of your
tweets and get that tweet out in front
of their followers so you can advertise
on twitter and the unique thing about
advertising on twitter you can you know
promote your tweet just like you promote
a post on facebook or instagram or
linkedin but more so i think than any
other platform is the use of hashtags
and so use appropriate relevant hashtags
i always tend to use a unique hashtag
but also depends on what you're tweeting
about if there's something that's
trending and again twitter will tell you
what's trending in terms of hashtags if
it's something you're tweeting about
then go ahead and use that hashtag as
well you can have multiple hash tags in
a particular tweet and so don't be
afraid to use a unique hashtag along
with a hashtag that's trending because
the whole idea is you want your tweet to
get noticed and then you can use chat or
some there's some other tools out there
that are available to allow you to find
people to follow and these people might
be
interested in your product or service
because you know they could fit your
target audience or you can connect with
like-minded folks who are in the same
industry or have similar products or
interests so tweet chat's available for
that reason and you want to take
advantage of these tools because again
with twitter it's easy to build a
following but you want to build a
following
that is going to engage with your tweets
so let's talk about what tools are
available for social media marketing so
when we talk about all these platforms
available to us okay we talk about
facebook and instagram and we talked
about linkedin and twitter and youtube i
mean those are popular platforms but at
the beginning of the session i mentioned
there's hundreds of social media
platforms out there and if you're
posting content on a number of them you
want to be able to organize that content
you want to be able to organize it and
schedule it you know where it makes
sense and when it makes sense you want
to stay organized and so there are tools
available to help you stay organized
tools like hootsuite buffer or sprout
social okay some of these tools are
available you know at a cost of a free
trial or at a low cost per month so
regardless of whether you're using a
free version of one of these tools or
another tool not listed or you're
actually paying for it it's worth the
investment if you're going to partake in
social media marketing and even if
you're on one platform it's still worth
it to have a social media tool available
to help you schedule and not only do
these social media tools help you
schedule they do a lot of other things
too for example they help you measure
the engagement of your posts so let's
take an example of one of them like
sprout social so if i go to sprout
social here i can see for a particular
company i'm able to see you know how my
post and get were engaged okay so i
could see daily engagements on
particular platforms i can also you know
schedule my
post so i can go ahead and pick a time
and date to schedule them and so i can
go ahead and post something and put it
in a queue to be published for example
tomorrow or next week or whatever the
case may be so
these tools do a lot for you i mean they
help you discover new followers they
give you in-depth reports they help you
stay organized and so
to me it's worth the investment to look
at one of the tools listed here you know
these are some of the more popular ones
to maybe even a free version but
regardless of how much you pay and what
tool you're using it's still worth the
investment just to make sure you're
scheduling your post at the appropriate
time so you're not posting something
back to back as an example and you're
able to measure accordingly so it's nice
to be able to go into a tool like sprout
social go to reports and
measure you know in one place you know
how twitter is performing or how
facebook's performing or how linkedin's
performing and so that's what a lot of
these tools provide is nice reporting
options and nice
scheduling options so
you can find more content you can create
by using these tools again you can
schedule efficiently analyze them and
you can use insights to improve your
campaign so a lot of these tools give
you nice insights to how the post was
actually engaged and you want to be able
to leverage that and some of these tools
if not all of them have social listening
and social listening is monitoring
what's being posted out there so what
else is posted you can take a look at
and if it's something interesting or
relevant you can go ahead and follow or
take part in that conversation okay so
that's what social listening allows you
to do and a lot of these platforms have
that as a feature so let's take a look
at tips to be a good social media
marketer so some of the important things
you should take care of are set up a
social media marketing plan when i say
set up a social media marketing plan
there's some questions you want to be
able to ask okay what platforms am i
going to use what's my objective on each
platform in fact in before you choose
the platform you want to figure out what
your objective is in terms of social
media so your objective could be
different on each platform it could be
brand awareness on facebook and it could
be promoting a particular product on
twitter your objective is going to be on
each platform you want to be able to
choose your kpis and align your kpis
with each platform meaning what metrics
are important to your business goals and
you want to be able to figure out okay
what kind of content am i going to post
on these social media platforms so you
want to get organized and put a plan in
place and then you want to create
informative shareable actionable and
relevant content and what i mean by all
that is you want to create unique
content that doesn't mean you can't
leverage what other people are doing
meaning you know if i'm you know in the
shoe business i can certainly go to nike
or adidas or puma or reebok and see what
kind of post they're putting out and
then i could take their cue and do
something similar but i want it to be
unique to me and i wanted to be unique
to my brand and i want to be able to
keep my content visual meaning i want to
be able to use as many photos and videos
as i can that's available to me because
remember videos generate better
engagement i want to be active and
responsive with my customer base meaning
the whole point of social media is to
engage and people are going to respond
they're going to comment they're going
to take part in what you post and so
whatever they do you want to be able to
respond accordingly whether that's
positive or negative and then you want
to measure metrics like conversion rates
and click-through rates so that goes
back to putting a plan in place figure
out what your metrics are and then when
you're posting on a particular platform
you want to be able to lean on those
metrics to make sure you're achieving
your goals so you want to have those
metrics in place beforehand and then you
want to be able to use those metrics
moving forward as you post the whole
idea is if you're measuring what you
post you're obviously going to want to
lean more towards what's working versus
what's not working
in a world where
a lot of competing different products
satisfy the same requirement you have a
lot of advertisers who want you to try
their product and then you have other
advertisers who want you to try their
product try my product try my product
try my product try no try my product my
product's the best no no no no my
product's the best try my product well i
want you to forget all that and try my
product forget about those other
advertisers try my product well there's
only one way you can prove your product
is better than the rest and that's with
powerful advertising and
one of the best ways to advertise on the
internet is via social media and through
the largest social media platform in the
world and that's facebook and today we
are going to talk about all the
different ads that facebook has to offer
so introduced back in 2007
the facebook ads platform has grown
tremendously over the last few years
almost four billion dollars of revenue
in one year so what does that mean that
means there's a lot of advertisers why
is there a lot of advertisers because a
lot of people use facebook it's a
popular platform so not only is it
popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on facebook you have the
opportunity to
share your product and your brand with
users who you think are going to buy
your product or associate with your
brand and on facebook you can do that a
number of different ways specifically in
somebody's news feed and specifically
that person's news feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so i
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to
your product and your brand so not only
that but you combine that target
audience with the amount of time that
people spend on facebook okay people
spend a lot of time on facebook in fact
not only do people spend a lot of time
on facebook there's a lot of people on
facebook in fact 2.27 billion in the
third quarter of 2018 and so when we say
spend a lot of time we mean going to
that facebook profile at least once a
day okay so a lot of eyeballs throughout
the day checking their news feed on
facebook facebook also enables you the
advertiser to find the perfect audience
and so that's the great combination a
lot of people on facebook and targeted
audience so it's a platform that allows
you to put your product in front of
people based on specific interest
specific demographics specific location
so you're really really putting your
product out in front of the right people
at the right time and so the other
positive and pro about facebook is it's
lesser spend greater reach and what do
we mean by that well traditionally
facebook is a little bit cheaper
than other
online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement in
somebody's news feed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on facebook
active on facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
facebook is it also has other features
those are advertising features such as
retargeting so you could target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your service or product but if they
didn't go through
the conversion process meaning they
didn't go all the way through and and
buy your product you can certainly reach
out to them again just like your
traditional retargeting options on say
google or some other advertising
platform facebook works the same way we
want to be able to reach out to people
who aren't fully committed at that point
in time but we can reach out to them at
another point in time and so facebook's
advertising platform allows us to do
that so it's a great feature that we
could take advantage of that we'll talk
about more throughout this session and
then it helps increase revenue sales and
leads and and that's primarily what most
advertisers are after you know more
revenue more sales more leads so
facebook allows us to educate our
audience again a targeted audience about
a specific product we have to offer so
the more our audience knows about our
product especially if their friends and
family members and colleagues are using
the product then the more likely they're
going to purchase so if you go back to
the other feature higher revenue less
spend this is the primary reason because
you have a chance to influence somebody
who's very targeted who's very active on
the platform and who may have
like-minded people in their life
associating with your brand and product
so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad in the
single image ad are just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own facebook
feed if you look so in fact i'll just
jump over to my facebook feed right now
and if i go there what do i see i see a
single image ad here and it's from
shopify partners so become a shopify
partner at e-commerce to your list of
qualifications so shopify must be
you know a brand that is trying to woo
my business okay so they know that
somebody that i'm associated with or
maybe i fit their demographic so they're
targeting my newsfeed with a single
image ad so that's what a single image
ad looks like it's simply just one
single image with some description and
the great thing about this single image
if you haven't noticed is the pixels are
pretty large it's 1200 by 628 so it kind
of stands out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if i go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so i can't miss it if i'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to
you know not see this ad interact in
some way especially again if i know
somebody in my network on facebook or
either that be a friend or family member
is associated with that product okay in
addition to the single image ads
facebook also has multi-product ads or
also known as carousel ads and so what
the carousel ads do is allow you in
carousel form allow you to rotate
different ads with different messaging
and different call to action and so here
you can see simply learn has a example
of a carousel ad where they're
showcasing their different courses so
this allows users to view a range of all
your different products and services if
you have multiple products and services
to offer then the carousel ads would be
a good option for you so in addition to
the carousel ads and single image ads it
gets a little bit more sophisticated in
terms of technology where facebook
allows us to offer up video ads and so
video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to you know two
minutes or excuse me all the way up to
120 minutes and so you can really really
put a lot of time and effort into the
video ads to really put your brand out
there and so the one thing about video
is it is interactive most people engage
with video and they tend to get about 10
to 30 percent more views than other
forms of ads so the video ads are really
a popular way for you as an advertiser
to put your brand or product out there
so you can put your brand and product
out there and not just a few seconds but
you know really tell a nice complete
story to get the engagement to get the
person to take the action you want them
to do so that's why video ads have
become very popular because they tend to
get more engagement more interaction
than your traditional single image ad or
say your carousel ad so facebook also
allows us to
advertise something called lead ads
and what lead ads allow us to do is
obtain user details okay so we can
acquire or get an email address or phone
number from somebody who's interested in
our product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave facebook so
if you look here in the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead ad is
that it can sync up with any crm or most
of your popular crms i should say for
example salesforce is a good example of
a crm where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the forum itself
the interaction stays right in facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really put your best
images out there with a really strong
call to action just like you see here
with the simply learn example okay so
they're showcasing you know they're
different classes and then they have to
get started today call to action to
really punctuate the slideshow ad so
what's interesting is you can really
gauge a person's interest by throwing
different products or images out there
you know you can really immerse a user's
experience here by showing different
different images and then the last type
of ad on facebook is called the
collection ad and so these ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so
if you're an advertiser
who wants to advertise several products
at once then this could be a great
option for you the collection ad so here
you can see the simply learn example
here they're showing you know not only
you know some some good slide shows and
imagery with some good messaging below
that
so before we get into the steps for
creating an ad on facebook let's talk
about some of the important changes that
have happened on facebook recently
in light of data sharing so
really what facebook's done is they made
an important change on how user data is
being used for advertising and so
what facebook's done is they removed
something called a partner category and
that was an ad targeting program which
the targeting option was based on data
provided by a third-party partner so if
you're an advertiser
you had a third-party partner that
provided some targeted options to you
that was known as a partner category and
in summary facebook has removed that
program and so now the only way you can
gain user information is if they provide
that voluntary like the lead ad for
example now you have to get the data
directly from the third party now so you
can't have that third party give you
that targeting option anymore you could
certainly again capture the data
yourself by relying on leak capture
landing pages as an example or the lead
ads and you can certainly still
outsource your advertising to lead gen
agencies and media buying companies okay
but the partner category has more or
less
gone away
okay so now let's get into
how to create a facebook app so what are
the steps so the first thing you'll have
to do is set up a campaign so
when you're setting up a campaign you
have to select
what kind of spending you want to do for
your advertisement and what you want to
achieve okay so you have to in other
words identify the goal okay so with
facebook you have two opportunities at
hand here you can jump into an auction
just like google what you're going to do
is your ads going to enter into an
auction and so this is where you can
decide how you want to spend your money
to achieve your goals by choosing an
appropriate bid strategy for the auction
so
in the auction you're competing with
other advertisers another option is you
could do reach and frequency and so with
reach and frequency you'll be able to
advertise to your brand's audience
with a fixed cost so reach and frequency
allows you as the advertiser to better
predict the delivery cost and reach of
your branding campaigns so with auction
you have more choice you have
flexibility of scalability but not a lot
of predictability okay because again
you're going into an option and your
auction is going to be competing against
other advertisers so it's this option is
available to all advertisers and you can
have pricing that you can change during
the auction price process so
that's the
unpredictability part is the pricing so
pricing can fluctuate during the auction
because you have different advertisers
who are trying to achieve the most
prominence for their ad with reach and
frequency you'll be able to plan and set
up your campaigns
and
actually set it up so it's more
predictable on how the delivery is going
to be done
with reach and frequency so
more predictability will reach some
frequency because you could set
everything up in your campaign okay so
again with the reach and frequency
you'll be able to advertise with a fixed
cost auction you're not necessarily
going with a fixed cost you're going
with more scalability flexibility on
cost that can change okay so once you
choose your objective for your
advertisement then you need to choose
the type of advertisement you want to do
and it's based on your objectives so
what's your objective is it awareness to
drive awareness is it to
drive consideration or is it to
drive a conversion so these are the
three objectives
available to you for your advertising
you want to choose one of those
objectives so let's take a look at each
of these objectives available to you
okay so let's start out with awareness
so awareness can help with creating an
interest for your product or or your
service so when we say awareness we're
thinking maybe brand awareness or
product awareness to get out there in
front of people okay so with
consideration it's a little bit
different than awareness but not so
different in that we're really aiming to
get people
to think more about our product and
service and
have them take the next step so with
awareness you're introducing your
product and service with consideration
you're getting people to take the next
step and start looking for information
about the product or service you're
advertising and then conversion is kind
of that final step if you're really
after conversion you really
want that person to make the decision
okay so they're either going to buy
or use your product or service okay and
so that's the conversion objective so
you have to choose one of these three
objectives here is it going to be
awareness is it going to be
consideration or is it going to be
conversion and so
let's go back to awareness okay so if we
look at awareness under awareness we
have brand awareness and we have reach
okay so we look at brand awareness
really what we're trying to do is we're
trying to increase awareness about our
brand or the product in our brand so
these types of objectives i mean meaning
awareness don't really emphasize
interaction okay you're not really
trying to get somebody to purchase or or
buy something or opt into a newsletter
really your goal as an advertiser with
brand awareness is to get your product
out there so people are aware that it
exists okay let alone forget about
buying it or opting into a newsletter
you really your goal with awareness and
brand awareness is to get people to see
that you're existing your product exists
your service exists it's available and
really the aim is to create high brand
recall
amongst users rather than focusing on
generating revenue so when we say you
know high brand recall what we mean is
hey if your brand is out there and you
are
really pushing it out there amongst a
large targeted demographic audience then
the next time that audience sees your
brand they're going to be able to
associate with it it's not going to be
foreign to them or the first time
they've ever seen it you really want
them to recall hey i know that brand
i've seen that brand before okay that's
kind of the reaction you want to get
from a brand awareness hey that's a cool
looking logo or man that product looked
interesting now i'm going to take the
next step so that's what brand awareness
really needs to do it needs to create
that recall for that for your audience
okay so let's take a look now at reach
so with reach reach ensures that
our advertisement is seen by the maximum
number of people within our target
audience and budget so with reach we're
really trying to reach or get our ad out
there to as many people as possible
given who we're trying to target and
given the amount of money we have to
spend so it helps to target a smaller
audience to visit your website watch
your video or even convert on your
website okay so that's with reach we're
just really trying to get it out there
okay so let's move on to
consideration so we talked about
awareness we talked about brand
awareness and reach
with consideration we have you know
people who are willing to take that next
step okay so if we're targeting a
specific demographic and we're looking
at consideration we really want them to
do something with our ad we don't want
them just to recall it or see it for the
first time we want them to take that
next step and so with consideration we
have traffic so if we have an ad you
know the least we want somebody to do
who's seen our brand before is at least
click on our ad okay so we want people
to
you know click on our ad
and go to our website really that's a
goal of consideration is hey i know that
brand i've seen that brand before let me
click on this and see what they have to
offer so this might involve them
listening to a podcast or reading an
article
or being introduced to an app so really
you're setting the stage for
further down the funnel by
further introducing them to something
that's on your website so you really
want them to take that next baby step
the next baby step is clicking on the ad
going to your site and further educating
themselves about your particular product
or surface so facebook shows these
advertisements to people within your
target audience based on their past
behavior okay so that's a great thing
about facebook it's you can really
really get targeted here with your
audience okay so engagement so we talk
about traffic we're gonna talk about
engagement so these types of ads are
useful when we want users to engage more
with our ad for example we can you know
really have an advertisement or post
that will allow people to like it they
can respond
or even take advantage of an offer so
that's what we mean by engagement we
really want people to react
positively within facebook about our ad
or our post okay so it can help with
building engagement an engagement
audience for your facebook page that can
be used for future advertising campaigns
so
we're really getting people to
take that next step and what's that next
step if they don't go to our website
they can like what we have to say
and then we can have app installs so
that's another option to us for
consideration so app installs are great
if we want to send users to an app store
for example so they can download our app
so for really really pushing an app that
we just developed then an app install
could be a good opportunity under
consideration to allow that user to take
the next step and download your app so
that that at a later stage they can go
and interact with the app we have video
views so video views are are good
advertisements when you're promoting
your product or service and you really
want a high number of views so remember
early on we were talking about the types
of ads available on facebook we talked
about video views how they get 10 to 30
percent more
engagement well that's really what we
want videos to do under consideration we
really want people to understand what
we're trying to do and really engage
with our product and so they could turn
around and like it they could turn
around and um push it out to their
friends so video you we know is high
engaging with an audience and so having
a video allows you to really allow that
video to potentially go viral okay so
video views help users engage and
enables the creation of an audience
which can be used for future
advertisements okay so highly engageable
you know interactive allows people to
you know really really take that next
step with your product or service by
really getting to know what you're all
about okay then we have lead generation
so lead generation is interesting
because remember those leads that we
mentioned in the when we're talking
about the type of ads that facebook has
to offer well lead ads or you know if
you have a lead generation type ad
really what you could do is you can just
collect the information so if really
somebody's interested in your product or
service right away then you can generate
a lead ad and allow them to say hey you
know what i'm interested i'm going to
sign up for your newsletter or yes i'm
interested in your product or your
future any future giveaway or promotion
you have to offer here here's my email
address here's my name here's my phone
number so lead ads are great for
consideration because somebody knows
your ad they've likely engaged with you
they like what you have to say and
they're willing to take that next step
and you can integrate your lead ads with
third-party apps that's tied to your crm
so for example salesforce lead ads can
sync up right with salesforce and then
you can then follow up with that user at
a later point so that's consideration so
we have a lot of good options available
to us under consideration you know we
could drive traffic
video views app installs just regular
engagement you know and then we got
legion so we got a lot of opportunities
for consideration if you're really
trying to target people who are already
familiar with your brand or product or
service and then last but certainly not
least we have messaging so with messages
you know these ads aim to convert a
user's interest in a product to a
successful sale or conversion so it
targets people who are more likely to
respond through messenger so facebook
messenger is a service that is
integrated nicely in with facebook and
so with facebook messenger you know you
can communicate with that person
directly just through messenger okay so
it could be a chat bot or it can be a
rep who can act as customer support or
provide more information about the
product or service so you can use
messenger to your advantage you can talk
right away to somebody who is really
interested in considering your product
or service so this is kind of the
capstone of consideration because it
takes into account one of facebook's
most popular features which is messenger
and allows you as an advertiser to use
that feature to engage with your
targeted audience directly let's turn
our attention to the last objective
which is conversion so under conversions
we have conversions product catalog
sales and store visits so
for conversions really this is the end
of the funnel this is really the part of
the funnel where we want people to take
action so
ads related to the objective of
conversions really aims to increase you
know whatever the goal is of your
website so if it means signups or
registrations for your services or sales
or downloads or any desired action on
your website then that's the conversion
okay so that's what we're aiming to
achieve when we are tying our ads to
conversions okay so you have conversions
and you have your pure product product
catalog sales so for product catalog
sales these could be ads to help promote
your ecommerce store or other products
in your store portfolio you know so
think of amazon think about all the
products they have on their website you
know they are probably likely going to
choose you know product catalog sales
because it really will help really push
traffic to the store and really get
somebody to convert either in a for a
particular product or get them to look
at other product categories and buy
something there so
really really product catalog sales are
really great for future campaigns when
you're really looking for sales and then
we have store visits and so store visits
really help direct traffic to your
location and really helps deliver ads
based on your users current location
okay so if we really want to get
somebody to the store if you have a
brick and mortar store for example and
then you can use store visits as your
objective under conversions to really
drive traffic to that location so that's
what store visits are we really want
people to you know take that next step
get to your store and check out your
store and purchase so that's what store
visits are under the conversions
objective so within each of these
advertisement objectives we can create
split tests also known as a b testing
and the reason why we call it a b
testing because what you're doing is
you're testing one variable from the
other so really you have two
advertisements that really are the same
except the only difference is there's
one thing that's altered from the other
so in this example we have a
with one promotion and then we have b
which is the same audience same
everything except a different promotion
so you're really changing one variable
when you do a split test and so that's
available to facebook just like any
other type of advertising let's say you
do you know search advertising on google
split testing's available let's say you
do email marketing split testing is
available with subject clients
facebook's no different it allows split
testing or allows you to use two
versions of the same ad and able to
change one of those parameters so you
can see really what ads performs best
that's the whole idea behind a split
test okay so if it's the original sales
sale of 25 off then hey so be it you
know it works because you tested it
against another variation and then the
great thing about testing it never ends
so if 25 off works over say 2 000
off then you try something else to see
if that will increase sales that's the
whole idea behind testing is you only
want you always want to see what works
okay so really what it comes down to is
it can be really it could be a
promotional offer or it could be
something as simple as changing the call
to action you know a different color on
the call to action it could be anything
you want to test as long as you're able
to you know figure out what works and
then apply what works so you can
continue to improve your advertising
that's really the whole idea behind a b
testing okay so it really is identifying
an element you want to test and then
really once you identify that element
and you test it and you know it wins
then you can move on other things to
figure out what else works so if you
tested the promotion then go on to the
cta so
you could test things like
colors and call to actions and imaging
and messaging and positioning and you
could play around with your target
audience and test a segment of a target
audience against another so
there's lots of things you could test
when you a b test the most important
thing to note though when you a b test
is you always want to keep in mind what
metric you want to measure the test up
against so some of the metrics you could
use are click-through rate which is ctr
cost per click cpc you can use
conversion rate also known as cr or just
clicks the whole idea is when you do a
test and you're testing a promotional
offer you're testing even the call to
action you need to measure that up
against a metric so that metric is
what's going to determine the winner and
so
it doesn't have to be overly complicated
it could be as simple as testing you
know one call to action against another
and determining which one gets more
clicks and if one gets more clicks than
the other then hey you know you have a
winner okay let's go through the steps
of creating a new campaign on facebook
using facebook's ads manager so you're
gonna log into facebook.com
ads manager and you're just gonna click
on the create new campaign button and
when you do that you're gonna see a
screen that looks just like this and
you're gonna go through a series of
steps so as we presented earlier the
first step is always choosing your
objective so we have awareness
consideration and conversion so recall
that awareness was getting your brand
out there to people who never seen your
brand or product or service before so
it's a matter of trying to reach as many
people as you can to get your brand out
there and so you have brand awareness or
you have reach remember one is
controlled one is uncontrolled okay so
reach is a little bit more control
because you can set your budget okay and
you can control your budget a little bit
better so brand awareness is just
getting it out there having facebook
plop it in front of the ad in front of
as many people as possible
with reach you are trying to maximize
how many people you show your ad to but
it is a little bit more controlled
against the budget okay either way
choose an awareness is going to set the
objective of trying to maximize your
exposure for your brand your product or
your service okay if somebody
has already seen your brand or
somebody's already familiar with your
product or your services then you may
want to choose the objective of
consideration and so these are people
who again are already familiar who you
want to take that next step remember
facebook is an environment where you're
targeting a specific audience so you're
targeting people you know have likely
seen your brand product or service so
you want to take that next step that's
what you want them to do okay so here
under consideration we have traffic
engagement app installs video views lead
gen or messages all of these choices are
getting somebody to do something for you
for example app installs you want them
to install your app or engagement you
want them to like or share your post
video views watching your video or
messaging you want them to interact with
you via facebook's messenger
feature so all of these are interactions
of some sort where somebody's taking
that next step they've seen your brand
they're interested but you they're not
ready quite ready to purchase yet okay
so that's what consideration is then you
have conversion this is people in the
funnel who you know or think you know
want to convert and when i say think you
know meaning you know you're really
targeting people who you've targeted
before who
maybe has purchased from you before or
is exactly the type of audience you're
looking to purchase okay so you have
conversions you have catalog sales and
you have store traffic meaning driving
foot traffic to a store okay so these
are people further down the funnel who
you don't necessarily want to take a
smaller action like just share your
facebook post or provide their email
address and name okay so you want them
to purchase so these are three marketing
objectives you're gonna choose from
okay so we're just gonna choose
conversions for the sake of this example
and then when we go to choose
conversions remember we can create a a b
split test okay so that's a choice you
should always choose because you always
want to be testing something okay in
this case we might want to test the ad
we might want to test say the call to
action because we're looking for
conversions so it could be as simple as
having one ad with a buy more and the
other way that says hey check out our
website so you have that option to a b
split test and then you have budget
optimization which basically allows you
to
set your budget evenly across your
different ads okay and so what
facebook's gonna do is basically make
sure that the best performing ad is
going to be seen more often so that's
budget optimization you're maximizing
your budget towards an ad or ads
that
you want to be able to have more control
over in terms of what's working and
what's not working versus not selecting
this option your ads are just going to
randomly show and there's not going to
be any necessary control over how much
spend each ad gets so that's the first
step in creating your campaign it's
always choosing your objective with a
few options built in
so the next step in the process
is ad set
okay and as you can see here before you
even get to ad set what
facebook is prompting us to do is look
at
basically how the a b test is going to
work so
here they're explaining how an a b split
test works okay so
basically what an a b split test does is
serve up 50 50. the original versus
a variation of the original
okay so that's more or less how an a b
split test works and so facebook is
doing us some good by showing us this
messaging okay because that's what we
chose now notice we chose conversions
objective
okay so what we're going to be required
to do is put a conversion pixel on our
website so that facebook can actually
track conversions and so what we want
people to do is purchase
and so what we need to do then is
add a facebook pixel
to our website so that facebook can
actually track how many people
purchase from your campaign so this is
very important and so if you're driving
traffic to your website and you want
them to convert then you need to make
sure all the tracking's in place
so the next step in setting up your ads
is setting up an offer so if you have an
offer that you want to provide go ahead
and select
on because the default is set to off
okay what you could do is you can
associate it with
your particular
company page
on facebook and then you're going to
create your offer so i'm going to put my
offer title i'm going to put a little
bit more details in there i can put an
end date when the offer expires in a
specific time so
based on what you put this is what
people is going to see with the ad and
here
you have the redemption section where
you can have people redeem the offer
online or online and in store so if it's
online you need to provide facebook with
the url
where people can go and redeem that that
promotion that offer and then you have a
chance an opportunity to add a
particular code so you don't necessarily
have to have a code with your offer it
could be a one-time code it can be a
unique code okay or unique codes okay
and then you have an advanced option
here and this advanced option is pretty
important because if you're
setting up an offer and you only want a
specific number of people to see that
offer then and you don't want them to
share that offer then what you could do
is hide the share option so that way
people won't be able to share the
promotion with friends or family or
whatnot now they could still copy and
paste the link of the offer but they
won't be able to easily do it with the
share option
and uh here you can put some terms and
conditions
so that's the offer okay and it's pretty
intuitive in the wizard
my recommendation is you should always
put out an offer to get people to
you know again your objective is to get
people to convert so an offer always
helps incentivize conversions
okay here we have our variable because
we're testing we're split testing okay
so
here we're we're choosing what we want
to split test so if we choose creative
basically what we're doing is we're
telling facebook we want to test our
creative our ad and so now what we're
going to do is we're going to select the
audience and so we could choose a custom
audience a look-alike or all so here you
can see we have a look-alike and a
look-alike basically is basically what
facebook does is they're trying to find
people who are very similar to your
customers okay so that's who you want to
target people who look like your
customers on facebook okay so you could
choose a look-alike audience you could
choose a custom audience if you already
have one
so we're going to create a new custom
audience here
and
basically what we want them to do is
website traffic
and we're just going to call it website
traffic and basically it's going to be
all website visitors
okay so we're going to create this
audience here
so we've done that and basically now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to tell facebook okay if our audience is
all website visitors where are those
visitors going to come from so we want
to choose a location so it could be
everyone in a particular location
everyone who lives in a particular
location or recently in the location or
traveling in a location okay so here you
can see we have it set to united states
but we can always change that so you can
really pick and choose areas or cities
and even exclude areas
you can even upload locations in bulk so
if you have a specific set of locations
you can upload that
after you choose your location you're
then going to choose your age so
here you have if you look all the way
down to 13 years of age and then your
range goes all the way up to 65 years of
age
then we have our gender we can choose
both men and women or just men and just
women and then we can target a specific
language if we want to target spanish
people or people who speak spanish then
we can choose spanish notice we can add
multiple languages
okay so if we want to do some specific
targeting for example we can do interest
or specific behavior so if i click
suggestions then for example facebook's
going to offer us up some suggestions so
if we want to target people who have an
interest in foreign language or charity
and causes or mindfulness or it could be
specific job titles okay so we can get
really detailed with our targeting we
also have connections
so who do we want to target so are these
people who like our page who are friends
of people who like our page we can also
exclude people who like our pitch okay
so remember your advertising is tied to
a facebook page however you could still
drive that traffic to your website but
what facebook does is once you connect
your ad or your campaign to a facebook
page then they have an idea of the
profile then they have an idea of what
type of community you have on facebook
okay so that really helps them
offer you more detailed targeting in the
form of connections okay so when we're
done we could save the audience
so i'm just gonna name it uh
english and spanish click save okay now
i have my audience saved and the
important thing here is that this
audience is saved we can use it at a
later date or if we're setting up a new
campaign we can pull from the same
audience under use a saved audience so
if i just type in english in spanish
you'll see my audience here
okay and we can always edit it if we
need to
okay so next is the placements section
so here placements is where we want to
show our ads okay so we want to be able
to place our ads in the proper placement
and so what facebook does is they
actually recommend you do an auto
placement and so facebook will based on
your audience show your ad in different
spots or different placements throughout
facebook
based on the people you're trying to
target the audience okay so in this case
we're targeting both spanish and english
okay and we're targeting 13 to 65 year
olds who live in the united states and
so what facebook's going to do then
because we have automatic placement set
up is they're going to be able to place
our ads based on our target audience so
this is an option i always recommend you
do and facebook recommends as well if
you're specific about where you want
your ad to be placed then you can just
select edit placements and notice when
you select edit placements here you have
different options not only on facebook
but on instagram as well okay and
facebook's network and in facebook
messenger so you have all these
different options available to you if
you really want your
your ad placed in a specific position so
here if i just scroll over here i can
see what it looks like in a feed in
stream video
i can scroll down to instagram that's
what it looks like in a feed on
instagram okay uh you have instagram
stories if i want to go and advertise on
facebook messenger then i have some
options here
in
messenger inbox or sponsored messages
okay so you have a lot of options
available under edit placements meaning
picking your placement specifically but
again i recommend as does facebook just
go with the recommended placements for
now unless you're really clear and you
really understand how
facebook works and where these
placements are actually going to be but
remember if you choose edit placements
and place it in a specific position
let's just say on messenger inbox
remember your audience may not be there
so going with the automatic placements
you know is a way for facebook to help
you get your ad in front of the right
audience
here the next section delivery
optimization okay how much
of our ads are optimized and delivered
so
remember we chose conversions here so
we're going to optimize our ads for
conversions so what facebook's going to
do is take into account each conversion
that each ad is getting and they're
going to show that ad that's getting
more conversions more often than the ads
that aren't getting as many conversions
okay so they're optimizing the ad
delivery based on
how many conversions each ad gets and
there's an option in here as well so
you can put a cost control in place so
you have an average cost per purchase
okay so facebook will aim to get the
most purchases and spend your entire
budget okay if you put in an average
cost per purchase so for example if i'm
selling t-shirts i may not want my
average cost per purchase to be
twenty dollars because i'm not going to
make any money so i'm probably going to
choose maybe two three four even as high
as five dollars on a cost per purchase
because i want to make sure i'm not
spending a lot of money just to get a
purchase so you have that option
available to you to put in as a cost
control
and here we have a conversion window
and so what this conversion window is
going to do is
you know help facebook
optimize your ads a little bit better
based on the number of conversions that
happen in this window
okay so you have some other options in
here you want to do standard delivery
ad scheduling you can run your ads on a
schedule
or you can run them all the time
okay
and then moving down to the next option
in our ad set
is we have split test and
split test budget and schedule so
we have the opportunity to put a budget
in place for our ads okay and we can
schedule the the a b test to start
running immediately if we want to or we
can have the a b test run at a specific
date and we can have it run for a
specific period of time so this goes all
the way back to the first option where
we chose a b split test on step one so
we have a series of options available to
us for the split test
okay once we
have all our options in place okay we're
going to click continue
and then the final step is actually
setting up our ads okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
name our ad in this case add a okay it's
going to be tied to a facebook page
it's going to be tied to an instagram
account
and then we can choose the format of our
ad so remember we have a lot of
different options available to us on
facebook we have the carousel which
allows us to have
multiple images scrolling horizontally
we can have that single image ad we can
have a video we can have a collection of
images
so we have a lot of options available to
us
and then what we could do is we can link
up
our ad to a specific page okay now
before we do that we want to be able to
upload our images okay so we're going to
manually choose images videos and links
okay
and then we're going to add some text to
support that image
okay and so when we add text in for our
ad we have the option of setting up a
headline actually it's not an option
it's actually mandatory the description
is actually optional okay but my
recommendation is you want to add a
headline that's going to grab attention
and you want to add a description to
support that headline so i always
recommend
putting in a description and then once
you do that you're going to add your
destination url
and then you're going to be able to
preview your ad okay so
if we have an image here okay we can
just say hey this
come check out
our new product and so as i add
this information i'll be able to view it
on the right side
okay so it looks like facebook at this
point is not able to view the image but
normally you're able to see a preview in
this case it's on the mobile news feed
so if we drop down we can see desktop
right column okay so we need to really
choose our images so we're going to
change an image here let's see if i can
choose another image
okay i'm gonna choose an image here
and so now i can see the image
now i could see the headline um and and
then i could see what it looks like just
by changing the placement okay so if i
want to choose facebook stories whoops
that's not available
if i go to
for example instant articles okay
here i can see
what my ad looks like on instant
articles
so wasn't available on certain
placements because of the type of ad we
chose but the point being when you set
up your ad and you choose your image and
you write your headline and put your
destination url in then you'll be able
to preview it on certain placements
depending on what type of ads you chose
okay once you're once you're set up and
remember we're setting up a b testing so
that was add one now we want to test the
second ad or the variation and so
basically what we want to do is choose
the same type of format then what we
want to do is pick a variation what is
that variation going to be it could be
maybe just a different headline okay or
it could be a different url
you need to decide what it is you're
going to test
once you decide what you test you're
going to add that to variation b
once you add the variation b
then you have both ads set up
once you confirm facebook is going to
confirm for you whether the ads meet
their criteria okay and if it doesn't in
this case you could see we have some
errors
then we need to go back and fix them so
i'm going to go back and choose single
image ad okay so now
i can just choose my one image
so i can browse a library of images i
already have
now here's my single image ad i'm going
to add some text in there a website url
a headline
remember you want it to be catchy okay
you can change the call to action here
okay you can add multiple languages so
you have a lot of options depending on
the type of format you choose
so remember we chose a b test so
we're going to
set up both ads add a and add b okay and
when we do that again we can have
facebook review it once they review it
we they can confirm this you can see we
still have some errors on
add a so let's go ahead and fix that i'm
going to choose single image because
that's what add b is i'm going to browse
my library maybe i'll just test a
different image i'm going to click
continue
and so basically keep everything the
same what i'll test is maybe the image
so you have to go into an a b test
knowing what it is you want to test
ahead of time okay once you do that
you're going to go ahead and continue to
add b and then once you do that um here
let's go ahead and fix this error here
um
the link field so let's just go ahead
and put a link in there
continue to add b
once i confirm then i have two ads ready
to go on specific placements or excuse
me automatic placements and this option
is that's the option we chose and
basically the ads are set to
optimization against conversions we have
a set budget and we're going to be able
to then once our ads go live is look at
some reports to see how they're
performing so that's the steps in
setting up a campaign
on facebook you're choosing your
objective okay then you're setting up
your ad set okay and then once you set
up your ad set with your target audience
then you're actually going through the
motions in this case we set up two ads
because we chose a b testing okay
and if you didn't choose a b testing
then you would just choose to set up the
first ad and once you do that you
confirm and voila your campaign is set
up based on these three steps okay so
let's uh review with some do's and
don'ts of facebook so we mentioned the
types of ad that facebook has we
mentioned how to set up a facebook ad
itself and choosing the right
objectives and so some of the do's
involved are what just what i mentioned
we always want to do a b testing on our
ads whether that's again just changing
out the color we're changing out an
image you always want to do a b testing
because facebook has you know carousel
ads and because they have you know ads
that can rotate and you can use even
video with your ads you always want to
take advantage of what's given to you
and so facebook allows you to do it do
it so if you have the opportunity to
have a video at then use the video ad
highly recommend it remember video ads
have higher engagement so definite do is
use engaging videos and imagery so you
don't necessarily have to use a static
ad or image ad you can use the carousel
for example or the presentation mode
where you can show multiple images to
really showcase your product and service
so with all the advertising that you do
you always want to align your messaging
so
use a message that will stay with the
audience okay so use something that's
going to be able to trigger remember it
depends on the funnel and where you're
at so if your awareness or consideration
or conversion that has to align with
your messaging so if you're you know
targeting ads you know when you want
people to convert then your message is
going to be as such you're going to talk
to people as if you want them to convert
as if they're ready to convert and you
want to keep your message consistent and
simple so remember the ads are available
to you and you have so many different
features available to you within those
ads but that doesn't mean you gotta
convolute it with messaging so keep your
message
consistent and simple if it's brand
awareness you know definitely keep your
message simple so that people can
understand exactly what it is your
product or service is all about then you
want to alter your reach so that the ads
are shown to the appropriate audience
okay so you always want to keep in mind
who you're trying to target okay so you
don't want to target somebody who's not
in your demographic so alter your reach
so that the ads are shown to the
appropriate audience remember you have
you know reach available to you and
reach allows you to really pick and
choose exactly who you're targeting to
and how often remember you want to reach
as many people as possible but you don't
want to reach the wrong people some of
the don'ts to stay some things you want
to stay away from is you don't want to
put all your money on one campaign so
you want to separate out your budget
allocate your budget across different
campaigns and i would even take that a
step further and you know put different
types of ads in different campaigns just
to see what works so again it depends on
where you're at in the funnel if it's
just brand awareness okay maybe create a
campaign for that if it's consideration
create a campaign for that because in
consideration you might have lead ads in
there i say with the awareness campaign
you may just have a single image ad okay
just to introduce your product to
somebody with a simple message so
you want to
you know definitely think about how you
want to separate out your campaigns but
don't be afraid to separate your
campaigns by the type of ads
don't put too much information in the
ads remember keep it consistent and keep
it simple that's the best thing i can
say and remember a lot of these ads are
image based so images tell a thousand
words they tell a thousand stories a
video will do the job if you have to say
too much so if you're saying too much
think about a video but if you're using
an image let the image tell the story
okay don't forget to proofread your ads
i can't stress that enough remember if
you're an awareness campaign this is the
first time somebody's seen your product
or service so you definitely want to get
the messaging not only correct meaning
consistent and simple but grammatically
correct you don't want to be so active
on your facebook page so you know when i
say being don't be so active on your
facebook page really it depends on where
you're at you're trying to introduce a
product or service so that doesn't mean
that you need to go out and tell
everybody to start buying your product
remember these people may not even know
who you are what product and service you
offer so you want to be able to approach
your audience on your facebook page in a
manner which is suitable for your
audience and then have an image that
doesn't correspond to the product being
advertised so you you want to be able to
you know have an image that does
correspond so if you're targeting a
specific audience with a specific
product then make sure the image on your
facebook page aligns with that okay
don't be inconsistent don't confuse the
audience you know be consistent with
your imagery as well as your messaging
okay so those are some of the don't see
things you want to stay away from when
you're advertising today we're going to
cover a number of tips to help you gain
a better advantage on advertising on
facebook so let's get right to it with
tip number one and with tip number one
not all advertisements need to sell
something so remember you have different
objectives on facebook you can advertise
an event you can promote a customer
story you can send traffic to your
website or you can get them to download
an app so it all goes back to your
objective so if we go to facebook and i
want to create an ad remember my first
option is to create an objective so you
have awareness you have consideration
you have conversion so depending on what
you want somebody to do that's the
objective you're gonna choose so just
keep that in mind when you're setting up
your campaign on facebook you need to
align your objective with what you want
people to do tip number two we want to
use facebook messenger for advertising
so facebook messenger is a feature that
can be used with advertising on facebook
and it's a good tool it's a good
practice because it allows you to as the
advertiser to commute with individuals
directly so it's a feature that you
should take advantage of because it
allows you to quickly engage with your
target audience so that's the beauty of
leveraging facebook messenger with your
advertising the communication tools
available and for you to engage with
your target audience so it's great for
not only interacting but taking care of
any other objections that they have as
an as an audience or prospective client
so you can answer any concerns they have
right away so it's a lot more personal
and interactive than other forms of
advertising because you're directly
communicating with your audience tip
three use video advertisements i can't
stress this enough video is very
engaging in fact it's not only engaging
but it's very easy to use so if we go to
facebook really facebook is telling us
for video all we need to do is have
basically a phone handy and an app and
just to be able to upload it so with
facebook video you can really drive
awareness and you can really drive sales
when you can really make some really
splashy videos on facebook all you need
is a mobile camera so with facebook
videos it's really very easy to create
you just gotta be creative that's really
the key to videos you know they're going
to be engaging to the end user say
something do something that's going to
really grab their attention and get them
to do what you want them to do so these
are just some of the examples you can
see on facebook and you can see how
creative advertisers are getting you
know clear call to action great video or
great imagery good promotional use so
there's a lot you can do with video and
really make it interactive so i can't
stress video enough as an option for
facebook it really is one of the better
features of facebook advertising and
really very limited use of resources all
you need is that web camera an app and
the ability to upload that video that's
really it for video advertisements so
keep in mind and the reason why i'm
harping on those video ads is they tend
to outperform your traditional facebook
image ads in other formats like the
carousel or the presentation mode so
there's other types of formats on
facebook video tends to give it that
extra edge because it's very interactive
and in the form of interactivity comes
engagement so in this example you know
people are going to react they're going
to comment they're going to share the
video and that's what you want as an
advertiser you want to grab as much
reach as possible towards your target
audience and so video will help you do
that it will help you not only engage
with the person but allow that video to
be shared and expand your reach towards
your target audience so remember video
can range from a few seconds all the way
up to 120 minutes so you're really gonna
get more views regardless of how long
the video is because it's just gonna be
so interactive so just keep that in mind
it doesn't have to be full on 120
minutes it could be you know anywhere
from one to five minutes you know to me
that's probably a good range but just
know that you have that lead way if you
wanted to so remember video ads always
perform better than single image ads or
other type of image ad formats on
facebook and they also perform better
when they have subtitle support so just
keep that in mind as well because you
may have you know individuals watching
the video from you know different
countries speaking different languages
say tip four when you're placing your
advertisement where you place your
advertising will play an important role
in deciding how many people come across
it so facebook offers a number of
different options to choose from so
remember you got the news feed you got
instant articles right column you got
suggested videos so you got a lot of
options at your disposal there's lots of
other options too so you can have
facebook actually automatically place
your ads or you can specifically tell
facebook where you want to place your
ads and that's all part of the facebook
setup so if we go to facebook and then
we go to create your campaign so if we
close ad set here is where we're going
to be able to choose our placement if we
click on choose placement we'll be able
to you know be able to allow facebook to
place it or we can edit the placement
specifically so just keep that in mind
you have a lot of different options here
again feeds and stuff articles in-stream
videos you got rycom you even have
instagram so you have a lot of options
available to you so my recommendation
and facebook's recommendation is always
go with the auto placement but you could
specifically choose your placement if
you want to when you're setting up your
campaign so start the advertising on the
news feed could be recommended the news
feed is where you're probably going to
get your most eyeballs most users spend
most of their time there and it has the
highest chance of grabbing their
attention so the news feed could be a
good place to start again you can have
it at auto placement and your ads may be
there as well or you can specifically
choose just the news feed or other
placements so tip four just be careful
where you place your ad it's really
important you wanna place your ad where
you're gonna get eyeballs so tip five
facebook ads also offer you the option
to advertise on instagram so you have
that option available to you as i
mentioned in tip four you have the
option to advertise through stories
carousel ads photo ads and video ads so
again that's all part of the ad setup
when you go to choose your placements
here you got instagram feed you get
instagram stories and again with both of
those placements on instagram you can
work with several different types of ads
including that carousel ad including
that video ad so just keep that in mind
that instagram is an option for you take
advantage of it there's a lot more
eyeballs on instagram these days and it
plays off nicely with what you're trying
to do with facebook so go ahead and give
it a try okay so let's take a quick
break from the first few tips we went
over and let's take a look at an ad so
it's an ad break time so let's take a
look at this and this is by new
scientist and so what makes this ad so
great well there's been a lot of shake
up in the world today about fake news
you know what is fake news so new
scientist is actually playing off of
that they're mentioning hey fake news
not in our world so they're actually
playing off of that that term fake news
and so that's an attention grabber so i
think that's what makes this look so
good but this is a single image ad and
you can see here they're promoting this
ad with a promotion so try 12 weeks for
just 36 euros okay so they have a
promotion in there so and you notice
they the image of the you know the
magazine they're also displaying that
hey you can look at this digitally on a
laptop a tablet or a mobile phone so you
have other options as well so they show
you that in the image which is placed on
the right side of their messaging so for
me this is a good ad because of the
placement of the image the type of image
they're using the play on fake news and
the promotion that they're offering up
so this is really a good ad it's very
eye-catching and hopefully the promotion
is good enough to get you to sign up
okay so tip number six so tip number six
we wanna continuously do a b testing you
want to always have this option going
for you you want to be able to test
variation a versus variation b because
you want to be able to find out what
works and what doesn't work with your
audience and on top of that it helps you
really put your best foot forward by
showing your best ad so by doing a b
testing you're getting feedback from the
audience and turning that feedback into
positive returns so you're then turning
your ad that does work well in front of
an audience and you're going to continue
to do that so a b testing is always a
good option so remember when you're
setting up your ad in facebook go ahead
and choose to have your a b test set up
and when you do that you choose that
option you're going to be able to then
go in and choose what it is you want to
test with that a and then with add b so
you're going to again align your tests
with a facebook page you're going to
choose an ad format once you choose your
ad format then you're going to be able
to go ahead and you know put your ad in
there and then you're going to choose
your call to action so the whole idea
behind an a b test is you want to be
able to find what it is you want to test
is that going to be the
call to action is it going to be the
messaging is it going to be the ad
format so there are lots of things you
can test with facebook on a b testing so
it's all part of the ad setup so things
you can change again are the color of
the elements imaging text the call to
action the position of the ad there's
lots of things you could test that's all
part of the facebook setup so the thing
is you want to continuously test that's
the key continuously test certain
elements of an ad so testing can be done
initially on broader elements and then
smaller finer details like statements in
your ad copy so my advice is when you're
actually setting this up on facebook you
know think ahead think what it is you
want to choose to test my advice is
maybe start out with a call to action so
if you're in facebook itself you know
you have an opportunity to test
different call to action try that that's
an easy way to test and then you know
when you test the call to action once
you find out what works and doesn't work
then you can move on to something more
sophisticated like maybe the image type
or maybe trying different types of
imagery or ad types like the carousel
versus single image so start small start
easy and then work your way up tip
number seven so we want to choose an
appropriate call to action in your
advertisements that will attract
potential customers so what do we mean
well you have different call to actions
available to you you want to choose one
that aligns with your ad so for example
the simply learn ad about hey learn how
seo works search engine optimization so
if you're trying to get somebody to you
know learn or take one of your courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up so
that's the key we want them to sign up
so use a call to action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interest it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do if it's you know customers
in the buying process
then that's our objective is to get
conversions then we want to move
somebody over to a product page and get
them to purchase you know if it's
focusing on just website visits then
maybe it's the objective of
consideration maybe you just want to get
people to your website to learn more
about your product so that's the whole
idea behind you know choosing uh the
right you know objective uh because you
want to align the objective with your ad
okay so tip number nine
create look-alike audiences and i'd like
lookalike audience because what facebook
does is they create an audience that's
similar to the audience you're already
advertising to or customer base you
already have so in other words facebook
already has an idea of who your audience
is you can also you know provide them
with additional information like an
email list to give them a better sense
of who your audience is and then what
facebook does is they take that
information and they'll put your ad in
front of an audience that looks just
like the audience you already have
that's why they call it a look-alike
audience so it's a great feature by
facebook it really allows you to reach a
target audience an audience is very
similar to the audience you currently
have in one example provide facebook
with an email list with that email list
they're going to be able to map that
email list and be able to identify an
audience that you could target so that's
the whole idea behind lookalike audience
it's a great feature by facebook
definitely recommend taking advantage of
that why because it will increase the
number of people who will find your
advertisement relevant remember you're
targeting people who are similar to your
actual audience to your the people who
are already connected with your brand or
already liking your page so if they're
similar to those people then the chances
of them engaging with you are going to
be greater so lookalike audiences tend
to perform well because you're targeting
an audience that's very similar to your
actual audience tip number 10 so use the
golden point rule on your ad creator so
what do we mean by golden point rule
well let's take this ad here as an
example so what we want to do is we want
to divide the creative into nine equally
sized boxes so what we want to do is
draw two horizontal lines and two
vertical lines just like a tic-tac-toe
box and so ideally what we want to do is
place the main subject of your ad in the
cross sections of the drawn lines and so
what that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there as a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's take
a look at another ad here on facebook
and this one's by blue apron and so of
all the tips we've talked about this
particular ad takes into account a lot
of them okay so this is again they're
using multiple images in this ad here so
again what they're doing promotion
they're offering up a 30 off promotion
here and what they're asking you to do
is sign up to get that 30 off so you
could see the call to action we already
mentioned that on one of our tips the
call to action matches the ad so they're
asking to sign up they're using really
good imagery here and they're supporting
that with you know some good copy and
text so this is what makes this ad so
good i mean who doesn't like good
looking food or tasty food and healthy
food okay so they're definitely taking
advantage of the imagery with a
promotion and with a good call to action
and so remember we want to a b test so
blue apron is likely testing this ad so
what they could do with this is test
different imagery or they could test a
different promotion so there's a lot
they can do here on the a b testing side
so
for me if i were to test this yeah i
would probably be testing the imagery
because we want to be able to see what
images get people to sign up
alternatively we can also test the offer
as well what offer is going to get
somebody to click on that sign up button
so ideally there's a lot to do here from
the a b test standpoint and the way
they've structured this ad it makes it
very easy to test so that's what makes
this ad really good is shows good
imagery has a good promotion and aligns
the cta tip number 11 so we want to
place the product in the right hand of
your creative so the right side should
contain our product imagery so why is
that why because there's been a study
called the perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation and that states
that depending on where a product is
placed users would react differently to
it and so the study found that users
tend to react more positively when the
product is placed on the right side of
the ad creative so here you can see
countdown to black friday this is an
amazon related ad and you can see the
product is basically a letterbox which
is placed on the right side so it's a
black friday ad they didn't place the
image on the left side they placed on
the right side because people tend to
react positively when the product image
is on the right side so keep that in
mind when you're placing your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12 don't use images that have
more than 20
text okay so you want to use images that
are clean remember that blue apron image
we looked at and that was a very clean
image of food no text overlaying the
image so we want to try and stay away
from images that have text on the
overlay okay so there's no limit to how
much text you can add to your creative
but your facebook and myself recommend
hey the lesser text you have the more
likely it is for your ad to have its
desired impact meaning somebody's going
to click on that ad okay so keep that in
mind let the image do the talking for
you you don't necessarily need to
overwhelm the image with words or
messages tip number 13 so we want to use
an ad creative that's attention grabbing
and is relevant for your business so
again going back to that blue apron ad
hey who doesn't like good looking food
good looking healthy food green food
well switching gears we're looking at a
nike ad who doesn't like a good looking
shoe here this is a good running shoe
and nike is definitely taking advantage
of the opportunity to place the shoe
against a nice looking background so
here the image on the left you got a
nice mauve looking color the shoe on the
right on a nice red background to kind
of really play into the color of the
shoe and so that's attention grabbing so
the colors kind of match and go with one
another and it tends to grab your
attention so nike's doing a good job
here of just not showing an image of a
shoe really what they're doing is put
the shoe as the central focal point and
supporting that with additional color
and they're really putting the messaging
kind of as the background behind the
shoe so they're making it as
attention-grabbing as possible here so
nike's done a good job with this ad you
know me personally i'm not the biggest
nike fan when it comes to shoes but hey
this ad definitely grabbed my attention
because now i could see you know this
shoe is really popping to me we don't
want to use clip art in your ad creative
okay and don't use low resolution
pixelated images as well we want to use
high quality imagery so and use images
that are well lit you know natural
lighting always tends to work well as as
well so when you're doing a placement
for product whether that be food or shoe
you can see here in this plated example
they're putting it on the right image
they're putting it in a natural
environment on a table on a plate with
some paper next to it you know and then
you could see the one on the left it's
of a person holding a box with the image
of plated on it and so to me that's not
stock imagery or clip art you know
that's an actual person holding the
product so it's real life you want to
make it as real life as possible and as
clear and quality as possible so when
you create attention grabbing ads you
show images of people benefiting from
your product instead of just having the
product itself so that's always a good
idea in the case of coca-cola you know
these people are enjoying their bottle
of coca-cola well going back to the nike
ad you know they could have had a person
wearing that shoe or you know running
with that shoe that could have been an
alternative for them as well so the
whole idea is just make sure your ads
are attention getting and they grab your
attention and if you're going to use
people make sure the person is enjoying
it just like on the previous image the
person holding the box we could see
she's got a smile on her face and she is
enjoying holding that box so to me you
want to use people with the images to
the best of your ability and that means
use that person who's enjoying it so
that's really going to put the product
in the forefront okay tip 14 don't
hesitate to experiment with your
advertisements creative or its copy okay
so what do we mean by that really we
want to be refreshing our text we want
to be refreshing our images okay so
if you're gonna place an ad on facebook
don't let that be the only ad okay if
you're using a single image ad you know
feel free to change out that single
image from time to time especially if a
lot of people have seen that ad so
if you're using reach as your objective
and you're trying to reach as many
people as possible just keep in mind
that if that ad is reaching the same
people over and over again it's going to
get stale and you want to be able to
update that ad so feel free to change
out the imagery changing out the text is
just as easy okay so feel free to play
around with the text even you're not
doing a b testing you can always change
out the text just to see hey if changing
out the text actually gets you better
engagement or meet your goals tip 15
plan your campaigns for the holiday
season okay so can't state this enough
you know towards you know october
november december there tends to be a
lot of holidays you know across multiple
religions okay so it's really the time
of year where people are in full ad mode
and audiences are in full watch mode so
advertisers are really pushing ads that
time of year especially christmas you
know and people are accepting of that
because they're used to it so you want
to be able to plan accordingly so if
you're doing your ads you can easily
engage with your audience if you're
aligning your ad with that time of year
so during christmas most people are in
the mood for shopping so it's a time of
year where you can really really really
take advantage of increasing your sales
increasing your conversions so you want
to plan accordingly and so if you're
planning you know months in advance you
don't have to do a full year but you
know for me if i'm thinking i'm going to
do a lot of advertising during the
holiday season i'm probably gonna go out
maybe once summer ends probably august
beginning of september beginning of
september
seasons change a little i might start
thinking about the holiday season and
when you can plan appropriately you can
come out with really good ads you can
think about what you want to say and so
in this case you know target this
particular ad is really promoting black
friday so black friday is the day after
thanksgiving in the united states and so
here they're letting you know black
friday's here and there's deals to be
had so planning in advance gives you an
opportunity to really really tweak your
messaging and come up with some good
creative ideas so let's take another
break and let's look at another
good looking ad this example we're gonna
look at dell okay so dell i've seen
their ads all over facebook they do a
lot of different advertising types
between videos carousels and this is a
single image ad they're really trying to
do is get you over to the storefront so
you can buy one of these good looking
you know dell computers okay so
you know here again they're promoting
their latest computer the dell inspirion
3000 series all in one desktop so to
them anytime they create a new product
they're going to go ahead and put out a
new ad for that product and here they're
putting a little bit of a different
twist on it if you notice the ad itself
is just the image of the product there's
really no promotion here they're letting
the product image speak for itself
they're really showing you hey look how
good this computer looks you know this
is our new model and
you know we got to shop now ctas if
you're interested go ahead and click on
that shop now so they're really putting
the effort into the image itself you
know they're not offering any promotion
you know no discounts you know what you
see is what you get with the image and
you click on it you're going to go right
to their storefront so dell does a good
job of really you know cranking out
their new products whenever they go to
market so tip 16 shorten the amount of
time between retargeting your audience
so target people have visited your
website within the span of a month or
two weeks so retargeting is reaching out
to people who you've already engaged
with so if somebody has seen your ad or
somebody's went to your website
somebody's even purchased from you
before you have the opportunity to reach
back out to that person so how often you
reach out to that person or how long
between their initial engagement and
when you retarget them really does
depend on what it is you're selling so
if you're selling a pair of shoes if
you're nike then chances are somebody's
looking for a pair of shoes it's not
going to be a long purchase window
meaning they're not going to wait two
three months so
if i'm nike and somebody's seen my ad
i'm probably going to target that person
in a short period of time for
retargeting so it really depends on your
product but you don't want to wait too
long between the time they've been
initially engaged in the time you
retarget so really depends on your
product you know again if you're selling
merchandise you know retail it's
probably going to be a smaller time
frame if you're dell computers you know
that's a bigger purchase somebody's
going to take their time so you know you
want to target people you know for their
dell computer probably you know over a
longer period of time okay so just keep
the product in mind you don't want to
wait too long you don't want to keep it
too short so you want to find that nice
balance of when you could retarget
someone okay tip number 17 keep altering
the hook of your ad copy what do we mean
by altering the hook so here you can see
a couple of different options option one
you know we're talking about hey if
you're interested in getting some dmca
certification you know this is what you
need to do option two a little bit
different of a hook hey start your
journey to get your dmc ca certification
so you know just altering the way you're
trying to talk to somebody is really
what we're we're after here on tip
number 17. you have an ad especially the
text remember we always want to refresh
that copy but if you're testing it try
different hooks try different ways to
talk to people okay it always works well
when you can have different types of
messaging because people react to
different messaging so an effective
strategy would be to create multiple ads
with different hooks and see what
performs best so this is an option for a
b testing okay you have an option to add
messaging go ahead and talk one way in
one option and then you know tweak that
messaging tweak that hook a bit in
option b and see what resonates with
people so that's a good option for a b
testing is always you know look at the
way you're going to try and you know get
somebody to convert tip number 18 okay
respond to lead ad responses as soon as
possible so remember one of your ad
formats is a lead ad okay so if you have
a lead ad basically what you're asking
somebody to do is add their name their
phone number and their email if you get
that information don't sit on it react
to it just like the messaging the
facebook messenger how it's almost
instantaneous think of the lead ads the
same way okay you have somebody who's
engaging with your ad by providing
information you don't want to sit on it
you want to respond as soon as possible
in fact you know when you do engage that
person let them know you're available on
facebook messenger so they can actually
then reach out to you via facebook
messenger just to expedite the
communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service because the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer will want to
continue interacting with you so there's
no real good rule of thumb here except
for do it as soon as possible okay tip
number 19 add scarcity to your
advertisements so what do we mean by
that well in this example we could see
the top 100 registrations get free
access so by putting this into your ad
copy we're hoping your prospects are
more inclined to buy your product due to
that fear that they're not going to be
one of the first 100 registrations okay
so it allows you to really put some
sense of urgency
in the ad to get somebody to react so
that's what we mean by you know scarcity
okay so by doing so it could affect the
long-term credibility you know we don't
want to come across as fear-mongering by
any means but hey if your promotion is
the first 100 registrations get free
access then why not you know go ahead
and put it in there some other examples
could be you know only three days left
to register or
first 50 get 50 off or you know hurry
now there's only two days left so
there's other language you can put to
play around with the language but if you
only have certain slots available or
certain amount of days left there's
nothing wrong with putting that in the
ad copy to get people to react and so
that's the whole idea behind you know
the scarcity is you want to be able to
let people know hey there's a limited
edition going on here if you're
interested go ahead and take advantage
tip number 20 keep track of your ad
relevance scores so your ads do get
scored so the score ranges from 1 to 10
okay so what that score does is it's an
indicator to signify the quality and
engagement levels so you know if your
score is between 1 and 6 then the ad
isn't reaching the relevant audience and
your audience isn't reacting to it
however if your
relevance score is between 7 and 10 then
your ads are reaching the appropriate
audience and you're getting a lot of
interaction so keep an eye on that you
know the lower the number that means hey
we're not get our ads not getting to the
right audience and if it's not getting
to the right audience our audience isn't
going to react to it so it all starts
with making sure you're reaching your
audience with your ad when your ad is
reaching your audience and you're doing
a b testing your audience is going to
react to one of those two ads so that's
always going to help your relevance
score so keep an eye on that relevant
score okay so let's take another break
here and let's take a look at an ad here
by blue bottle coffee okay so i'm a big
coffee drinker myself i frequent blue
bottle in san francisco a lot and so
here this is a nice image a nice
close-up image of coffee and i really
like this notice there's really no call
to action here okay so they're putting
their website url the domain
bluebottlecoffee.com
they're saying hey we source great
coffees we roast them to perfection and
get them to you fresh so i can vouch for
that really putting their brand out
there okay so this is more of a brand
awareness type ad that's their objective
their objective is if you're going to
drink coffee at some other location
or with some other brand hey take a look
at ours you know we got good coffee too
we roast them pretty good and and we
make sure that you get them fresh that's
what they're trying to do they're trying
to introduce their brand to you so this
is a good example of a brand awareness
ad single image ad they're definitely
making use of the added the image itself
you know with a nice close-up shot of
that roasted coffee so that's what makes
this ad so special brand awareness you
know the image is telling us hey this
coffee looks pretty pretty good it looks
nice and roasted it looks pretty fresh
and
maybe i'll give blue bottle coffee a try
so that's why they're putting their
domain there okay so it's a good brand
awareness ad and the hope is to convert
some people over to their brand okay so
tip number 21 include emojis in your ad
copy okay so emojis we know are popular
you use them in text use them on social
media
i mean there's hundreds of emojis
nowadays that you could pick and choose
from they are really specific and so
here you can see in the case of simply
learn hey if you're taking a digital
marketing course for simply learn it
doesn't hurt to have some emojis support
that that message so you always get the
thumbs up to get emoji you know the
image of the graduation and that's a
good emoji so you know you always want
to align you know really fun relevant
emojis with your messaging it kind of
just helps it stick out a bit and people
resonate with emojis and so it doesn't
hurt to add those emojis in your ad copy
and especially if your competition is
not using emojis you want every
advantage you can to have your ad stick
out so emojis is a good way to get your
ad to stick out tip number 22 use utm
parameters to your ad which can feed
into your google analytics account and
provide tracking information so i can't
stress this enough if you're using
google analytics to track your campaigns
then you want to use utm parameters so
what do we mean by utm parameters well
let me show you an example so all you
need to do is type in utm tracking or
url builder in google and then you're
going to actually get to this page here
so what this does this is a tool to help
you create utm tracking so if we're
simply learn and we want to
advertise and drive the audience to a
specific page in this case artificial
intelligence masters program page so
this is going to be the url but we want
to append that url with some utm
tracking parameters our campaign source
parameter we're going to put facebook
because that's the source that we're
advertising the medium in which we're
driving that traffic to the page from
facebook is cpc which stands for cost
per click and then we're just going to
put campaign name ai engineer to
identify
what it is that campaign is related to
it so notice that the only required
parameter is campaign source in this
case we're going to put facebook but we
can also use campaign content if we want
to differentiate the different ads that
we have so you can use campaign content
parameter as well you don't have to the
only required parameters campaign source
my recommendation go all lowercase okay
and then when you're done you have a url
that you can use in your advertising so
when somebody actually goes to that url
notice the url includes the utm tracking
and then analytics is going to be able
to pick up that campaign from where
facebook the medium is going to be cpc
and the campaign in this case is going
to be ai engineer and that's what you're
going to look for in google analytics so
it helps you track your ads more closely
because if you don't use utm tracking
for example on facebook then analytics
might you know interpret that traffic
coming from that ad as you know organic
social so we want to be able to identify
specifically the campaign you're running
by putting in different variables for
those parameters so that's what utm
tracking is you want to use it for all
your facebook advertising okay so it
really helps you you know in analytics
identify how your campaign's performing
not only is it driving traffic but is
the campaign converting for you so if
you're trying to get somebody to sign up
for a class then analytics is going to
help us measure those conversions but
with utm tracking we can bridge the gap
between how many people facebook
delivered or drove to our site from the
ad and how many of those people actually
converted so ut and parameters help
bridge that gap tip 23 use exclusion
marketing to improve your facebook
return on investment by not including
people who have already taken the action
desired by you okay so this is a very
key feature here so if we've already
advertised and people have reacted to
our ad and has subscribed they have
subscribed then we don't want to target
that person again so that's what
exclusion marketing is we want to be
able to you know target people that
we're really after so if you know
somebody's looked at our ad and did not
convert or do not go to our website or
to not download something or whatever it
is we wanted them to do then those are
the people we wanted to focus in on okay
so in this case exclusion marketing
we're going to exclude people
who have subscribed in this case we're
going to retarget people meaning
advertise again to people who have not
subscribed so that's what the exclusion
marketing feature does it helps you
really hone in on where you're targeting
and retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only going to lead to poor
performance tip 24 track the right
metrics for your business so keep your
eye on important metrics what are those
metrics you know those are going to be
kpis kpis are key performance indicators
and kpis differentiate from metrics
because kpis are related to business
goals so track the right metrics for
your business what are the right metrics
for your business more than likely it's
going to be conversions or conversion
rate but you could be running a brand
awareness campaign just like uh blue
bottle coffee did and so if you're
running a brand awareness campaign then
maybe your kpi or metric is going to be
a click okay or click-through rate how
many people are actually reacting to our
ad okay so you always want to align the
right metric with your business okay
it's just very important that you're
measuring against the right metric if
you're not then it's going to be
misaligned in terms of how you judge the
campaign performance another set of
metrics could be reach and frequency so
reach and frequency allow us to measure
how many people saw the ad and post
engagement can determine how many users
are reacting to your ads cpc helps us
determine the cost effectiveness or how
much we're paying for every click you
could see that information in your
facebook ad manager for example if i go
to facebook's ads manager here i'm
looking at some some ads that we're
running here what can i see i can see my
reach how many people i'm actually
reaching the frequency in which they're
seeing my ad notice i can see my
relevancy score i can also see my cost
per results i can see the total clicks
so i have a whole set of metrics
available to me really what i want to do
is pick and choose the metrics that are
most important to the ad i'm running
okay so if it's reach am i reaching the
full amount of people possible if i'm
running a brand awareness campaign or it
could be some other metric like
conversion so we want to be able to
align the right metric with the right ad
tip 25 take advantage of facebook's
location tracking tool for your
advertisements so facebook allows us to
advertise up to 25 countries with
different states provinces cities
districts and zip codes so we can really
hone in location wise on where we want
to target so facebook allows us to do
that so basically it could be somebody
in a particular area
or people who have been recently been
there or traveling to that location or
actually lived there so really you could
hone in on a specific location based on
certain set of criteria so with this you
could take your marketing to the next
level by approaching your competitors
customers by offering them better
discounts so that's the whole idea
targeting your advertising on a specific
location and then knowing that your
competitors are there you can really put
out some really good ads with some
really good offers to really convert
some of those people in that audience
okay let's take a look at another ad
okay so grammarly this is an ad that
they've put out there and again you
notice there's no real true call to
action associated with the single image
ad here it's all about messaging here
they're saying hey download it free
today okay and so it's a browser
extension that they're promoting and
really they're trying to get you to
identify or identify with this
particular brand that offers a specific
product so they do have a promotion in
there it's brand awareness hey your life
is about to change i mean the messaging
is pretty you know matter of fact
they're trying to get you to hey i need
this in my browser as an extension so
for me this ad is all about the
messaging here okay so with grammarly
you know if you're in gmail you're in
word you're in outlook they got you
covered by using their browser extension
it's free and by using it it's going to
make your life a lot easier so for me
the ad works from a messaging standpoint
not really big on the imagery but it's
really about this is who we are and
we can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my life's about to change they've
got my attention i'm going to talk about
how to rank youtube videos today so it's
simply learn we take our videos on
youtube very seriously meaning that when
we create videos we want people to see
them because we know we make good videos
and we know we have good content and we
know that our audience is going to enjoy
it and so we want our audience to see
the videos that we're creating and so
we're going to give you some tips and
tricks and methodology and ideas on how
to get your videos to rank on youtube so
at simply learn if i go to
youtube and i just type in machine
learning you can see we're right here is
the first organic video on youtube for
machine learning if i jump over to
google and i type in machine learning
basics you can see where number we're
number one for machine learning basics
under videos if i click on all we're
also ranked here as well under the video
section on organic search results
another example data science for
beginners we ranked number one for that
if i look at another keyword data
science interview question okay we're
ranked number two for that so we're
ranking for a lot of videos and why are
we ranking for a lot of different
content and videos on google search and
on youtube well we put a lot of work in
behind the scenes of creating the video
and that's what we want to show you so
part of that has a lot to do with you
know how our audience engages and sees
our video so for example we're looking
at the machine learning basics video
here and we can see that it has over 221
000 subscribers for this video 234 000
views we've had over 2 000 people like
the video and we have had over 270 plus
comment on the video so when we get our
videos to rank then we can see there's a
lot of engagement and so that's the
whole idea is when you do a video and
you want to show up on youtube you want
people to enjoy you want people to share
it you want people to like it you want
people to comment on that and that's
part of the whole ecosystem of youtube
it's you know we're going to show you
behind the scenes of what it takes to
get your videos to rank and then we're
going to show you some of the metrics
involved with some of these videos to
help you stay ranking so without further
ado let's go into
how to get your videos to rank on
youtube so we're going to talk about
keyword research for youtube we're going
to talk about some ways to create high
quality videos so the importance of user
engagement just as i showed you with the
machine learning basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your content and
then we're going to just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
center our keywords just like our
website we want to center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on youtube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states youtube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
google so
youtube is pretty popular majority
people use youtube search every day to
watch videos on a number of different
topics so they can find these videos in
google but because youtube's so powerful
and so popular people go directly right
into youtube for their searches and so
the whole idea behind youtube being the
second most well-known search engine
is centered around keywords so if you
have the right keywords for your video
then the chances of you ranking higher
increases on youtube so we're gonna
share with you a few easy ways to do
keyword research this is the most
important step in getting your videos to
rank on youtube just like for those of
you who watched any of the seo videos we
produced at simplylearn you know that
keyword research is so essential to
getting your web pages to rank on google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your web pages so we're going to go into
a few things to do here to find the
right keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved in
google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
first thing is search suggest so youtube
has a feature called autocomplete so if
you've done any searches on google it's
very similar if you're typing something
in to youtube search then youtube is
going to suggest other related popular
keywords so let's take a look at that if
we go back to
youtube for a second and i just type in
machine learning youtube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if i choose you know machine
learning tutorial i'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns rank
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know youtube
just like on google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing a
video on machine learning then you know
we have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are our popular keywords
these are keywords that people are using
to search on youtube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitor's youtube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title description and then once you do
that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to youtube so if i go
to type in simply learn here's their
channel page just by clicking on simply
learn i click on videos ever wonder if
there's so now i can see all of this
ever wonder if there's an easier way go
back so here i can see all the videos
sort by most popular once i do that then
i could choose a video this is the most
popular video right now for simply learn
if i click on that video it's
automatically going to start playing but
what i could do is simply just look at
you know the content and description so
just by clicking show more i can see all
the content that align with this video
that's one way to do it is simply by
looking at your competitors now what you
could also do is look at the tags
associated with the particular video and
so
what you want to do is you want to look
at the html and so that means looking at
the page source so just like web pages
what youtube does is they look at meta
tags so if you call from seo in order to
get your pages to rank you need to have
a title tag and a meta tag description
so videos are no different what we're
doing
for youtube is aligning certain keywords
with the video so if you take a look and
do a search for keywords by viewing the
page source you're gonna see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example i go back to
youtube and i look at the page source of
a video let's just say this video here
facebook's ad tutorial i'm going to pull
up the page source and all i need to do
is control f and type in keywords and
now for that facebook video i can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that youtube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this was popular keywords so
if they're related align those keywords
with the videos so here you can see
facebook marketing facebook ad strategy
facebook ads for beginners so forth and
so on so there's a lot of keywords we've
aligned here with that particular video
and again all you need to do is look at
the page source so right clicking view
page source do a control f for keywords
and you'll be able to see the keywords
aligned so you could do that for your
competitors videos as well so you can
see what keywords your competitors using
for a video that's most popular for
their channel and is also ranking on
youtube and on google so using the
autocomplete gives you those keyword
ideas looking at your competitors videos
also gives you some other ideas for
keywords that you can align with a video
that's relevant that you want to rank
for so let's look at uh
some other ideas here so you can install
plugins and there are plenty of plugins
available on the chrome browser that
will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples of vid iq and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if i go
back here and i look at a video on
youtube let's just say the machine
learning basics video i have vid iq
installed on my chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid iq is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video they're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with facebook
some engagement metrics really what i'm
interested in is those keywords so if i
scroll down a bit here i can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning basics video so vid iq is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated i can also see where they
rank so for machine learning basics this
particular video ranks number one if i
go down i can see what is machine
learning and how does it work i can see
it's ranked number two here i could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so i can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
i can also see some channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place i want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you
to really get an understanding of what
keywords to use at the particular video
so autocomplete you can look at the page
source of a competitor's video or you
can use a chrome extension in this case
i'm using vid iq to give me some
information about the video tags for a
particular video so according to an
industry study using keywords and video
tags will help you rank well on youtube
so you have to use keywords and video
tags if you want your video to rank
there's been a lot of studies youtube is
so popular and videos are so prominent
in today's world where if you have
videos and you're going to upload them
to youtube then associate the right
keywords with those videos so some
important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on youtube or google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in chrome in my example i use
vid iq that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what google's
going to do and youtube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very
closely related to the video that we're
trying to optimize for and so we have a
number of different keywords at our
disposal that are relevant that we can
look to see if they have good volume and
low competition and so the whole idea is
we want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition are
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the contents
about and then those secondary keywords
that support the primary so if you have
a machine learning video you could
choose your primary keyword as in this
case the machine learning basics video
so well chosen keywords help you rank
well on youtube just like the machine
learning basics so if i go back to our
video
our machine learning basics video if i
just type in machine learning basics
i'll be able to pull it up and so here
it is i click on it i'm going to go to
youtube and so here i can see this
keyword we know humans learn from their
is well aligned because
it's in the title it's in the copy and
it's aligned as a keyword tag with the
video so we know that that keyword has
good volume low competition is relevant
because that's what the video is about
the basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of honing in on just
introduction
machine learning primary keyword is
machine learning basics and then we
supported that video with those
secondary keywords what is machine
learning because somebody who doesn't
know machine learning is probably going
to type in that keyword and then
introduction of machine learning is a
good secondary keyword because it's
explaining the basics of what machine
learning is all about so primary keyword
machine learning basic secondary
keywords what is machine learning and
introduction to machine learning so
that's the whole idea behind choosing
keywords you want that keyword that
really is going to define the content
and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
google shows on the video results page
so what i mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on youtube it's
also to be found on google so if i go
back to google and i just type in data
science for beginners and i type in
videos then you could see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on google search you can always
just when you do a search what google's
going to do is also put in the videos
here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall
for data science for beginners but we're
ranked number one in the videos category
and so if somebody's looking for a video
that's important and you can see here
that these first two are ads so what
google is doing is they're saying hey
this is so relevant this particular
video for the keyword query data science
for beginners that we're going to show
it above the organic listings even
though it's a video so the whole idea is
to be found on youtube and google
because you're increasing your
visibility you're increasing your
chances of getting found on both search
platforms so according to backlinko
google ranks videos with keywords like
how to tutorials so you know a lot of
the videos that you find on youtube are
going to be instructional based and so
what google's doing is they're saying
hey if somebody types in how to or
tutorial or an introduction to anything
that's going to signal to google that
it's instructional it's going to help
you rank so when you search for machine
learning tutorial or how to become a
machine learning engineer you're going
to get results related to that because
if you look at these examples we have
machine learning tutorial in our title
or how to become a machine learning
engineer so keep that in mind if you're
creating a video and it's educational in
nature you know use those key terms like
how to and tutorials in the video title
because that will help you rank so let's
move over now to video titles so we want
to use our target keyword in the title
of the video and again we want to make
sure if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title youtube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose a really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really google and youtube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
high click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if i go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data signs
in five minutes so that was purposely
done so that hey i don't have time to
watch a video i only have a couple
minutes data science in five minutes
okay great i'm gonna click on the video
and now i have an opportunity to watch
something and learn something under five
minutes so choosing the right words in
your video title is going to help you
get that click-through rate up remember
click-through rate is clicks divided by
impressions and an impression is how
many times your video shows up in the
search results on youtube or google so
we want to keep our click-through rate
high and in order to do that we want to
be able to write some really good title
tags for our video so use catchy words
like a number or how to or what is
because that's going to resonate with
people when they're searching now for
the description what we want to do is we
want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if i go back to
my video here machine learning basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if i look at the description
of the video here i can see this machine
learning basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5 000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if i go back to my video i click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if i go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if i go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's
aligned with that hashtag and then
there's target keywords and lsi keywords
latent semantic indexing keywords we
want to be able to use those keywords as
target keywords with our video so if you
recall the example i gave a few minutes
ago we used the facebook ads tutorial as
our example here i could see all the
target keywords associated with that
particular video so don't be afraid to
use those lsi related keywords meaning
keywords that are related to the content
use them as target keywords with the
video so between your lsi keywords
target keywords and then using our
primary and secondary keyword in the
title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword in the description and
then using hashtags in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword then we should
find that our video will eventually rank
on youtube so just doing these small
tidbits with our keywords really help
get our video to rank so at the end of
the day we want to be able to use the
tools available to us youtube itself by
looking at our competitors those
extensions like vid iq the autocomplete
to really find our good keywords and
then incorporating those keywords into
you know the title tag the description
as target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on youtube let's turn our attention to
creating high quality videos and some of
the best practices around that so along
with everything we mentioned about
choosing the right keywords we always
need to keep in mind that the videos we
create need to be of high quality so the
content itself in addition to the
keywords this is a primary factor in
ranking so in order to have keywords we
need to have content and in order to
rank we need to have you know good
content so let's talk a little bit about
creating content and what's involved
with that and what we really mean by
high quality videos so if you have a
video content that is not informative or
relevant to the topic it won't rank so
that's just common sense so you need to
create content that's aligned with the
topic obviously and then that way you
have keywords that are in line with the
content so but if you have content it
really isn't aligned with the topic then
you're not going to rank no matter how
much you've optimized that video so just
keep that in mind so there's a couple of
things we want to look at here so high
quality content is determined by
really two metrics so we're not sure
about how good our content is and how
good of high quality video we created we
want to look at audience retention and
user engagement so audience retention is
simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched it's
the percentage your audience has watched
so focusing on audience retention is
important for people who want their
videos to rank high so if you want to
rank you need to optimize for the
keywords but got to keep in mind content
so content is related to audience
retention and user engagement so
audience retention percentage length
your video of your video that the
audience has watched and for example it
can be both absolute in minutes or
percentages so audience retention can be
the average view duration or percentage
of the audience that watched then we
have user engagement so users are
engaged from our viewers who are engaged
with your content and so that means
they're either sharing it subscribing
commenting or liking so those are all
forms of engagement so the percentage of
users who watched or how long they
watched versus engagement or in
combination with engagement are two
factors for ranking so let's talk about
some tips for creating high quality
videos so we want to publish longer
videos and so what do we mean behind
longer videos so what's the reason for
longer videos let's just suppose we have
two videos one shorter in length and one
longer in length first video is 15
minutes long the second video is seven
minutes long so on average if viewers
watch about 40 of both videos then video
x which is 15 minutes long will have
more than twice the watch time of the
video that's seven minutes long so
remember
duration we want you know people to
watch our videos longer so if the video
is longer in length if it's 40 then it's
gonna have a longer audience engagement
audience retention so that's one of the
reasons you know from a metric
standpoint so even when viewers watch
you know both videos the time is going
to differ so we want to take into
account longer videos for primarily that
reason is because you know it gives an
open end user an opportunity to
watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so we talk about watch time so if one
video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recommendation is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay it's really
with an outline starting out with an
on-holistic videos are no different than
say a presentation if you've done a
powerpoint presentation you always want
to start out doing an outline and then
we want to upload high resolution videos
high resolution we don't want to create
videos that you know are small
resolution like say you know 400 by 400
resolution or something you know
something really small we want to create
something a very high res so according
to back or link oaks more than 50 of
videos on the first page of youtube are
high definition so
high definition videos of higher quality
are going to be shown on the first page
of youtube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality videos we also
want to make sure that content is
relevant to the title so if we're
talking about machine learning basics
you know obviously the content is going
to be about you know intro to machine
learning or what is machine learning and
then the title should reflect that
content so
aligning the title sets the expectation
for the end user so when they see a
title what is machine learning then when
they watch the video they're expecting
to learn about machine learning and what
it is so if it meets expectations then
the chances are that person who's
watching the video is going to watch it
longer and that means it's going to
fulfill the viewers requirements and
when you align everything accordingly
keywords titles content then at the end
of the day view users going to watch it
and the more they watch it the higher
the engagement the higher the engagement
the better chance you have to rank some
other tips that you could use to
create high quality videos so we want to
be able to you know use examples to
clarify our content so you know don't be
afraid to go into another screen like i
am i want to i'm talking about videos
jump into the machine learning basics
video which i've done throughout this
session i can simply do that by keeping
the user engaged here this video is
about machine learning basics well the
title is online with the video we made
sure that we have a nice description
about what the video is about and we're
aligning the expectations so not only
that i'm showing you example within the
video itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like shutterstock
or flat icon i mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to
use high quality images in your video
give more information to your audience
okay giving maximum relevant information
can help gain more views and so when we
talk about more information again it
goes back to you know examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from youtube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on youtube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
i'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what i'm trying to say or
what the viewers trying to to understand
when they're watching the video so
watching and listening are two of the
components and you want to make sure
both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content to go along with the video that
outline i referenced earlier in terms of
organization you always want to have a
content outline so what topics are you
going to cover in the video that's why
you need the outline to point that out
confirm that before you actually start
creating the video i focus on the
initial 15 seconds so that's key you
know somebody's gonna click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out
altogether so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in youtube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example i can see you know
43 44
watch the video for at least two minutes
here i can see
28.6 watch it for six minutes plus so
that's the audience retention it gives
us an idea in terms of percentage how
many people or percentage of people
watch the video at what length so that's
audience retention so we want to keep
that number high at the very initial
stage of the video and we want to keep
it high throughout and that's why you
always want to create high quality
content using those examples using
imagery making it organized content not
pausing you know going from one point to
the other those are all
best practices to keep the viewer
engaged and then we want to add
resources from well-known sites so
throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or youtube can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by autoplaying the next
video so if you enable this feature it's
going to go from one video to another
pattern interrupts keep the audience
engaged so
basically it allows your audience to
stay within one video without having any
interruptions involved and so going back
to the did you know audience retention
report helps you analyze how well your
videos are engaging to the audience so
what do we mean by that well if i go
back again to my audience retention
report how engaging was it well i could
see 42 percent 43
watched it on average of 3 minutes and
21 seconds so to me that's pretty good
of course we always want a hundred
percent of the video the video is seven
minutes long if almost half of our
audience saw over half of the video then
i would say that's pretty good people
were engaged so audience retention just
is a good report to start looking at to
help you understand how engaging is my
video and if your video is not engaging
you know you can always go back and edit
it or fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for all videos and
top performing videos listed by all time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location okay we can look at
playback locations report and what the
playback locations report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within youtube look at the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so if there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into youtube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to see from device type so if i click on
more i can see my playback location so
this will show me where the video was
watched it was on a watch page or a
channel page i could see the traffic
sources i could see the gender and age
so if i click on the viewer age report i
can see the percentage of views by age
so i can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within youtube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to youtube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to youtube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at youtube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically
we can't rank without engagement our
videos won't rank unless we have
engagement so that's why it's important
so engagement is somebody liking the
video commenting sharing it or
subscribing each one of these is
important to ranking so yes you need to
line keywords yes you need to have high
quality content so when you do both of
those and you upload your video then
it's up to the viewer and so
the hard work that you put out for the
video is hopefully going to pay
dividends with engagement so you want
people to do one of these for okay so
let's talk about
what that means so how do i get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to word stream if your
content is entertaining then over three
quarters of the users are going to share
it so that's part of keeping uh users
engaged keep it in entertaining is part
of getting a high quality video so
remember on the high quality video when
we say entertaining the audio portion
has a lot to do with it examples has a
lot to do with it quality of the video
itself has a lot to do with it so a lot
of components so all those components on
a high quality video are going to lead
to engagement so parts of what you could
do in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that'll
also help you get some more comments so
according to backlinku video comments
help in ranking your video higher so
just as i mentioned in the last segment
about
youtube analytics and all the different
reports available on youtube hey if you
have questions on those just go ahead
and add a comment so that's a way to
entice your users or your viewers to add
comments is if they have questions
because you know with videos you're not
going to be able to cover every detail
or every minute detail about a
particular topic you can only cover in
some cases the topic at a high level so
users are going to have comments or
questions naturally and so the comments
section is a good way to remind viewers
hey if you have a question or comment go
ahead and put in the comment section
because that will lend to engagement as
well so we want to add sources from high
quality websites that'll help with
engagement okay use humor in your video
we want to be able to
basically you know make it human based
we don't want to be robots so we want to
be able to sound like you know we know
we're talking about but at the same time
talk to the viewer not necessarily at
the viewer or looking the other way and
just going through the motions so adding
humor adding personality never hurts at
the end of the day we are all human
adding that clear call to action at the
end of the video will also
lead to engagement so if we win the
video with hey leave your comments on
this video or hey feel free to share
this video with colleagues who are
interested then that's a call to action
that's likely going to lead to more
engagement reply to your comments as
well so if you have comments we always
want to reply to them likely those
comments are going to be questions
because again as i mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on youtube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comments section
so more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engagement so when
you're getting high engagement and your
video starts to rank well you know
you're going to start feeling really
good and what is that going to do look
at that feel good it's going to lead to
confidence which in turn is going to
probably lead to more videos and that's
exactly what we do at simply learn we're
in the education business but we're in
it to not only educate but making sure
that our videos are shown to as many
people as possible so that we can
educate as many people as possible so
it's all it's contagious so getting
ranked feels good and then once you get
ranked then you know you probably have
good engagement okay let's talk about
how to promote your content so once
you've done all the hard work getting
your video done high quality content
optimize with keywords and then publish
to youtube we want to let everybody in
the world know about it right so we want
to promote it we've done all the work we
want to promote it now so is it
necessary to promote it i would say yes
because once your video is published you
want to reach out you want to reach out
to your audience not necessarily on
youtube but on different platforms so if
you're active on facebook or twitter
that's an opportunity for you to post or
tweet something about the new video so
when we say different platforms i am
talking about you know social media
platforms so it depends on what you're
active on so if you're active on
facebook yeah go ahead and post
something you're active on twitter go
ahead and tweet something it could be
you know on linkedin group if you're
part of a linkedin group about you know
machine learning then go ahead and post
something to that group to promote the
video so that's going to help drive
traffic to the video and then help with
engagement so we want to engage with our
audience on those social media sites so
it really depends on what you're active
on so if you have a large following on
twitter then go ahead and you know share
that youtube video link on twitter with
the tweet that's going to drive traffic
from twitter to youtube remember you
know you're going to be able to see
audience engagement or retention by
getting people to watch the video so
you're going to be able to see right
away by promoting the video
and driving traffic to the video how
engaging it is remember the more people
you have watch the video the more
engaging it becomes the better it's
going to rain so it's an ecosystem and
promoting your content is part of that
ecosystem so it all starts with social
media if you're active on whatever
platform that is go ahead and promote it
so you can also
look at you know content-based social
media sites or social media
content-based platforms like
reddit or flickr for example so you can
participate in a forum discussion on
reddit so in this example here it's
about machine learning so we want to be
able to post something about machine
learning with the link to our video so
we can also go to content-based sites
that are q and a
related like quora for example core is a
really good site where you know if you
go there post information about machine
learning or the basics of machine
learning with the link back to the video
it's going to help because not only is
it going to drive traffic but it's going
to signal to google hey
a lot of traffic coming from quora this
is going to bode well for this video in
terms of ranking so here's an example
you know if you find a question that you
can post on core then you're gonna get
people to click on your video and
respond accordingly on quora or you can
act as the person responding to a
question that's already there so
somebody already asked a question about
what is machine learning you can respond
with your video as the answer so you can
just simply embed your video url as part
of your answer that'll help drive
traffic so you can also create your own
blog and embed your videos so in the
case of machine learning here we have an
example machine learning what is it and
why it matters so this goes nicely with
the video so here you can see the person
the author of this blog went ahead and
embedded the relevant video in the blog
post so they play off one another nicely
you can also opt in for influencer
marketing meaning hey you can reach out
to somebody in this example here you
know katie nuggets posted information
about machine learning so in this case
why choose machine learning as a career
well they got information and then what
did they do they went ahead and embedded
the video about machine learning basics
and so working with you know influencers
in a particular category or topic will
help drive traffic to the video you can
also create a youtube playlist so
playlists tend to rank high in youtube
searches so if you find yourself doing a
lot of videos we'll go ahead and you
know go to
your channel and simply on your channel
you can go ahead and create playlists so
when you create playlists basically what
you're doing is you're organizing the
content into different playlists no
different than say the music you have
set up on your you know your iphone or
ipad or or ipod whatever it is you're
using so you're just creating different
videos in a particular category and it
youtube likes it it's organized it's
gonna help you get your videos found
quicker and easier on youtube itself by
putting your videos in a playlist so
here you could see we have entire
playlist on machine learning trending
technologies cloud computing big data
digital marketing project management so
a lot of different playlists very
organized if somebody goes to the
channel they're going to be able to go
to the playlist that's interesting to
them and see all the videos there so it
allows not only the end user to find
what they're looking for but it's good
for youtube because youtube likes those
playlists so we want to engage our
audience by posting your video link on a
community page so you could do that
within youtube and you can prefer to
link your youtube channel in your email
so you can also do that so for example
if i go back to youtube and i'm looking
at a youtube video you know i can always
click share so here i'm gonna get a
particular url that's associated with
the video and i can just embed that so i
can embed the whole thing in my email i
can embed it on a web page or a blog
post so just by clicking share i can
also immediately
share it onto the social media platforms
that we mentioned facebook linkedin
reddit okay tumblr so
there's a lot of ways to
embed the video not just that a blog
post or influencer blog post but in our
email and on social media as well so
here's an example of what we can do with
the youtube discussion so we can also
bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or read it or
you know there's lots of other ones out
there so there's plenty of sites that
you'll be able to go to and bookmark
that content so that people can find it
and you can always opt for backlinks so
that means that hey
if there's a blogger out there that
blogs about machine learning you can
always you know ask that blogger to
create a link back to the video and you
could reciprocate do the same thing so
that helps increase the authority of the
video so a lot of things you could do to
promote your video so let's do a quick
review on everything we talked about in
terms of ranking your video on youtube
it all starts with the keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords but
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords well we can use the
autocomplete on youtube we could check
out our own competitors videos or you
know we could use vid iq or tubebuddy or
any of these extensions in chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video so
remember we want to have a primary
keyword that's aligned with the content
and we want to choose lsi keywords as
our secondary keyword or keywords that
are related to the primary keyword so we
want to create high retention videos
meaning that first 15 seconds are the
most important but throughout the video
we want to use examples we want to keep
it interacting by adding quizzes imagery
good audio good video quality so we want
to focus on the user experience and we
also want to optimize our video content
what does that mean well those keywords
that we chose we want to use them in the
title we want to use them in the
description we want to use them as
hashtags we want to use them and tag
them with the video themselves so we can
add keywords to our meta tag okay we
don't want to overdo it but we want to
add a handful of keywords that are
associated with the video so we want to
be able to write eye catchy video titles
and descriptions so remember use some of
those key phrases like a number
or a question like what is machine
learning so we want to use relevant meta
tags for the videos and we want to use
popular youtube tags so we want to be
able to tag our videos appropriately to
watch the length of your meta tags so
there are links involved remember
keywords at the beginning of the title
target keywords in the title description
and tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click-through
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when i say thumbnails i mean the
actual title tag itself or the meta
description we want to use high-res
videos we want to create you know videos
with good high audio quality don't be
afraid to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlist and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your youtube video ranked so let's
get started uh with learning how to
create a youtube channel i'm excited to
be with you and hopefully you'll get a
lot out of this webinar so the first
thing you need to do when you create a
youtube channel is you have to have an
email address so one email address will
work with all google products and since
youtube is owned by google the email
address you use to log into google
products for example gmail will get you
into youtube so i would recommend
setting up a new email address if you
don't want to use an older email address
so you just want to make sure the email
address you use is the one you're going
to use with youtube and so it probably
will be easier just to go ahead and set
up a new gmail account and so you can
see here for today's webinar i'm going
to use my email address rob sanders dot
simply learn in gmail so that's the
email address i'm going to use and once
you're logged in to google so when
you're logged into one product
technically you're logged into all
google products if you're in the same
browser so you can see i'm in firefox so
if i went over to google and did a
search i'm going to be logged in as rob
sanders dot simply learn so generally
that's how it works so when you're
logged into one you're logged into all
and so once you set up that gmail
address then you want to go and log into
youtube with the same email address so
note that in all google products you can
have multiple logins so you can see here
i can log into multiple accounts in the
same browser so here you can see i'm
logged in as
robsanders.simplylearn and that's the
email address i'm using to login to
youtube so i'm logged into youtube now
what do i want to do i want to create a
channel that's what this whole webinar
is about so we want to learn how to
create a youtube channel and so the
first thing we're going to do here is
click on our name and you can see that
in the upper right hand corner i have an
r for rob i'm going to click my channel
since i've never created a channel for
this email address now i have the
opportunity to create one so i'm just
gonna use digital marketing as my
example here okay so by clicking on this
i agree to the terms of service of
youtube so i'm going to go ahead and
agree to those terms by clicking on the
call to action create channel and once i
click on create channel voila i have a
youtube channel so now that i have a
channel i want to go ahead and optimize
my channel page so
here you can see i have a button that
says customize channel so i'm going to
go ahead and click customize channel and
this will get me into
customizing my channel so what's the
first thing i want to do well with
youtube as a best practice you want to
be able to customize the channel as much
as you can and what do i mean by
customize a channel well you want to add
some channel art you also want to
you go ahead and put information about
yourself uh you want to go ahead and
obviously upload videos and create
playlists so we're going to be covering
throughout this webinar some of these
best practices and if you haven't had a
chance go ahead and take a look uh at
the videos we put together regarding how
to rank your youtube videos and also how
to increase create increase youtube
subscribers so both of these videos
actually complement today's video and we
do talk about some of the best practices
in setting up your youtube channel so
these are good videos to complement what
we're doing on youtube so
you definitely want to go ahead and
customize the channel so the first thing
we're going to do is spruce up our
channel a bit and add some some artwork
and so i'm just going to go ahead and
click on add channel art and i'm going
to upload some photos here so i'm going
to select a photo from my computer so if
i go to my desktop have it sitting in a
nice
folder here ready to go and so here i'm
going to go ahead and choose this
particular piece of art it's a png file
so i'm just going to go ahead and click
open so notice it says the photo you
uploaded is too small it must be at
least
2048 pixels wide and 11 58 pixels tall
so you got to make sure you have a nice
big photo that's going to fit this
particular uh requirement so because
this image was a little bit small what i
went ahead and did was adjusted the size
so i just open up the file and adjust
the size so now if i look at my original
size i can go to tools here adjust size
so i adjusted it so
basically it fits within the scope of
what youtube is asking for in terms of
pixel dimensions so now i re went ahead
and re-uploaded it and now i can see
what it looks like on a tv on a desktop
and on a mobile device so i can adjust
the crop if i wanted to
if i wanted to i'm going to go ahead and
leave it as is because we don't want to
crop anything out of it so i'm going to
go ahead and select saved and there you
go there's my image still a little bit
pixelated but that's okay i can go in
and
upload another image if i want to now
once i've uploaded my channel art i'm
going to go ahead and upload my channel
icon so i'm going to go ahead and click
on edit and i'm going to go ahead and
edit my channel icon and so now i'm
going to go ahead and upload a photo so
you see i went ahead and put all these
images ahead of time in a folder so
that's what you want to do you want to
have everything prepared and ready to go
just like your email address go ahead
and and think about what particular
images you're going to use with your
channel so
you want to have those ready to go and
so i'm going to go ahead and pick my
channel icon and click open here's my
channel icon so i'm going to click done
and it should upload my channel icon and
there you go so now i have a nice
channel icon which is the logo of my
company to go along with the artwork i
have for my channel so now i refresh my
channel page and here is my channel icon
ready to go along with my channel
artwork okay now that i have my artwork
in place i'm ready to upload a video so
just like the artwork just like the
email address you want to have that
video ready to go so to me you want to
make sure
you're choosing a good quality video
because when you upload that video you
could make it available to
everybody on youtube to view so if this
is your first video you really want to
make a good impression and so by making
a good impression is make sure that
first video is of good quality now you
can always upload a video and remove it
later for just testing purposes that's
fine but if you're going to upload a
video and keep it there make sure that
video is a good quality when i say good
quality i mean good video and audio
quality you know make sure you have a
theme make sure it fits what your
channel is all about because if somebody
is looking on youtube and they're
looking for something related to what
you're offering that video needs to come
across as professional and you want to
have a good impression so that's my
disclaimer on uploading a video so now
let's just go ahead and upload a video
so we're going to go ahead and we can go
choose videos or you could see here
under uploads says you don't have any
recent uploads so this will not appear
in your channel so we want to add a
video so let's go ahead and just click
on the link upload a video okay so now
here's what i was referring to a minute
ago you have the option to
make this public you can make it private
unlisted you could schedule it let's
just go ahead and make this private for
now okay so now let's go ahead and
select a file i have that video ready to
go so it's in my folder here and so now
i'm just gonna select my video and click
open and now it's going to upload the
video here i can see the status of my
upload of course videos depending on
your bandwidth may take a few minutes
may take a few seconds so let's go ahead
and wait for this to finish processing
and then we're going to take the next
step okay so once your video has been
uploaded it's going to say processing's
done now you have the opportunity to go
ahead and fill in some basic information
so here you could see you have three
fields that you should fill out with
every video you upload you have a title
you have a description and we have some
tags here so the title is the title of
the video so this is digital marketing
certified associate training dmca
training simply learn so you you can
basically customize it anything and have
it say anything you want it to say i
mean your video so you want to make the
title relevant to the video because
that's what people are going to see now
i'm going to go ahead and put in some
information here about the video what is
the video about so here you can see i
prepared some content so you can add a
lot of characters here under the
description you can see a lot of
characters and so you want to put as
much information about the video as
possible of course you don't have to add
all this content so we can just scale it
down you just want to have basic a basic
description of what the video is about
that's really what you want to do and
then you can add some tags so let's go
ahead and add some tags about the video
itself so
this is a video about digital marketing
so we're going to add tags related to
digital marketing so here you can see we
can add a hashtag digital marketing we
want to add another one this one's about
uh dmc a training so let's go ahead and
add that here now the thing about
hashtags you want to keep the words all
together
there's no spaces involved okay so you
can see i just added two hashtags hit
enter now the thing is you don't want to
overdo it on the hashtags probably two
or three you know google excuse me
youtube will
probably ignore anything over a handful
of hashtags so you want to make sure you
don't overdo it on the hashtags like i
said one or two or three related to the
video should be all you need notice you
have a couple of other settings here
okay and we're just going to keep this
privates only we can view this but if
you're ready to make this public then go
ahead and you know make it public just
change the setting from private to
public now if you have a playlist if
you've already set up a playlist you can
add it to that playlist if you don't
well you can create a playlist and
here's a good opportunity for you to set
up a playlist with your first video now
if you're not ready to set up a playlist
and playlists really are there to help
you organize videos so if you know
you're going to upload more videos in
the future then go ahead and set up
these playlists to organize your videos
so we can go ahead and create a playlist
and we're just going to call it dmca so
anything related to dmca we're going to
go ahead and
put the video there we're going to make
this playlist public here you can see we
can keep it unlisted or private so we're
just going to go ahead and create it and
just by checking on this box this video
will now be in the playlist dmca so you
have the opportunity to really organize
your videos any way you want by creating
multiple playlists in fact i would
recommend that and so again these are
the steps you need to take when you
upload a video you need to make sure
that the title tag the description and
the hashtags are all relevant to the
video in fact you want to make sure even
before you do that you align the right
keywords with the video so i want to
remind you we elaborate a lot on that on
the how to rank youtube videos so go
ahead and take a look at this video here
how to rank youtube videos and
this will get you going with ranking
your video i would recommend for now if
you're not sure how to do that and
you're not ready to watch the video how
to rank youtube videos then just go
ahead and make sure you're aligning the
right
title tag or title description and
hashtags with the video and when you're
done and you're ready to go you can
click done and now you have a video with
a specific link so if i click on that
link i should be able to watch the video
i just uploaded so once we've uploaded
that video we do have the option to go
back and edit the video so
here you can see i'm still in my channel
i clicked on videos if i just click on
the video itself i can see what the
video is and right underneath that
there's gonna be a blue call to action
button that says edit video and so i'm
gonna go ahead and click edit video and
so remember we added the video with
title tags the meta the description and
some hashtags but there are a lot of
other
features that we can use or take
advantage of to edit the video so let's
take a look at what that is and what
that looks like so again we can go back
in and edit the title of the video we
can edit the description notice you have
5 000 characters so take advantage of
all those characters that youtube is
giving you so we have the option to
switch out the visibility again change
the playlist so we can add more tags so
we we have a lot of different options at
our disposal okay so notice the
thumbnail here so
youtube selects three different
thumbnails so you can change the
thumbnail here and the thumbnail is what
the opening screen is going to look like
so you can change that if you'd like
okay so if you make any changes just go
ahead and make sure you click save you
also have some advanced features here so
we can add a recording date if you want
to basically put a timestamp on it we
can add a category in here for search so
if people are looking for specific
category this is where it'll be located
so we're going to go ahead and change
that we're going to put it under
education okay we have an option to
select the language okay so we're gonna
go ahead and select english okay we can
have caption so
you have a lot of different options here
to
really set up your video nicely to be
found to be published based on the
description and all the other settings
available to you so when i'm done i'm
just going to go ahead and click save
and all my changes are saved and so
again those are going to be located
under video so anytime i want to go
ahead and edit my video i'm just going
to go i can always go back to my channel
i can always just click on videos on the
left side navigation and then from there
again i can just click on the video or i
can select it and then i can edit it and
so here you can see as an alternative i
can go to any one of these areas to edit
so if i click on tags i can go ahead and
edit the tag so think of this as a
shortcut if you will if you want to edit
any one of these specific parameters
related to your video so let's talk
about some other settings you have
available to your channel so we went
through some of the settings for the
video itself okay so again just as a
reminder if you need to edit the video
you can just click on and select the
video that you want to edit and you have
some quick edit options here so here are
all your edit options you can quickly
edit those or again you can just click
on the video itself you can see you have
some editing options here as well okay
so these are settings related to the
video and so
if i want to have edit some settings
related to the channel that's a little
bit different so if i go if i want to
change some of the settings on my
channel i can simply just on the left
side navigation where you got channel
you have dashboard videos analytics so
forth you can just scroll down and you
can see some settings here so you want
to click on that sprocket icon and then
you're going to have your settings
window open up okay then i'm going to
click channel okay so let's just say i
want to add a watermark to my channel so
i'm going to click branding and as you
can see here adding a watermark to your
content it's just a really a great way
to really put your brand in place so
it's gonna add you know your brand to
every video that you do okay so it's
gonna overlay in the bottom right corner
of the video player and so that's what
we want to do we want to add a watermark
that's a best practice so go ahead and
choose an image again i have this
already prepared for me so i'm going to
go into my folder here and then i'm
going to go ahead and select my image so
this is my logo i'm going to go and
select that that image there now i can
see here it added to the bottom right of
the video player and so it can be at the
end of the video at a specific custom
start time at the beginning of the video
or it can be throughout the entire video
so let's just go ahead and add it to the
entire video okay so i'm going to go
ahead and click save okay so now i've
added a watermark let's go back into
settings so there could be some other
settings we want to change so if i go
back to channel so here i can add some
keywords okay so this is key because if
i want my channel to be found you know i
want to be able to tell youtube what
those keywords i want to be found for
just like in search with google youtube
and all intents and purposes is a search
engine it's just a video platform where
you can search for videos and so my
channel is all about digital marketing
so i'm going to go ahead and put digital
marketing i can also go ahead and put
you know search engine optimization okay
i can or seo just to be shorter i can go
ahead and put sem for search engine
marketing so these are just some key
words here here i can choose my country
so i can choose my country and choose
like united states just to hone in
specifically on the country so let's see
here i'm going to scroll down i'm going
to choose uh united states is my country
here i get some advanced settings as
well i can link my google ads account to
this so this is key so if you if you're
running google ads campaigns then you
want to be able to link it up so linking
your channel to your ads account
basically will
you know allow you to get some
information about how this particular
channel is performing so basically it
lets the google ads account run ads
based on interactions with your
channel's videos and access insights
from your channels videos so basically
when you link the two they're going to
be communicating they're going to be
passing data back and forth so if you
have a google ads account i would go
ahead and link it up okay so remember
it's based on email address so make sure
the same email address you're using for
youtube is the same email address you're
using for google ads so i can go ahead
and choose this option to show my
subscriber count i can also disable
interest-based ads so if i select this
option personalized ads will not be
shown on videos on your channel such as
ads based on viewers interest
remarketing so if you want to go ahead
and disable any interest-based ads any
ads again that are based on a specific
interest or remarketing then you can
disable that so let's go back to
branding here's my watermark under
branding again advanced based on
advertising and just some basic options
specifically keywords so go ahead and
make sure you go ahead and choose
settings and go ahead and add those
keywords go ahead and add that watermark
it's important to the channel it's
important to be found it's important
that you know your channel's set up the
way you want it to be set up branded
with some certain keywords in a specific
industry targeting a specific country so
you want to set that up that's why so
settings here are so important for the
channel okay so
once you created your channel once
you've uploaded a video once you set up
all your settings for the channel
congratulations so you're really on your
way now to uploading more videos and
really having a successful youtube
channel so congratulations now let's
move on and get a little bit more
complex here with the youtube channel so
we're gonna move on to the next step and
we're gonna run through the creator
studio and the beta studio okay so i'm
gonna go ahead and show you what the
creator studio and beta studio are so
let's focus first on the creator studio
and so basically the creator studio we
have some tools to at our disposal okay
so we have a dashboard where we could
see certain analytics we have a video
manager we can actually edit the video
we have an opportunity to live stream
work with our community and we have some
channel settings we can play with the
audio again we can you know manipulate
and look at some analytics and react to
the analytics so you have a lot of
options here in creator studio so let's
go into youtube and let's dive into the
creator studio and take a look at what
that's all about so when we go to uh
youtube
and our channel basically what we see
here is our creator studio if you will
so we have a lot of different options so
we talked about videos already and how
to edit videos we talked about settings
well let's talk about some of these
other options available to us in the
creator studio so this is the dashboard
so the dashboard is going to give you an
overview
of your channel so here we could see a
snapshot of some subscribers some data
over the last 28 days so if we look here
we can see some other performance
metrics based on analytics okay so we
can youtube can give us some ideas we
have some news so it's it's a dashboard
that
youtube is communicating with you on so
they're communicating data about your
videos that you uploaded what's been
popular you know how many times
somebody's viewed it how many
subscribers and then you also have some
communication information some tips some
suggestions some ideas so that's what
the dashboard is and if you're new to
youtube i would definitely take
advantage of it you know for example
ideas for you grow your community so if
we get started you know youtube's gonna
be able to you know share some
information about you know how to create
or how to grow your community so you
know go ahead and take advantage of
you know some of these options that
youtube has for you so you have ideas
you have some ins creator insider and
you have some news so don't be afraid to
go ahead and click on it and get some
tips about you know growing your
community for example so here you could
see some courses and some lessons that
youtube put together and again at
youtube we have the same simply learn we
have the same information for example we
have a video on how to increase youtube
subscribers but you can look at our
videos you can also you know lean on
youtube for some information as well and
all that's located here in the dashboard
let's talk about the video manager so
basically we click on videos so we'll be
able to see videos that we have here so
you can see in uh
in this particular channel you can see
all the videos that we have here and you
can see
the visibility of these videos are they
public yet are they unlisted are they
private we have a a stamp of when
they've been uploaded the date at which
they've been uploaded and then you can
kind of get a sense of how many views
how many comments how many likes versus
dislikes by video okay so if we want we
can always just click on one of the
videos here and again we can edit it so
we have an opportunity to you know make
some edits and changes to the video
itself
especially for not getting comments
we're not getting views if we're not
getting views then you probably should
go forward and think about editing say
the title or description or or making
sure you align the right keywords or
tags with the video okay so that's the
video manager we go to analytics in our
creator studio then we'll be able to get
some really deep insights about how our
videos are performing so there's a lot
of information here under analytics
about you know all your entire channel
broken down by each video so if you
wanted to really hone in on what the top
videos were in terms of watch time you
can specifically choose that particular
report and then what's going to happen
is youtube's going to load the report
and we're going to be able to see
specific information about a specific
video okay so again this is overall but
if i want to see analytics for specific
video i'm going to go down under the
video and click on this little graph
here and i'll be able to see some
insights about that specific video and
so for that specific video i could see
the total watch time how many views
subscribers and i can see audience
retention i can see real time activity
okay i can see watch time over a period
of time see subscribers over a period of
time so you can get really granular all
the way down to the video so a lot of
information
in youtube analytics about your overall
channel and the video itself so it's all
here for you to measure and look at so
remember when you're looking at this
analytics you want to go ahead and react
to what you see so again if you're not
getting subscribers or you're not
getting views what are you going to do
well if you're not getting views you got
to look at this the settings you got to
look at the keywords you got to look at
did you actually update and edit the
title and the description and add
hashtags that are relevant okay so if
they are relevant you know are you
getting found okay so that's the whole
idea is to make sure you're optimizing
these videos so you can get the views
and again is the quality of the content
good so if the quality of the content is
good you're probably going to get
subscribers and so if you're not getting
subscribers you want to take away that
learning okay you want to be able to
understand what people like and what
they don't like and that's the whole
point of youtube analytics youtube
analytics allows us to really adjust and
hone in on you know what people are
liking and what they don't like so that
way you can move your future videos in
that direction so let's go back to the
creator studio and let's look at some of
the other features available here so
we actually go from analytics to
comments okay so we can look at all the
comments so right now there's no
comments available for the video i just
uploaded but if there were i'd be able
to see what those are and
i can you know report any spam or
actually or review and respond to those
comments so when you actually do get
comments you'll be able to see them here
again held for review again anything
that spam is going to show up as spam
and so you can go ahead and
remove it or you can approve it again
you can flag it as spam so you have an
option here to let youtube know hey this
is spam we don't want this type of
comment in the future again you can hold
any comments for you know responding
later so if i click on it again i can
approve it and then i can go back to
public and i can look at any comments
that have been made public and from
there i can go ahead and react to those
comments and so i can go ahead and reply
give it a thumbs up give it a thumbs
down like it and you can go ahead and
remove it or hide from the channel okay
you can always approve comments from a
specific user who always responds or
comments okay or you can add a
particular user as a comment moderator
so you have a lot of options available
to you under comments and comments are
they really they're part of the youtube
ecosystem so it's important that if
somebody's watching your video just as
you are now you comment so if there's
anything that i'm missing here then go
ahead and comment right below this video
right on the channel and comments are
important because it allows you know
people to engage and interact with the
person who created the video and
comments are always you know always
welcome whether they positive or not so
positive comments do add a lot to the
video itself it lets people express
their opinions lets people provide
feedback on the video and it allows the
you know the owner of the video to go
ahead and learn what people think about
the video and of course youtube allows
that person to respond accordingly so
that's an important feature for both the
viewer and the publisher of the video
okay so let's look at some other
features here in the creator studios if
i click on transcriptions okay so i can
transcribe so i can choose here uh i can
add a language for example just by
clicking on add a language and so what
youtube's going to do is add that
particular language to my channel and
that's what that language will be
available for people who are speaking
that language and then i have some other
features available here as well so if i
go here i get translation and
transcription so if i click on that
again this is a little bit different
than
adding a language as a setting so now if
i really want to go ahead and select a
different language for my video i have
190 other languages so if i just choose
spanish and choose spanish here so what
youtube can do is make sure this video
is available in spanish so if i go back
to my translation i can add the language
spanish and then if i look on a
particular video then i can go ahead and
you know switch the language from
english to spanish here i can go ahead
and edit the video
any particular part of the video i can
go ahead and go ahead and add subtitles
and make this more spanish friendly so
to speak so you have this option
available to you again this is under
other features translation and
transcription again transcriptions here
allow you to make your videos available
in that language if i go to translation
and transcription i actually have uh the
opportunity to add subtitles to parts of
my video in that particular language
then when i'm done i can go ahead
and submit my contribution so let's take
a look at some other features available
to us under other features so
if i want to go ahead and manage my
different playlists i can go ahead and
select playlist and youtube's going to
open up a new window and here i could
see my one video that he uploaded
earlier is in this playlist here so i
have the opportunity to go ahead and
edit that one video okay i can go ahead
and move it to a different playlist go
ahead and make some other changes okay
so i can go playlist settings and i can
go ahead and go ahead and order the
types of videos that are in that
playlist uh in terms of when they were
added the most popular when they were
published so i have some options
available to me for the playlist uh this
particular playlist that i created
however if i go back i can go ahead and
go and add more playlist if i wanted to
so here i can go ahead and just say test
okay i can again just make this private
to me
or make it public and i just created a
new playlist so
now i can add videos to the playlist um
or go ahead and make some setting
changes to that playlist so that's what
playlists are it's a chance for you to
organize all your videos into different
playlists now some other features
available to us live stream so if we
click on live stream youtube's going to
open up a new window
and now we can live stream our video so
live streaming basically means that
we're going to be able to record right
here and now okay so this is an
opportunity for you to really put
yourself out there uh so if you want to
promote it ahead of time that's probably
why so you get people to
you know go ahead and
watch and take part in the live stream
that you have available to you so really
live streaming is just an easy way to
reach your audience in real time uh it
could be if you're streaming a video
game or hosting a live q a or teaching a
class
basically whatever the reason is it
allows you to really get yourself out
there in front of your audience and so
the whole prerequisite is you want to go
ahead and promote the live stream ahead
of time so that people can take part in
the live stream so that's what live
streaming is so if i click on status and
features youtube's going to open up a
new window that shows me my status and
all the different features available to
me in youtube so see my copyright status
okay in good standing okay so i don't
have any negative basically negative uh
copyright strikes against me so i'm in
good standing there so you want to
follow copyright rules in other words
you know don't grab something in your
video that's already copyrighted okay so
youtube does look for that here you can
see we have all these different features
available to us from live streaming we
can enable it you know we can enable
longer videos okay so we have all these
different options available to us you
know custom thumbnails
annotations okay super chats so we have
all these options and some of them
require you know some account
verification some of them have
prerequisites for
uploading more videos in order to be
eligible but if you want to take a look
at all the features that are available
just click on status and features and
youtube will explain to you what you're
eligible for and what you're not
eligible for so remember if you want to
get to the creator studio you can always
just click on your icon in the upper
right when you click on the icon you're
going to see youtube studio beta just
click on that when you click on that
that's where you're going to get your
dashboard that's going to be where
you're going to be able to edit your
videos look at analytics and insights
respond to comments add some
transcriptions and take advantage of
other features so that's the creator
studio so again once you get going with
your youtube channel you upload the
video and you adjust all your settings i
recommend you look at the video how to
increase youtube subscribers because it
really does complement this video on how
to set up a youtube channel so take a
look at the video we get into really
deep details about how to increase your
subscribers because once you get the
videos on your channel you're gonna want
to
know all the best practices in order to
get people to watch your video today
we're going to talk about how to
increase youtube subscribers so with
youtube it's all about subscribers the
number of subscribers you have on
youtube it's just one of the key metrics
to measure success so gaining more
subscribers can help you achieve more
view counts on your youtube videos so
it's all about how to get subscribers
and today we're going to talk about how
to get more subscribers and before we
begin let's just show you what we did at
simply learn so if we look at the past
365 days on our youtube channel you can
see we started here back in uh if we
look back at march 9 2018 we had 208 and
you can see just over the course of the
year it kept creeping up creeping up
creeping up and creeping up we've gained
you know a significant number of
subscribers over the last year and
what's our secret well it's posting
videos so you can see we've posted a
number of videos over the course of the
year and then our subscribers have gone
basically 165
over the last year so you can see it's
part of it is about posting videos
because when you post videos you have
people who can watch those videos when
you have people watch those videos you
can have engagement and then when you
have engagement you have shares and
people who like it and then other people
will see it so it's kind of a halo
effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase those subscriptions so
let's start out with some of those tips
we're going to start with creating
engagement informative content so
engaging in informative content that's
where we're going to start talking today
about how to increase subscriptions then
we're going to talk about publishing
videos frequently so simply learn you
can see the past 365 days we were
consistent in publishing videos
consistently throughout the month and
the weeks so another tip we're going to
talk about is how to optimize your
youtube videos so there's a lot that
goes into optimization but this is a key
key tip to pay attention to because when
it comes to posting publishing videos on
youtube you need to align certain things
like keywords and content and metadata
so optimize on our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the youtube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you wanna do to optimize your
youtube channel producing high quality
videos we're gonna talk about that
adding a subscriber watermark to your
videos okay that's another tip we're
gonna mention today engage with our
audience okay that's what we want to do
we want to engage with our audience
that's a really key tip we're saving the
best for last promote your videos in
different platforms so all of these tips
we're going to talk about today so let's
get started and talk about create
engaging informative content so that's
the first place we want to start okay so
create engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our channel we have to create highly
engaged and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you got to create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audio okay so when you create a video
who you're creating the video for i mean
that's where it all starts so when
you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on youtube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on youtube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't veer off
course if you veer off course you're not
going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out so what i normally do is
you know have an outline and then once i
have the outline then i go ahead and
create my slides if i will or my topics
points i want to talk about and then i
write out those points i want to make
sure i get all my points in and that's
what you should be doing you want to
plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of the session i showed you an
example of simply learned subscribers
over the past 365 days and so that's
what we want to do we want to be clear
but use examples to punctuate the
content or the point we're trying to get
across so we want to include sources
from high quality sites so if you're
going to use examples make sure they're
from relevant high quality sites when i
mean high quality meaning does your
audience know who that source is or that
site if it's really specific and your
audience may not know then it's probably
not high quality so just keep that in
mind always play to your audience so you
want to start your video with an
interesting hook so again i go back to
this example if you're still watching
this then the hook worked we showed you
our subscriptions we showed you how we
grew over the course of a year you could
see our growth and part of it was
posting a lot of videos with relevant
and informative content and so you see
how we did it so you're paying attention
you want to know how to do it and so
part of what we did is exactly what i'm
telling you now we know who our audience
is we plan out our scripts we use good
examples and we start our videos with
interesting hooks now when we do our
videos we also create original content
so that goes back to planning your
script okay you always want to you know
come across as original and informative
when you do that you're going to be
engaging but if you're leveraging
somebody else's content then the
engaging part may not resonate because
it's not your content to begin with so
always always always use original
content okay so keep the content flow
organized so again that goes back to an
outline you know feel free to change up
the outline so the flow makes sense add
visuals to your content and make it
appealing always include images to me if
you can use images in your videos and
play off the video or the images then
it's just gonna flow and make it a
little bit more engaging and appealing
meaning the content so visuals help
guide and aid in the points you're
trying to make so don't make it so text
heavy you know accentuate it balance it
with some images use simple language and
crisp sentences meaning don't choose
jargon don't come across and talk above
your audience you always want to talk to
your audience and talk in a language
that they're going to understand so it
goes back to point one if you know who
your audience is you're talking to them
as if they're right in front of you and
not you're above them or they're below
you you want to talk at them so add
cards end screens and pattern interrupts
to engage your audience and so youtube
cards are just interactive panels that
slide in and out when a video is playing
so it encourages
interaction by the viewer okay so you
can add up to five cards which include
images text or clickable links so feel
free to play around with some of these
features that youtube has to offer to
make your content more engaging so tip
two publish videos frequently so
creating and uploading videos
consistently will help you increase your
youtube subscribers so suppose you
haven't published videos for more than
say a month or two months it's likely
that that audience not going to
subscribe to your channel so think about
youtube videos as a popular tv program
that comes on once a week when a new
episode comes on based on the regular
schedule it's consistency and that
consistency is what helps your users
stay engaged so for example if i go back
to our youtube channel you know what
helped us gain subscribers was our
consistency in publishing videos you
could see we were consistent publishing
a couple of videos a week every couple
of weeks and so this helps users stay
engaged they know when the video is
coming out they know that simply learn
is good for two three four videos a
month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
gonna get a notification or youtube has
an option where they can get a
notification via email so i subscribed
to simplylearn's channel i subscribe to
other channels like google analytics for
example so anytime google analytics
publishes a video i get an email that
says hey google analytics youtube
channel just published a video and the
great thing is i'm checking my email and
i'm getting this notification in gmail
so guess what i can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email i don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to social
media examiner youtube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are going to be
greater so keeping a fixed frequency can
help you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging i always say start small if you
could do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequency so from one blog
post you could do two a month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week same with the youtube videos you
want to get into a rhythm you know start
with once a month and ramp it up okay
you'll find that the more you ramp it up
the more subscribers you're gonna get so
tip three optimize your youtube videos
so optimizing your videos will help your
content rank higher on youtube so this
is a give must it's not a given it's a
must you must optimize your videos if
you want people to see them of course if
you don't optimize people aren't going
to see them then people aren't going to
engage and then not subscribe so it's
just kind of a snowball effect so this
is an important tip so i mentioned it at
the beginning when we were going over
all the items we're going to discuss
this is the one item that is a must and
a given to some degree because if you
don't optimize your videos they're just
not going to be found so you need that
audience to watch your video so
audiences who tend to interact more with
your content have more chance to
subscribe to your channel but they're
not going to subscribe if they don't
even watch your video so there is a
snowball effect in play here if we don't
optimize your videos so okay rob what
are some of the tips to optimize your
youtube video well let's go through some
of those tips so to ensure your videos
reaches the relevant audience on youtube
you need to optimize the title
description in the video tag okay rob
what do you mean by title description
and video tag so let's take a look at
that so when you actually create your
youtube video you're going to have an
opportunity to put in a title you're
going to have an opportunity to put in a
description and you're going to have an
opportunity to add text so those are the
three key areas okay so once you put in
that what it looks like on the front end
is this so if i go back to youtube and
here you can see another video that we
did about a month ago you could see what
is seo so if that's our topic that's our
title uh or of the content of the video
then the title of the video is going to
be what is seo and you can see we also
added in some other content for the
title so what is seo and how does it
work seo tutorial for beginners and then
our brand name so we have some content
to work with for the title okay and then
the description we have a lot of
characters to work with descriptions so
use as much as you can here to describe
what the video is about here you can see
we did that and so it's always good to
include this information okay and then
you can see we have tags up here seo seo
tutorial for beginners digital marketing
so we put in the necessary information
here on this video to help us rank
because if we don't optimize it we're
not going to rank and so you can see we
just put a lot of relevant content
around the description around the title
and around those tags by doing so we're
able to optimize this video and get
found so that's just an example three of
the things you can do to help optimize
your youtube video so if you want to
watch more on how to optimize meta tags
then i suggest maybe watching the other
video we did on the subject how to rank
youtube videos so this goes into more
detail about how to optimize the title
the meta description and the meta tags
but those are three quick fields or
areas that you can use to optimize your
video so just something to keep in mind
write a long description with keywords
time stamps and links so what i mean by
time stands for timestamp an audience
can choose the section of the video that
they want to look for and then links
prefer to include relevant links of your
other videos so those are just some
additional tips to help keep your
content engaging so remember when your
content is engaging then people are
going to like it people are going to
share it and watch it later so upload a
captivating thumbnail okay so you want
to include a thumbnail that's going to
grab people's attention you want to
upload a transcript of the video so that
goes back to when you're creating your
content when you write your original
content you want to keep a transcript of
the content of the video so that you can
upload that as well and then add a start
screen and end screen to your youtube
videos so that way you know when
somebody plays the video they're gonna
see it what it looks like up front and
then we finish it they're gonna see an
end screen at the end and so you just
don't want to keep it dark and black and
non-descriptive so according to
backlinko using an exact keyword in your
video title can help you with rankings
so high ranking more views more views
more subscribers so that's what i've
been saying all along you need to get
these videos optimized so again use an
exact keyword in your video title so
let's go back again to that video i just
showed you a couple minutes ago what is
seo so here we started out with a
question what is seo that's the name of
the title that's one our exact title of
the video that's our exact keyword okay
so what is seo and how does it work and
then seo tutorial for beginners so what
is seo is our exact keyword and that's
part of the video that's the content of
the video that's in the title and we use
it throughout the description as well so
using that exact keyword in your video
title can help with the ranking so
whatever your topic is your title of the
video or the topic of the video included
in the title so backlinko also mentions
that there is a moderate correlation
between a channel's total subscribers
and rankings and so for some of you this
may be common sense it's just like
organic search if you're not ranking
you're not going to get traffic on
youtube if you're not ranking you're not
going to get eyeballs on your videos and
you're not going to get subscribers so
higher rankings can help you to get more
subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title matches the title of the
video itself when you're publishing your
description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
it this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which you'll turn
into subscribers so tip four optimize
your youtube channel so we just talked
about optimizing our videos now we're
going to turn our attention to our
youtube channel so one of the easiest
ways to ask your viewers to subscribe to
your channel is really by creating a
good not even a good a great youtube
channel trailer you also want to add
channel keywords a description and some
good artwork and then having sections
and playlists to keep your videos
organized these are all good tips to
creating a good youtube channel so let's
talk about some of these these tips here
so we want to give your audience a
preview what your channel is offering so
this is by hooking your audience with a
trailer so you can create a trailer to
you know just give your audience an idea
of who you are as a brand what kind of
videos you're going to be posting and
give them a kind of a taste of what the
future videos are going to be like okay
you can even tell them your release
schedule in the trailer so you can start
off by saying hey hey guys we're new to
this we're going to be posting one video
a month but as we get rolling maybe two
per month and you know one per week you
know just being honest and open and
talking into your audience and get them
excited about future videos that's what
the trailer is all about so you also
want to keep it that the channel
description short interesting so in your
channel you want to have a description
of what the channel is all about what
kind of videos you're going to be
posting so in addition to the trailer
you want to write something short and
interesting then we want to use keywords
in our channel descriptions just like in
the videos with what is seo we included
what is seo in the title we included you
know what is seo in the description and
so we want to be true to what our
channel is so pick keywords not only
include those keywords in the videos but
include them in the channel description
pay attention to the first 100 to 150
characters of your channel description
because that's what's shown next your
channel on the search results so for
example here you can see we have a
description here simply learn is one of
the world's leading certification
training providers we partner with
companies and individuals to address and
so you can see those characters
100-150 are what shows up in the channel
description when somebody's trying to
understand hey simply learn just
uploaded this video who is simply
learning so you want to write short
interesting channel description so that
when somebody's first introduced to your
video they could see what your brand's
all about so and your description with
an appropriate call to action so short
interesting good call to action at the
end of the video a good call to action
would be hey check out our next video or
check out our latest video something
that's going to gauge somebody and get
them to watch one of your videos so you
want to pick interesting channel art so
let's turn our attention to the simply
learn channel page and here you can see
we recently
had reached a milestone so recently
reached the 200 000 k subscribers so 200
000 subscribers is a big achievement for
simply learn we went ahead and updated
our channel our and i'm sure we will
reach 500k we'll update the artwork then
too but the point is you want to keep
your channel art kind of interesting hip
and cool and feel free to change it out
every once in a while so you have that
option in youtube to do i mean it's very
simple so here you can see simply learns
channel we go home get all our videos
listed here we got the about us you know
something very short interesting about
us here's our call to action for more
information visit simply learn so you
want to make sure when you create your
channel get some good artwork in there
put your description in play and create
your first videos and get them posted up
there and optimize them accordingly okay
so some other tips to go with that
channel art and description is a profile
picture relevant to your brand so you
always want to maybe put
the company logo up there okay so here
you can see we have the company logo at
accurate relevant channel keywords so if
we go back to who we are who are we
we're the world's leading certification
training provider okay that's who we are
okay we partner with companies and
individuals so we're all about training
and training is one of our keywords so
you can see that simply learn we provide
online training and machine learning aws
amazon web services devops big data
digital marketing project management a
lot of different topics so make sure
that's included in the channel
description feature the playlist on your
home page so if we go back to the home
page we can see here we have our
channels so you can see we have ai
machine learning trending technologies
cloud computing tutorials devop
tutorials popular videos big data we
have a lot of different channels so you
want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but i
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're seeing the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you
could take a video that maybe hasn't
gotten a lot of views or isn't ranked
particularly high maybe put that video
up so you can get some views and some
shares and likes so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you just
have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video so for example if i go
back to our youtube page you can see the
top performing videos here you know for
example this one we got a nice thumbnail
here what is machine learning so if i
click on that
most popular videos so 3 000 likes on
this video a lot of views 250 000 plus
views so have a thumbnail to go along
with that particular video so according
to backlinko youtube seo ranking factor
study discovered that channel keywords
have a small yet significant correlation
with higher youtube search rankings so
channel keywords so when you're
optimizing your channel and you want to
include keywords start with your
description so if i go back to our
channel if i go back about us make sure
your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
that gets posted on our videos so if
you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
align keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
us a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to get in
the habit of producing high quality
videos because viewers don't prefer to
watch videos that have poor audio and
video quality it's just that simple you
need to know what it takes to produce
high quality videos if you don't you're
just going to discredit you're not going
to come across as relevant you're not
going to come across as qualified
professional there's a lot of things
attached to poor quality videos so we
need to
create high quality videos for the end
users so let's talk about some ways in
which you can create high quality videos
and so the first is to avoid any noise
in the background so you want to have a
nice quiet atmosphere no distractions so
people can hear you clearly and only you
clearly you want to use good audio
recording equipment there's plenty of
options available on the internet
usually i would recommend going with
something paid not overly expensive
because you get what you pay for so if
you use something free it might not be
of good quality and you might not have
all the features and bells and whistles
with a free option so you know use good
audio recording equipment again it could
be online or it could be some software
just make sure that you're able to
produce good high quality video and
audio so when you do purchase that audio
recording equipment you want to have
something similar to an input volume
meter that way you can see
whether your audio is coming across or
not so if you're not seeing green lights
then your audio is not coming across if
it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good quality audio you want to create
your videos in 10 80 pixel size okay
that's hd and so you want to have at
least minimum 1080. so anything less
than that it's probably gonna come
across as not so good maybe staticky
blurry
not professional not high def so you
want to create a high def video and 1080
is about the minimum you want to go and
then you want to plan your video script
before filming so it goes back to some
of the other points i made earlier you
always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professional so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
as good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video you know using slow motion and
jump cuts are some of the features you
can use to
accentuate your points and then set up a
green background for recording again
this is for you know making sure that
the video part of it comes across in
good quality and stabilize your video
recordings with a tripod that way you're
not moving your video camera all around
and and again it's coming across as
shaky and poor quality shoot horizontal
videos you don't want to go vertical it
tends to cut the screen so you want to
stay horizontal so that people can see
everything that should be included in
the video okay you want to capture a
wider shot using a clip-on lens again a
good feature good tip to use use that
wider shot okay so you could do that
using a clip-on lens and then choose
good video editing software i can't
state this enough because you're putting
all this time and effort into a video
you need to be able to edit it to cut
out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
i would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video and
at the very least review your work
before publishing i just said it a
minute ago i'll say it again you want to
be able to have a really professional
video and high def when you have a good
professional video and high def with
good audio horizontal shots you know
nice green background image nice well
lit it's gonna come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are gonna
take you seriously they're gonna see you
as a professional and then share or
subscribe and like and then they're
going to watch more videos and and
that's how you start to build up a
reputation as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're going to
realize hey your video is low quality
and then you're going to have to do it
all over again so follow these tips get
a high quality video and you should be
on your way to ranking in fact according
to backlinko youtube preferably ranks hd
videos so you got to have that 1080 uh
pixel size that way you know your video
is gonna come across crisp and clear and
youtube prefers that tip six add a
subscriber watermark to your videos so
this is a great feature in youtube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your channel the watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so how do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your youtube account it's it's
pretty simple at the top right corner
you're going to select your creator
studio icon and then you're going to go
to channel select branding and then add
a watermark to your video so if we look
at that in youtube so here creator
studio on the left side navigation i'm
just going to click channel then i'm
going to click branding and then once
you click branding you have the ability
to add your watermark and then you can
add it to the entire video at the end of
the video at a specific start time and
then just click update and that's pretty
much it so you want to be able to add
this so that you can brand your videos
with an image and then add that cta so
this is a good good feature for youtube
it allows you to be consistent with all
your videos by branding and adding that
call to action tip seven engage with
your audience so you want to be able to
interact with your audience as much as
possible just because the video and you
can't see people doesn't mean you can't
engage with them so when you interact
with your viewers especially when you
interact with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of your busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you can thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with youtube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on other ways to engage with
your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on youtube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback is always going to be positive
some of the feedback could be less than
positive or even negative there could be
mistakes so the idea behind getting
feedback is you want to look at it you
want to read it and you want to react to
it you want to react to it positively in
the form of you know what thank you for
the feedback and looking at the feedback
weighing it and incorporating the
feedback so you don't always want to
make the same mistake twice in a video
so if there's something definitely wrong
with the video that we're doing for
example and somebody looked at it and
gave us feedback on it we'd certainly
definitely take a deep look into that
and try not to do the same mistake twice
because likely that user is going to
watch the video again so you always want
to learn from your mistakes and you want
to turn those mistakes or turn those
comments into future videos okay so
create videos based on your commenter's
request the audience is giving us
feedback we should take that as positive
and sometimes that's creative sometimes
those ideas for more videos okay you
always want to ask questions to your
audience and reward excellent commenters
so we try to ask questions in our videos
and when users respond with the answer
if there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them in the form of
say some type of gift card or gift
certificate or promotion or something
there's always some way to incentivize
somebody who provides excellent feedback
you can always give emoji hearts there's
so many emojis out there that you can
use emojis just to engage with your
audience based on the feedback that
they're giving the point is if your
audience has taken the time to give
feedback you always want to respond to
it and you want to respond to a positive
so emojis tend to have a positive
connotation to them and so responding
with an emoji especially to a favorite
comment goes a long way so you can
reward your community both on and off
youtube for their engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways many ways not
necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
youtube has them other platforms like
facebook have them instagram so you can
certainly reach out to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience right there in
the flesh so when you can have an
opportunity to talk to your audience and
engage with them that's always going to
work because they can see personality
they can see what you're all about and
there's two-way conversation and so that
will lend to more of a you know
relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan base so if
you create something for them that's a
form of a reward so you can captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
youtube stories as well you can also
hear from your audience and get their
videos and use their videos and upload
them to your channel so according to
backlinko video comments have a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey if you
have any comments feel free to put them
in the comment section right below this
video i see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and i'm going to ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free to comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings but with
your subscriber base so comments are the
way to go solicit comments respond to
the comments reward the comments tip
number eight promote your videos on
different platforms so promoting your
videos on different platforms has been
around for many years it's a good
strategy once you create your video on
youtube you want people to see it you
want to get it out there so if you want
to increase your youtube subscribers
this is a strategy you have to perform
so let's take a look at all the ways you
can use and leverage different platforms
to increase your subscribers so before
you do that you want to research
discover how and
you can use different platforms so the
first thing you want to do is look at
the platforms you're already using
you're using facebook and instagram
that's probably a good place to start
but there's other platforms you can also
leverage and we're going to talk about
those so social media most companies
most individuals are on in some form or
fashion amongst the most popular like
facebook and instagram so you could
start there so with facebook you can
post something include the link of your
youtube video with facebook if you're a
business you have a business page you're
communicating with your community and
that's a great way to get started by
promoting your youtube video you can
also do the same on twitter or instagram
or whatever platform you're on go ahead
and post something or tweet something
and include that link to youtube you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in a discussion and include
a link to the youtube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a blog about machine learning
you can include if you have a video
about machine learning in the response
to that conversation in this example
we've done that on reddit you can list
your video in relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use testimonial link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimonial
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here test genix okay there's a article
here about you know certificate of
achievements okay for aws so if you
scroll down we could see our video is
included here in this particular web
page so this is a high quality web page
okay that's generating a backlink for us
not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic and
awareness for the video go ahead and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to your video topic and see
if you can collaborate with them on
producing a web page to include that
video you can also take advantage of
email marketing by adding your youtube
link in the email signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like gmail or yahoo or even hotmail or
outlook is going to have an ability to
or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature you could
simply just include a link to the video
or to your youtube channel it doesn't
have to be do a specific video but it's
a way to get people to your youtube page
or to that video so the whole idea is
more eyeballs more potential subscribers
engage your audience by posting your
video links on community pages so for
example you know we're promoting
something here on a community page and
that's going to get some additional
traffic over to us you can always
bookmark your videos on bookmarking
sites like stumbledupon.com again this
is free very little time to do this but
it's a chance for you to get the video
out there and even generate a backlink
you can collaborate with other youtube
channels this is always a good strategy
if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on youtube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their channel
and you can take their video and put it
on your channel in a particular playlist
okay so that's a way to collaborate with
other youtube channels is swap videos
you could join high pr qa sites and post
answers to the questions related to your
video like core is always a good example
or e-hop okay so core there's always a
question being posted and if you have
the answer to that question in the form
of your video then go ahead and post a
response with a link to the video on
youtube it's a great way to get the
video noticed and it's relevant and
natural okay you can embed videos in
your blog post so if you're using a
platform like wordpress for example very
easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link in
the blog post i like this option i think
blog posts are always good because you
don't have to be text heavy with a blog
post you want to create a blog post
that's nice and balanced with an image
and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so having a video in your blog
post always goes well in my opinion okay
so you can promote other videos in your
end screen for example at the end of
your video you can always promote
something related like we've done here
in this example so lots of ideas get
your video out there use them in email
use them in your blog post go to free
bookmarking sites like stumbleupon you
know collaborate with other people on
youtube you know go to core respond to a
question use social media to your
advantage there's lots of opportunities
to get your video out there the more you
can get your video out there the more
traffic you're gonna get the more
traffic you get to the video the more
subscribers you're going to get so
that's how the game is played in order
to get your video out there but these
are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video some
some subscribers so let's turn our
attention to some key takeaways from
today's video tip one you always want to
create engaging and informative content
so that's where it all starts remember
think about what you want to say and do
before you do it know your audience
that's really the key takeaway know your
audience tip two publish videos
frequently okay you don't have to start
out publishing three or four a week you
know start out publishing one a month if
that's how it works for you and then
once you build momentum once you start
getting a loyal fan base and start
getting more subscribers then think
about increasing your video output tip
three optimize your youtube videos title
description tags that's always a good
place to start you want to work in that
keyword that's relevant to the topic and
work that into the title work it into
the description and work it into those
tags tip 4 you want to optimize your
youtube channel there's lots of features
available okay you want to start with
your description of your channel because
the description is what shows up when
somebody does a search or sees your
video so that is key you always want to
optimize your channel as well as your
videos tip 5 we want to produce high
quality videos remember 1080 on the
pixel you know use good audio video
equipment don't necessarily go free go
with something low cost but make sure
you're using something that's going to
output good audio and video quality
because people are going to take you
serious tip six good feature in youtube
under the channel settings okay in the
creator studio you want to be able to
add a subscriber watermark that way
people know who you are and you can add
that call to action so that they can
scribe to your video tip seven engage
with your audience comments comments
comments in fact for those watching this
video now if you have any comments on
any of the tips that we provided feel
free to put them in there we will
respond and we will reward and that's
what you want to do with your audience
you want to engage with your audience to
make them feel like they're part of the
community and part of the solution and
then tip eight promote your videos in
different platforms there's plenty of
opportunities from social to blog posts
to influencer marketing to email
marketing lots of different
opportunities to get that link out there
the more you can get that link out there
the more traffic you're gonna drive the
more traffic the more eyeballs are gonna
realize hey this is some good stuff here
i'm gonna subscribe to this video i'm
gonna subscribe to this channel and i'm
gonna wait for this channel to produce
more videos so these are the tips and
with these key takeaways and these tips
you should be on your way to increasing
your subscriber base so thanks again i'm
rob sanders and i'm with simply learn
and let's get started and we're going to
do a little role playing here and let's
just say you're an advertiser and you're
not sure where you want to advertise
your products you have a product that
you want the entire world to see well
if you want to advertise your products
and let's just say you have some really
good video of your product that you want
to get out there really there's no other
place to look to than one place in
particular is youtube hence the reason
why we're doing this webinar because
today we're going to talk about
all things youtube advertising and for
those that don't know youtube is owned
by google and a lot of what you're going
to do is advertise on youtube via google
ads so today we're going to talk about
youtube advertising and we're going to
focus somewhat on google ads so buckle
up and let's get started with why is
advertising on youtube a good idea so
why is it a good idea well if you
haven't been on youtube of late you
should check it out youtube.com and just
take a look at the vastness of videos
that are on youtube now youtube is a
video platform but if it was a search
engine it'd be the second largest search
engine in the world only behind its
parent company google so it's a very big
platform with a lot of videos and hence
there's some good search functionality
on youtube so you can look at it as a
search engine there's 1.9 billion and
growing logged in visitors on a monthly
basis so you have a lot of people that
go to youtube and watch videos on a
daily basis okay it has local versions
in more than 91 countries so if you're
an advertiser who's focusing on a
specific market or you're in a different
market with a different language you
have 91 different options to hone in on
okay so a little bit more about youtube
here and why is advertising on youtube a
good idea well most youtube users are on
mobile almost seventy percent almost
three quarters of those that you you use
youtube use it from their mobile device
which is staggering but not so
staggering considering most people in
the world now have mobile
phones or mobile devices and most people
use their mobile devices for multiple
reasons and
watching videos is one of those reasons
so mobile advertisements receive viewer
attention 83 percent of the time so what
do we mean by that well on youtube we
have the opportunity to get your ad in
front of people who are watching those
videos so if a lot of people are engaged
in watching a video on youtube and
you're advertising on that particular
video well
then you're going to get some attention
and so that attention has to be in the
80 percentile okay so a lot of people
are going to you know pay somewhat
attention to your ad and it's no secret
video ads have proven to be more
effective and engaging creating greater
impact and and that's just not on
youtube i mean that's that's on facebook
that's on other platforms like twitter
instagram so video is an engaging way to
communicate it's a lot better than
traditional text it's a lot better than
say a display banner because it's
engaging people are gonna watch what you
have to say and if they like it they're
gonna share they're gonna comment on it
they're going to subscribe there's a lot
of things that people can do when it
comes to video advertising so video
helps expand your digital reach so
basically if you are running those text
ads and display ads well having video
kind of
adds some more arsenal to
your advertising portfolio so to speak
so if you're running just those text ads
and banners that's fine that's great
because you can reach a lot of people
but having video just adds another piece
of the element and because video's so
engaging you might find that even for
yourself if you're advertising different
types of ads video display or text
you'll find that you know video does
have really really expansive reach to a
particular audience and the other thing
here about youtube is youtube helps to
find a relevant audience for your ads
using advanced targeting so just like
anything else that we've talked about
here at simply learn when it comes to
advertising whether that be facebook or
instagram
or google ads we can really hone in on
our audience here and that's really
important and we'll get to that later
because
when you're advertising you want to make
sure your ad is in front of the right
people and if we're talking about video
we're talking about high engagement if
you have your video in front of a really
relevant audience then chances of that
audience engaging can be even greater
and then youtube and video ads
themselves provide it provides a
situation that can be customized to
fulfill your marketing goals and so what
do we mean by that so
basically youtube allows us some
additional features where we can
customize our ads so meaning if our
marketing goal is to just get our ad in
front of millions of people well that's
not a problem if our marketing goals get
people who
you know we want to convert well we can
customize our marketing goal towards
that as well so just like on facebook
and some of these other platforms we've
talked about youtube is no different and
so we could set specific marketing goals
for our video ads some other good
pointers to talk about here with youtube
so with youtube just like on google ads
we can enable running cost-effective
campaigns and what do i mean by
cost-effective well meaning we can
really watch our budget we can measure
how how much it cost for 1 000 people to
watch our video or we can measure how
much it costs for
somebody to click on our video ad we can
measure the cost of when somebody clicks
on our video ad and converts how much
does that cost in us so you can really
run cost effective campaigns even on
youtube and youtube helps determine how
successful your ads with advanced
analytics so not only do we have
analytics on the youtube side of the
house but we also have analytics on
google ads and so we can really hone in
and use both platforms to really figure
out exactly how our ads are performing
and then ads that have reported a 500
growth in views of the channel's other
videos so basically you can see growth
in views just by advertising on youtube
so let's get in now to what are the
types of ads you can run on youtube so
we discussed all the benefits of youtube
we can go on for another two or three
hours because there are plenty of
benefits but i think you get the point
of you know youtube being a place where
you can grow measure and reach a custom
audience so
you're already sold on youtube now let's
talk about those types of ads you want
to run on youtube so depending on what
goal you want to achieve with your ads
there are different types of ad formats
available on youtube so our first set of
ads evolve around building brand
awareness and ad recalls so if you're in
the business of promoting your
product or your brand or your service
then these are the type of ads you want
to run on youtube building brand
awareness and ad recalls because what it
does is it's really going to get your ad
out there in front of thousands and
millions of people lots of eyeballs lots
of impressions impressions are the
number of times your ad was seen so ads
centered around brand awareness are
really ads that are going to put you out
there in front of a large number of
people with the goal of potentially
attracting new customers and ensuring
your brand is on top of their mind so
top of funnel brand awareness is always
introducing the brand getting people
familiar with the brand and getting them
to your website so that you can
introduce them to your brand and service
and product so that's the whole idea
behind the ads we're going to introduce
behind the goal building brand awareness
and ad recalls so let's take a look at
what those are so
we can build brand awareness and add
recalls so we call these these types of
ads trueview for reach okay so when we
say trueview meaning our ads going to
appear in front of a video and we want
to make sure that that adds in front of
a lot of people so skippable ads that
will enable your brand to reach as many
people in your target audience as
possible at the most efficient price so
the whole idea is we're trying to build
brand awareness then we could set it up
on youtube so that our ad appears before
other videos and that's going to ensure
that our ad is going to show up in a lot
of places based on the audience we
target and if we can get our ad in front
of
a lot of people a lot of targeted people
at an efficient price then how can you
say no to that so these ads are
skippable have an open video length and
their bidding is based on cost per 1000
impressions so cost per 1000 impressions
cpm means that you're paying youtube for
every 1000 people that looked at your ad
okay so that's what cost per 1000
impressions or cpm means that you're
paying youtube not when somebody clicks
on your ad but when 1 000 impressions
occurring an oppression is when somebody
looks at your ad and so that's where
you're going to be paying youtube you're
going to be paying them for 1 000 views
or impressions basically okay so the ads
are skippable but they have an open
video length and
it's based on eyeballs so that's the
whole goal there
when it comes to brand awareness you
want to go with a cpm model that ensures
you're getting your ads in front of
lots of people to accumulate impressions
and pay by impressions so this is what
the ad looks like and now we're going to
talk about the type 2 ad that you can
run on youtube and we call these bumper
ads so they're non-skippable ads with
which you can share your brand's message
in six seconds to drive reach and impact
so we've all seen these videos before
and i'm going to share an example with
you here when you're on youtube you
really can't get to that video that you
really want to watch until you watch a
few seconds of that video ad and so
that's what these bumper ads are they
allow you to
really make sure that your ad is in
front of that target audience still it's
still paid by impressions but you know
that your ad is going to run for a few
seconds and the idea behind that is
really you want to get your message out
there and it really does help to drive
reach and impact and so let's take an
exam look at an example on youtube of
what a bumper ad looks like so here's an
example of a bumper ad on youtube and
it's only six seconds but this example
it's pretty popular on youtube it's uh
been viewed a lot and we're just gonna
take a quick look at this video here
this video has six seconds but the whole
point is to really look at the ads
purpose and so if we hit play
[Music]
so that was it that was the ad six
seconds long it appears in in front of
other videos as an advertisement and the
whole point of these bumper ads is
really you have to get your message out
there quickly because the video is going
to start and
you want to really make sure that your
message is being delivered and you want
to keep in this case maybe keep users
guessing as to what it is and so this is
why it's a highly effective ad you know
you got a diver jumping off a diving
board into a pool that is basically
drying up over a period of time and so
for curiosity the old saying is
curiosity kills the cat a lot of people
are probably going to click on that ad
to figure out what is the subject what
are we all talking about here and really
the point of the the video was to bring
awareness about global warming but
that's it that's a six second bumper ad
example and you really if you're gonna
run bumper ads you want to make sure
that you get your message out there so
it has to have really high impact okay
so again they're non-skippable they have
to be of six seconds and their bidding
is based on again cos 1000 impressions
so it gives you a chance to get that ad
out there in front of a lot of people
again you're paying on a cpm model
you're paying google for every 1000
impression okay so that's could be 1000
different eyeballs looking at that ad so
if it's high impact you know if it's
non-skippable then chances are you can
get you know some clicks some some
eyeballs over to your youtube channel or
to your landing page on your website so
let's take a look at this one from
alaska airlines better yet let's take a
look at this example from airbnb i found
it to be a little bit more impactful
than the alaska air one so let's take a
look at this example actually so
we went on vacation with a tow dipper
and left with a cannonballer
okay so high impact ad great ad by
airbnb really impactful we went on
vacation kids playing you have your logo
on the bottom right corner of the video
and you know it gets people excited
about travel so similar to the alaska
airlines which we didn't look at this
one is just as good high impactful you
know getting people to
you know react within six seconds isn't
exactly a very easy thing to do so
you gotta make sure these videos really
resonate within the time frame that you
have so let's take a look at type three
here so we're talking about reservation
of 15 to 20 seconds so these particular
ads can span up to 20 seconds to
increase reach and make a lasting
impression so unlike the bumper ads
which are six seconds long these
reservation ads tend to run a few
seconds longer up to 20 seconds okay so
they're also non-skippable and like i
said can be up to 20 seconds and bidding
is based on a fixed cpm and what do we
mean by fixed cpm well if you're bidding
on a regular cpm model meaning that
you're paying google for every 1 000
impressions that number could be
variable what you pay google in this
case the fixed cpm is fixed at a certain
rate it could be you know ten dollars
for every one thousand impressions
twenty dollars it really depends on
where you're advertising and who else is
advertising so let's take a look at some
examples of a reservation ad on youtube
up to 15 to 20 seconds long so here is
an example of a
15 second ad
also called a trueview ad so
you can see this ad is going to run for
about 15 seconds before the video
actually plays it's non-skippable and so
let's just play this ad
who can paint the corners is known as a
red brand at gmc we get that
everyone loves that kind of
precision
this is gmc
okay so you can see the ad itself uh ran
a little bit longer than your
traditional or your six second
non-skippable version and the 15 second
you know allows you to get you know more
of the message out there still high
impactful but allows us to get the
message out there um with a little bit
longer of a video and that's
non-skippable so it's so going to run
for its entirety up to 15-20 seconds
before the video actually starts playing
so let's now turn our attention to the
fourth type of ad you can run on youtube
and that four type is an outstream video
ad and so these ads are going to reach
users wherever they're watching
regardless of the site or application
it's the whole point of the out stream
we want to be able to get our ads out
there regardless of the site or
application okay so these ads are also
non-skippable and they can be 15 to 20
seconds long and their bidding is based
on viewable cost per 1000 impressions
and so what do we mean by viewable cost
per 1000 impressions what we mean by
viewable cost per 1000 impressions is
basically
if you're paying for ad impressions
measured as viewable you you can use
this model and basically what that means
that an ad is counted as viewable
when fifty percent of your ad shows on
screen for one second or longer or plays
continuously for two seconds or longer
so there's some criteria about the
viewable but you're definitely paying
for impressions you're just paying when
those impressions showcase the ad 50
or longer or for one second or longer
for you know other type of video ads or
it plays continuously for two seconds or
longer for video ads so if it plays in
short if it plays for longer than two
seconds then you're going to pay for
that impression and so that's going to
count as an impression and that's
viewable for 1000 impressions so
if you get your basically your ad to
show for two seconds or longer then then
that's going to count as an impression
so for example with the viewable cpm for
example if you bid on 1000 viewable
impressions and you pay for impressions
that are measured as viewable an ad is
counted as viewable again when 50 of
your ad shows on the screen for one
second or longer for display ads and two
seconds or longer for video ads so uh so
that's basically what it's about so
really the key number here with viewable
cpm is two seconds or longer that's the
difference between regular 1000
impression cpm and viewable 1000
impressions vcpm so let's talk about the
next type of ad format you can run on
youtube and the next one is masted and
so mousetad is unique in that basically
they only run for 24 hours okay so and
they run on youtube's home page so you
can imagine the amount of reach that you
can have by
advertising on youtube's home page so
they're highly visible okay they can run
on multiple devices desktop app mobile
and basically these ads sit at the top
of youtube's home page so
they're fixed cost per day pricing
involved and so the best thing to do is
to contact youtube if you're interested
in advertising on youtube's home page so
that's the masthead advertising and
basically these ads are non-skippable
they have an open length and again their
bidding is based on fixed price per day
so here's an example of what the
masthead looks like on the home page so
you can see here this is that gmc ad
okay you can see that they have a video
supported with a banner and you know
call to action out there and so what
youtube is actually experimenting with
are you know different ways for
advertisers to buy masthead ads okay so
it's you know these ads are very
prominent so
it's it's basically youtube is now
offering the option uh to buy masthead
ads on a cost per 1000 impression basis
so they're playing around with that cost
format so just keep in mind that this is
a recent change by youtube so
traditionally it's cost per day but now
they're actually offering the option for
advertisers to buy a masthead ad on a
cpm basis so just keep that in mind you
do you do have the option here so at the
end of the day if you're interested in
master's ads and having your ads show up
on youtube's home homepage for 24 hours
i would still contact google and ask
them about hey i want to pay cosport 1
000 impressions so youtube is actually
offering up that option on pricey model
so the second set of ads we're going to
focus in on are
centered around this strategy of growth
consideration and interest and the whole
idea behind growth consideration and
interest is really we want to get our
ads in front of people who could be
potential customers but we want to
influence them okay we want to influence
them at a point in time when they when
we think they're going to be most
receptive to our message so that really
means getting our ad out in front of the
right audience at the right time because
the message we put out there is going to
be centered around you know getting them
to not only take notice of our brand
potentially take action so it's moving
our audience a little further down that
funnel so really growth consideration
and interest it's all about
placing your ad your message in front of
that potential customer when you think
they're going to be most receptive to
the messaging you're putting out so
that's what growth consideration and
interest is so let's go back and look at
let's talk a little bit more about those
trueview ads so
trueview ads are one of the most popular
ways of advertising on youtube so if
you're interested in
you know getting growth getting leads
getting conversions you might want to
think about some trueview ads because
basically these ads can run before
during or after videos on youtube or you
can run them on video partner sites and
applications again if you're interested
in driving not just brand awareness but
you know clicks to your site so if
you're interested in driving impact for
your brand of products you might want to
focus on the true view and stream ads
again these are the traditional ads
you've probably
seen before on youtube that run before
during or after a video and these ads
are skippable so you're likely to have
seen the skip add uh call to action
button they have an open video length
and their bidding is based on cost per
view so you're paying when somebody
views your ad and so what what's what
does that mean cost per view let's break
that down cost for review bidding is the
default way to set the amount you'll pay
for a trueview video ad so
when are you actually paying well you're
paying when somebody views your video
and but there's a threshold here so a
view is counted on youtube when someone
watches 30 at least 30 seconds of your
video ad or if it's shorter than 30
seconds and let's just say it's 20
seconds then that's gonna be considered
a view so 30 seconds is the number here
you need to be concerned about when
you're running a cost per view model so
if you have a video that's one minute
long and they watch 30 seconds it's
considered a view and that's what you're
going to pay you're going to pay cost
per view so that's what the cost per
view model is and that's the really the
default model with trueview ads whether
that be before the video during the
video or after the video it's it's cost
per view so let's talk about the other
type of trueview ad and that's the true
view discovery and so basically what
trueview discovery is is your ads are
placed in youtube search results next to
related videos or on the youtube
homepage so you're getting your ad
discovered more or less you know
throughout youtube and including the
youtube homepage so here's an example of
what that looks for looks like and so
let's jump over to youtube and take a
look at that so if i do type in let's
just say surfing i may scroll down and i
may see some ads i may not see some ads
so basically if you see an ad it's going
to have ad next to it and so that's when
you know your ad is being discovered on
youtube and so here in this example we
don't see any ads showing up here so
remember those
view discovery ads are going to have
something with the ad next to them that
way you know it's an advertisement uh
and they're going to be found in the
search results um on youtube's homepage
or
any page where you're actually searching
okay third set of ad type center around
driving action and so the whole point of
driving action is getting that potential
customer to actually take action on the
ad that they see so in the case of
videos we're gonna have some call to
action stronger call to action to get
these folks over to the website to
purchase or download or
you know sign up for a newsletter or do
something you want them to do
in terms of your business model so if
your business model is selling a product
then the whole point of driving action
on your ad is getting them to buy your
product we want so the whole point of
driving action is making it easier for
customers to take meaningful actions
that you can measure so the ads we're
going to introduce are centered around
getting potential customers to take
action okay so that's what driving
action is further down the funnel and
getting folks to react to your ad so
that they can take the action that's
aligned with your business talking about
trueview ads now and so again these ads
discovery can show up on search results
on youtube's homepage uh you have your
traditional in-stream trueview ads where
they show up before during or after and
then here you have trueview for action
and so these trueview for action ads are
video ads to drive any action that's
important to your business so again it
goes back to that marketing strategy so
the ads we looked at on early on were
about impressions so a lot of the cost
models for a lot of the ad types were
cost per 1000 impression and notice now
that you know it's it's now cost per
view for trueview ads and you want to be
on a different model when your marketing
strategy is more aligned with getting
people to take action that's important
to your business for example shopping or
buying something or getting a quote or
or downloading something so if that's
your marketing goal you want to go with
a true view for action if that's what's
important your business because these
ads are intended to get users to
interact with a clickable button that
leads to your site so that's the whole
idea behind trueview for action type ads
okay so these are skippable they have an
open video length and their bidding is
based on cost per acquisition so cpa
different cost models so let's now talk
about what cpa is so the cost per
acquisition model is in this case since
we're trying to drive action we're gonna
pay when somebody actually takes that
action so if somebody actually does shop
and they spend twenty dollars then
basically you're gonna pay for that
acquisition so
basically if it's to download something
whatever it costs for you to get that
person over and they actually download
that's what you're going to pay so cost
per acquisition
is really a model based on action so
when somebody actually performs at
action that's when you're actually going
to pay google so that's what cpa is and
that's what the youtube trueview for
action ads are all about trying to drive
action so let's talk about the universal
app campaign for video and so this is
all about driving action as well so
these ads promote your app on youtube so
where your ads are more likely to be
clicked and your app downloaded so again
targeting an audience and really it's
about you know getting people to
look at your application your mobile app
so that's what these ads are all about
they're about promoting your mobile app
on youtube okay so these ads are
skippable okay they have an open video
length okay meaning you can make them as
long as you want and again their bidding
is cost per acquisition but you also
have some additional models as well so
we already talked about what cost per
acquisition is because this is a
actionable based ad so we want people to
do something like download our app but
you also have another cost model here
cost per install and you only pay when
that person who watches or sees that ad
clicks on it and actually does install
the app okay you also have another model
that you can apply here and that's the
return on ad spend and a return on ad
spend basically is you're asking google
hey i want to make sure that if i'm
going to run this type of ad i'm getting
my return on investment meaning if i
spend 100
am i getting a hundred and one dollars
back so that's the return on ad spend
that's a cost per install and a cost per
acquisition so you have three models
here for the universal app campaign
about some important metric uh for
youtube so we thrown around a lot of
different cost models when we talked
about the different types of advertising
you can do on youtube and so
with that there's a lot of metrics so
let's go through some of these metrics
here you have views clicks your view
rate so you have all these different
types of metrics and
for some of you it could be confusing so
what do i need to look like look at what
i need to measure so it really does come
down to
you know what's important to your
business that's always first and
foremost but here we listed some of the
most common metrics available to you
with youtube okay so let's go through
some of these and basically a view is
just it shows the number of times people
watched or engaged with your video ad so
a view rate is basically the number of
views or engagement your ad receives and
the number times your ad is shown okay
so divided by the number of times your
ad was shown into the number of
engagements so if your ad was shown a
hundred times and you had one like or
one click for example then that would be
one percent so average cost per view is
the average amount you pay whenever your
watch is 30 seconds of your videos so
remember when you're on a cost per view
model remember 30 seconds is the magic
number so if your video is only 25
seconds then remember that's going to be
the view so it's got to be minimum or
maximum 30 seconds if your video is
under 30 seconds it's 25 seconds or 20
as an example then it's still going to
count as a view if it's a minute and
somebody watched at least 30 seconds of
it then that's gonna count as a view so
just keep in mind 30 seconds is the
magic number here for the view so if
somebody watches at least 30 seconds of
your video or engages with your video
that would be a cost per view so that's
the average amount you're gonna pay and
watch time is basically it measured the
total amount of time people watched your
video ads shown in seconds okay so it's
the total amount of time so
it gives you an idea of how many minutes
total your video is run so let's focus
on clicks so clicks is a common metric
across the board it shows the number of
times people actually clicked on your
video not to be confused the view so
views the number of times your video was
actually watched a click is something
also measurable and it's when somebody
actually clicked on it so it's an
indicator for how well your ads are
doing with those who see it and so you
know we want people to click on our ads
if we're running you know actionable
type video ads if we're running those
action at type ads or universal app ads
we're going to want people to take
action okay if you're running ads just
for impressions that's one thing so
clicks is an important metric depending
on the type of video ad you're running
so click-through rate is the number of
clicks you receive from your ad divided
by the number of times the ad was shown
so my ad was shown a hundred times and i
received one click and that's one
percent click-through rate so let's talk
about engagement and engagement is the
number of clicks on interactive elements
such as icons in your video ad okay so
that's what an engagement is here the
number of clicks on interactive elements
and then if we look at engagement rate
then any clicks on an interactive
element that we receive is going to be
divided by the number of times the ad
was shown so that's why we have
engagement rate as well so we want
people to engage with our video is there
something that they're doing on the
video if so then what's the rate at
which they're engaging earned views
that's a number of viewers who have seen
subsequent videos on your channel or
watch pages after
seeing your ads so watch pages or videos
on your channel if you've seen those
after seeing your ad then that's going
to be called an earned view so somebody
seen your ad and was impacted by what
they saw if we look back at the examples
we've shown earlier on with the global
warming or the gmc or the airbnb ads you
know if i saw those ads and i said man
that's really a cool ad or that's really
good message i'm gonna go over to that
that watch page or i'm gonna go over to
that channel and see what other videos
they have when you do that that's an
earned view and then if you can get an
earned view you're probably gonna get an
earned subscriber because it's the
number of viewers who subscribe to your
channel after seeing your ad so again
going back to any of the ads that you've
ever seen if you've ever gone over to
their channel and then subscribed to the
channel that's an earned subscriber so
your video ad is doing something for you
it's in this case it's getting you a
subscriber so let's talk about how to
create a youtube ad so this is going to
require
some access to google ads and we'll go
over that in a few minutes here but
first we need to think about setting up
a campaign and setting up a campaign
goal okay what's the goal of our
campaign to get eyeballs you know we
want to pay costs for 1000 impressions
or we want to run some actionable type
ads to get people over to our website so
that really is step one we need to
identify what the goal of our campaign
is then we need to create the ad so we
want to be able to create a video out
here that is going to show on youtube
and to our target audience so or whether
it be a bumper ad that's only gonna be
six seconds long we need to be able to
figure out what type of ad we wanna run
so here i am in google ads if we're
going to run a campaign on youtube we
need to make sure that
we're choosing a display campaign and so
remember the first step is you know
setting up that campaign setting up that
campaign goal so we're gonna go ahead
and select a new campaign here we're
going to run a new campaign and so
what's the goal of our campaign so if
we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach that's certainly
fine if it's all about sales or if it's
all about leads then you know the type
of video run is going to be a little bit
different so if we select brand
awareness and reach okay here we're
going to select the campaign type and so
if we select video
basically what we're doing is we're
going to tell google we want to go ahead
and set up some video ads on youtube and
so here you can see
the different types of video ads we
discussed today you know we got your
bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our out stream which is basically
our viewable cpm model so we're gonna go
ahead and
you know check one of these types of
campaign types or ad types so we're
gonna click continue and then once we do
that you know we're gonna get prompted
to
you know move forward with selecting our
ad so you can see here after i set up my
campaign now i'm just gonna go through
some of the settings for my ad and i'm
gonna give it a campaign name a budget
okay when it starts or ends the bidding
strategy so again we're going to focus
on cost per 1000 impressions and then
here's the network so this is an
important selection here so we're
dealing with youtube videos so
we also have the option to select video
partners on the display network so that
means that if you want your video to
show on websites that want to host ads
in video format then you can select this
option here notice you also have this
option available if you're running
certain types of ads on youtube we're
running those bumper ads so bumper ads
aren't available on search results so
i'm going to stick with the video
partners okay youtube videos and here we
can get into some other specifics like
language country the type of inventory
so here you can see the default is
standard inventory so that means that
this is what google recommends we want
to show our ads on content that's
appropriate for most ads okay so we can
go expanded or limited so we're going
with the recommended here okay and then
when we go down we're gonna have an ad
group so when you create an a campaign
you can have an ad group so with an ad
group that means that we can have a more
or less a video in every aggregate we
have but we have to have at least one ad
group so we're gonna go ahead and set up
you know this ad group here and here's
where it gets interesting and important
because here is where we can start
targeting our audience so here we got
demographics okay so we can choose
gender age parental status household
income okay we can focus in on audiences
if we want to so we can we can choose a
specific audience that we've set up we
can get some ideas or browse specific
audiences we could also choose a
specific placement so here you have
youtube videos or we can go with youtube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid
for our target cpm and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember we're
in this example we're going to bumper
ads so we're looking at about six
seconds and once we do that then that's
pretty much the campaign but i just want
to stress here that when you're setting
it up ahead of time you want to make
sure you identify what the campaign goal
is and then that's going to align with
the type of video you're going to run
and then once you choose that type of
video then it just comes down to where
you want that ad to be and who you're
targeting so
it's really crucial here that you go
through these steps and these options
very closely so because you want your
video to show in front of the right
audience on the right placement so let's
talk about how you can optimize your
youtube ads so once you get your
campaign set up once you select your
channel or the type of videos where you
want your ad to be and you select your
target audience and you're off and
running with your video ad well we're
going to give you some tips here that
you can focus on for optimizing those
ads and so going back to what i was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully define your metrics and goals
okay so that's step one so when you're
setting up the campaign remember you
have that option to choose the type of
goal for your campaign that can be brand
awareness it could be a sale it could be
a lead so to me that's the you know a
very critical step one so you want to
make sure you align your goal with your
video and then the second is track low
performing ad placements so if we just
ask
google to place our video ads anywhere
they want then it's up to us then to go
through and choose the ad placements and
remove them okay so let me show you an
example of what that means so if i'm
back in google i'm gonna go to my
campaign and i'm gonna select placements
and here i can see placements but then
i'm gonna select where my ads show and
so this is important you want to be able
to scan the list of placements where the
ad was shown so if you don't like one of
the placements on youtube you can always
select it edit it and exclude it from
the campaign or advert so that's really
the key is you want to be able to
manage your placements properly and when
we say low performing ad placements we
mean really what what's your goal if
your goal is to get sales or leads if
you're that placement is not converting
sales or leads then you need to remove
or exclude that placement so it's all
done within the google ads platform and
then you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well
it's always helpful in terms of
optimization so a couple of other
pointers here to help you optimize okay
you want to drive people to perform a
particular action with the appropriate
cta so
again depending on the ad type you know
if it's a true view ad 20 seconds long
you want to have a call to action you
want to maybe even have your domain name
at the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting specify who gets to see your
ad and who doesn't okay so that goes
back to your settings so you can pick
and choose who your target audience is
you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be as an other
setting you can use closed captioning in
your ads to make it more interactive so
that way people can actually see or read
what the ad is all about just to make it
a bit more interactive you can always
perform a b testing on your ads so if
you have one ad version you can create
another one just to see
what it which one performs better
testing is always a positive okay so if
you're paying too much maybe think about
reducing your bids so if you remember we
said a 10 cpm bid that may be too much
maybe we don't need to pay 10 so we can
always reduce our bids at the ad group
level so reduce bids in areas where you
see lower performance so in other words
you don't want to pay a lot for poor
performance you can also use remarketing
to re-engage with customers so if
somebody views your ads and doesn't take
action you can always retarget that
person uh to show your ad another even
another ad format it could be text ads
or display ads but if somebody looked at
your video and they didn't take the
action you preferred them to take then
you can always retarget them with
another ad so that's a good way to
optimize okay so we want to make sure
the ad has content that what viewers
would find relevant okay that really you
want to make sure that your ad is you
know is with the end viewer you don't
want to put out an ad that isn't going
to give somebody you know a good feeling
after they've watched it okay so you
want to make sure viewers find the
content relevant so if they don't find
it relevant then that means your
engagement rate and your engagement is
probably going to be low so you want to
take a look at those metrics that we
viewed earlier engagement rate
engagement and if they're low then you
probably need to look at the content of
the ad so try to make sure your ad
conveys your brand's message in the
first six seconds so that's why bumper
ads to me are so critical because you've
got to get the entirety of the ad and
make it impactful and so with any ad you
run any video ad you're on you really
want to make sure that that message is
conveyed at the very beginning early as
possible otherwise you know people are
going to be turned off or not engaged
and just going to go ahead and skip it
anyway so you want to make sure you get
the purpose of it right up front and out
of the way okay you can also include
visual and auditory components in your
ad that can make it more memorable to
the viewers okay meaning music or other
cool visuals okay so again you want to
be able to play around and test
different ads and you want to be able to
you know measure the ad performance
based on the metrics we discussed i mean
click-through rate engagement rate all
of those are indicators whether the ad
is of good quality or not with the end
user and when i say good quality i mean
do they find it engaging did they find
it interesting if so they're going to
click and if you don't have good
click-through rates or good engagement
rates then you definitely want to try
doing something different to the ad like
adding those audio components or other
visuals that could be appealing to the
end user so go ahead and test some of
those out with a b testing because you
have nothing to lose but higher or lower
engagement rates or lower click-through
rates so you want to be able to improve
those metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry so they're a good success
story on youtube so super dry
leaned on some youtube advertising to
help lift one of their products so in
september last year 2018 super dry if
you're not familiar with the brand
they're you know centered some asian
markets european markets and they focus
in on clothing uh all different styles
and sizes and genders
from jackets to jeans to t-shirts and so
their global brand they really wanted to
take a different approach here and their
approach was they wanted to focus in on
sales they wanted to see if video can
help lift them with sales and so what
they've done is they set up some
campaigns on youtube and their focus
here was on jackets and jackets to
specific ages across the board all
genders and interests and so what they
did was they want to want to take
advantage of all the different ad types
that youtube had to offer and let's take
a look at one of those ads here so if we
go to youtube
and let's just take a look at this one
minute ad here 53 second ad buy super
dry
i'm ready now super dry and painty cakey
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raving the jacket you're waiting
the jacket you're pulling the jacket
your play
not your death in this jacket it's the
jacket
you're chilling
it's the jacket you're hiding you're
vibing love live and prizes
this is the jacket
the jacket that will get you through
so that's the video that super dry ran
you could see that
you know it was it had some particular
goals there and so super dry is pretty
well known so probably wasn't built
around brand awareness per se it was
probably growth consideration and
interest and also driving action okay
it's a pretty cool video it was
definitely not a bumper ad because
bumper ads are six seconds so it was
definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on super dry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
target their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a
very broad audience of gender uh some
younger people is who they were
targeting so
younger people tend to slant on youtube
and so they were able to get some nice
views out of it 4.8 million but the more
important thing is because these videos
were to drive action and so they were
able to see a four to one ratio on
return on investment and as a result
these jackets saw a 138 percent increase
in brand lip i mean the jacket ad so it
was a pretty successful campaign see as
well choreographed good audio good video
just well professionally done and they
probably were able to now get a few more
loyal customers
under their belt because of this ad
alone so that's the power of video okay
so you're able to know who your target
audience is you can go out and target
them with a cool video and given that
youtube is vast then you can really take
advantage of a lot of their ads so what
they probably did again was there's
trueview in-stream ads uh with a cost
per view uh through a skippable video ad
format and they they also use the
shoppable ad format so that is another
option on youtube so they took advantage
of all youtube had to offer in terms of
who they were trying to target the
length of the ad
and
given that their product or selling a
product or promoting a product they will
take advantage of the trueview shoppable
ad format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video ad
and so
this is just a good case study you super
dry will probably do this again
based on the numbers that they're
reporting and so
basically that's the power of youtube
getting out in front of your audience
with a really good video ad targeting an
audience taking advantage of different
formats today we're going to talk about
how to increase instagram followers
today's webinar we're going to have some
tips and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about instagram so
instagram is not really an up-and-coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active instagram users 500 million daily
the user-based growth of more than 300
year-over-year so it's growing and
growing and growing it's become more and
more popular ever since it's launched
back in 2010 and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can upload
photos tag those photos even use and
implement videos and photos have become
very popular with the advent of mobile
technology that the instagram app makes
it easy for you to post your photo so
there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's
100 million photos plus uploaded daily
and then there are 400 million stories
posted daily so when you post something
you can create a story out of it and
there's 400 million of those per day and
then there's more than 50 billion photos
shared to date so since 2010 platform
nat which is now owned by facebook has
become really really popular a good
place for you if you have your own
company if you have your own brand if
you have your own product it's a good
place for you to really showcase that
service that product that brand because
of the user base how easy it is to use
and the wide reach it has for you in
which to tell your story so mention
there are lots of photos shared today
close to seven billion dollars revenue
generated through instagram mobile so on
top of everything i just said there's a
lot of e-commerce going on here too so
instagram is a platform in which there's
e-commerce integrated within the
platform
so as a business who offers up products
you can actually generate revenue for
yourself on the flip side instagram
which is owned by facebook has an
opportunity to sell advertising space on
instagram so instagram is an e-commerce
platform to say the least in fact
instagram is because it's so popular
because it's part of facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're gonna see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
gonna go through some tips and tricks
today and we're gonna talk about
everything there is to know about
instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip
one here so because instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you could
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if i go to my instagram account for
example using my desktop i could see my
profile and i can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear and
concise and compelling bio why because
this is your introduction to the world
you want people to know who you are and
because if you don't really become very
clear to people they're not going to
follow you so this is where it all
starts you need to take advantage of
your bio have a clear and concise bio
and have a link to your website or some
contact information so to me this is
where it all starts you gotta have a bio
because that's what people are gonna
look at and they're gonna decide whether
to follow you or not based on primarily
that bio that's where it all starts so
make sure you have a good bio that's tip
number one so you have to make sure that
your landing page is also mobile
optimized since most instagram users are
on mobile so if you're going to put a
link to your website and somebody's on
the instagram app and they see your bio
and they like it and you have a link to
your website make sure that lanny page
they go to is mobile optimized so tip
number two everything you do on
instagram when it comes to posting
evolves around hashtags so that's the
backbone of the platform just like most
platforms out there social media
platforms like twitter or facebook
pinterest you're gonna have hashtags
accompany those posts so instagram is no
different but in this case you really
really want to take advantage of the
hashtag so hashtags are there to help
users find your content so you want to
start out by using hashtags that are
relevant to your business so if you're
in the food industry you're going to
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
are being searched on instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested followers and
sales so here really what i'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's gonna follow
you or that doesn't mean really mean
somebody's gonna be interested in what
you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and broad yes
you're gonna get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to sprout
social which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform and posting content via
their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
post is between 2 and 3 p.m and the best
data post is thursday now that may be
all fine and true according to a sprout
social study and so you may want to go
with this 2 to 3 p.m and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone we're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try 2 to 3 p.m on thursday
the thing is what you're gonna have to
do eventually is figure out what the
best time to post is okay so if you're
pointing out a lot of content and you're
putting out content throughout the week
at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're gonna really have to lean
on a social media platform to help you
determine that because they're gonna
have the data that you need to determine
what the best time of day to post is
okay so we'll talk about social media
platforms here shortly we just know that
when you post post with some rationale
in mind ask yourself before you even
push that publish button or before you
even schedule that post this time a day
in this day of the week makes sense so
you always want to post at the right
time because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with some
platform and instagram also has some
analytics for business accounts so
instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here so steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitor's brand then what the chance
of them liking your brand could be great
so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted okay engage with them okay it
doesn't take that much time it's a good
way to
gain followers so if we're on instagram
we can simply just click on the brand's
followers so here i can see this brand
has 127 followers and here i can see all
the followers and what i could do is
simply just click on one of the
followers and i can go to their profile
and from there i could see what they've
posted in terms of videos and images and
i can like or comment so just doing
something as simple as this
gets you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you so tip five pay for sponsored
posts and product reviews so a number of
ways you could do this here so pay for a
sponsored post so you could find an
influencer who said it satisfies a
couple of requirements they have large
following and an email address in the
profile so you can connect with them and
ask them for sponsored post pricing so
it's as simple as that as reaching out
to somebody who has a large following
okay so if you do this then it's going
to put you in front of a large number of
people and so by doing this it'll help
expose your brand to that larger
audience and help build your credibility
because you're connecting with somebody
who has a large audience as well so do a
little bit of homework find people out
there in your industry who has a large
following and make sure they have that
email address in their profile so you
can contact them and when you contact
them you know ask them for sponsored
post pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shadow so that's the
key so they got to have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you want to get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location city or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you so tip seven
use instagram stories to attract
followers and grow your user base a
story is a really big feature on
instagram so what stories could be used
for is just show footage of an
environment so it could be your office
it could be your home it could be you
know the playground it could be the golf
course it could be anywhere that you
want to show vintage of so you want to
post new
relevant to your industry so if you're
in the food industry hey why not go in
the back into the kitchen and post a
story about how a particular bread or
cake is made okay show off your product
so if you are in that food industry and
say you're in the pizza making business
perfect opportunity to show people via
an instagram story how to make that
pizza and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
a story you want to show something
unique and relevant that's going to
grasp people's attention you can promote
a company event so if you're celebrating
say 200 000 subscribers create a youtube
video or you can create an instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog posts you
can post positive user reviews so these
are all features of a story increase
interactivity with polls sliders etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
instagram stories is a really big
feature with instagram check it out you
know you can just do a search for
instagram stories in fact let's get some
of you users involved what best
practices do you have when creating
instagram stories why don't you go ahead
and share your instagram story with us
by putting that instagram story in the
comment section below so we want to get
everybody involved here because there's
thousands upon thousands of great
instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back your mind
you know for me i always go back to what
industry are you in if you're in the
food industry hey you know people who
are following you are interested in food
if you're a pizza company you know show
off that pizza if you're a bakery show
off how you make your breads and goods
baked goods whatever it is you have show
it off because if somebody's following
you that's what they're interested in so
tip number eight highlight important
stories so you want to highlight
highlights serve as the easiest way to
create a first impression for a
potential follower so with highlights
can be used to tease what your content
is about create a trailer for what your
brand offers promote and promote your
product highlights are there it's a good
feature it's a first impression for
potential followers so it teases what
the contents about it creates a trailer
so to speak for your brand and promote
your product so use highlights and again
any users out there who have good
examples of highlights go ahead and put
those in the content section or comment
section uh right below this video so
remember stories have only a 24 hour
life span so highlights can be used to
give them a second wind okay so
highlights serve a purpose it teases
what the contents about it promotes the
product and it really kind of
accentuates that story tip number nine
ask for followers so sometimes people
need a little push before they can
follow you on instagram even if they
enjoy your content so you can ask users
to become your followers in the caption
the comment section or even work it into
your content so in other words when
you're posting something don't be afraid
to say hey follow me you know i got some
good stuff here be confident you don't
want to do it for every post of course
but you know pick and choose if you feel
you have a really good post you know
really good image that you think is
going to gain a lot of followers and
engagers then you don't necessarily need
to put a caption in there but if if it
is popular then go ahead and say hey
this is a popular post you know think
about following me or put something in
the comment section you want to do it
kind of succinctly you don't want to be
begging but just working in to some
degree okay but don't be afraid have
some confidence and asking for followers
so when you do this it's very similar to
how we do it on youtube so you can ask
viewers to subscribe to their channels
at the end of the video so it's if on
youtube basically you're saying hey if
you like what we have go ahead and
subscribe it's no different on instagram
if you have something you've posted just
go and say hey you like this yeah go
ahead and follow us it's that simple so
tip number 10 take on the latest trends
to get more followers so align your
content to cater to trendy topics or
hashtags to improve engagement and
discoverability so really what we're
trying to say here's your competitors
follow influencers what are the latest
trends and you can get an idea of the
latest trends by you looking at hashtags
so what hashtags are trending which ones
are people using the most so really what
you want to do is whatever is trending
in your industry you know ride that wave
so to speak now it doesn't have to take
on your entire profile but there's
nothing wrong with one or two posts if
something's really taking on popularity
then go ahead and post about it as well
you know for example in the wine
industry if there's a new wine that
really came out that's really gaining
some popularity go ahead and post about
it with the same hashtag and with the
unique hashtag so don't be afraid to
you know ride the wave of popularity so
to speak because it shows that you know
you know what you're talking about it
adds some credibility and it's going to
get some you know viewers over to your
instagram profile so keep in mind you
need to keep your content relevant
because if your audience is interested
in what you have to offer then they're
going to be engaged however you know if
you're joining the discussion in a
relevant manner keeping in mind whether
your audience will interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
youtube just like on facebook i mean
instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contest since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
what's an idea of a contest well again
if you're running a pizza parlor you
know you could say hey what's your
favorite pizza or give me your favorite
pizza ideas and you can run a contest
and you know you can have people even
create their own pizza and post an image
of it you can have people create stories
on the best ways in which they create
pizza or their experience in another
pizza parlor there's lots of things you
can do to create a contest and you don't
always have to give something away you
can just do something for fun especially
if you have a lot of followers if you
have a lot of followers then somebody's
going to take part in it so don't be
afraid to run contests just to make it
fun and light it up a little bit so each
tag can bring you a new audience member
who could be a potential follower so
anytime you run a contest people are
going to tag their friends to let them
know about that contest so those friends
are going to come over and likely engage
so that's the beauty of running a
contest or giveaway is chances are
word's going to spread and it's going to
get you some new followers so that's the
the end benefit so to speak but the real
benefit is keeping your audience engaged
so tip number 12 we want to stay
consistent with post so having a
consistent pace and theme for your post
can have a huge impact to convert
visitors so when we say consistent you
know if you're again that pizza parlor
stay within pizza you could branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to you know as a
complementary factor to the pizza okay
but don't talk about hamburgers if
you're focused in on pizza so we want to
stay consistent with your theme this
method involves less effort with a
faster production of instagram content
so that me what we're really trying to
say here is focus stay focused on who
you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's gonna muddy the
water suppose so to speak and you're
probably gonna get less engagement so
set a theme on instagram by maintaining
consistency and your personality filters
colors and layout and really what i'm
referring to is post and when you have
post something you're you're really
creating a personality for yourself okay
so if you're in fashion for example and
you're in the jeans industry well jeans
jeans jeans right that's your
personality accentuate it with different
outfits related to jeans but you know
when you start talking about dresses and
shoes and and that kind of blurs your
your personality a bit so if you stay
consistent with thin jeans and outfits
that go with jeans then i think people
are going to start to pick up on that
personality so tip 13 keep track of your
instagram following so you can analyze
the growth of your channel with tools
like social blade that could tell you
how many followers you've lost over time
and how engaged they are okay so you can
use data gather from here and from
instagram business account to diagnose
where you're faltering so let's take a
look at socialblade as an example here
so if i go over here i'm going to go to
socialblade here i can enter in
basically any account after i register
and i could see how that account has
performed you know where they rank you
know how many uploads they have what
country they focused on what industry
and the beauty here is i could see and
i'm looking at youtube as an example i
could see you know how my post to
perform well you could do this for
instagram you could do it for facebook
so you can really get an idea of
how your account's performing so
socialblade's a great platform for
measuring it and again you do also have
instagram business insights so with
instagram business insights basically
what you're going to do is you're going
to go to your app right and then from
the app you can basically look at your
insights from there so in the app itself
you're gonna click on the upper right
three lines and from there you're gonna
see insights and when you go to insights
you're also gonna see you know what your
reach is how many impressions and some
engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're going to also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the the instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns and post what posts
receive the most amount of engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replicate it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use instagram ads so instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mention this on other webinars for
facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if i go back into say
facebook ads manager i can pick and
choose my placements and really what i
want to do is pick and choose for
example instagram and so i have
instagram feed i have instagram stories
so and i could see what the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on instagram so with
instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
carousel to really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
facebook ads manager and it's going to
tell you you know what your audience
size is your potential reach okay what
your daily results would be so you're
going to get all that information when
you run your ads on facebook ads manager
but it's a great opportunity for you to
really push forward if you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting units you need
meaning you know who saw the ad do they
click on it okay you can refine that
target audience you can go back into
facebook ads manager and refine who your
audience is so lots of flexibility here
and advertising on instagram but the key
here is if you want to run advertising
on instagram you know think about what
it is you're trying to promote if you
feel something needs to get promoted
then go ahead and you know you can
either again reach out to somebody and
have them sponsor it or you can run it
as an advertisement so let's move on to
tip 15. so we want to create visually
attractive and eye-catching ads so if
you are going to run ads you know here's
some things to keep in mind okay you
want to use images that are natural and
seem native okay you don't want to use
any stock photography first off you want
to use something that you've done okay
you want to minimize the amount of text
so let the image do the talking you want
to ensure your caption relates to the
image and resonates with your audience
okay so you have an opportunity to add
some text below the image okay so make
sure it resonates and then of course use
hashtags to show your ads to target your
audience but a wider relevant audience
so hashtags do play a role here as well
so these are some tips if you're going
to create ads you want to take these
into account the whole point of the ad
is to get people over to either web page
or to your profile page okay so that
they can engage and take action so
instagram ads will help showcase your
product service or brand in a way that's
memorable and unique so if you really
want to get your vision your brand your
product out there in front of a lot of
people then advertising on instagram is
a good way to do that so since we've
been talking about pizza throughout this
webinar there's a good instagram a
profile here about pizza you know i'm
getting hungry just looking at this
hopefully this is an example for all veg
and non-veg pizza consumers i mean you
can see this profile here they got the
website you know they got the handle
okay so they have a lot of followers so
you know if i'm in the pizza industry i
can go ahead and you know click on their
followers and see who who's following
them who they're following so
some really good shots of pizza here it
looks like you know a lot of people were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo so
here you know you could say use daily
pizza as a hashtag for feature okay so
they're even encouraging you to use a
specific hashtag so you can really do a
lot here on instagram this is just a
good example of what you can do and have
fun with you know with an example like
pizza just to give you some ideas so
let's move on to tip 16. take advantage
of instagram tools so you can use
scheduling tools like later hootsuite
and buffer so i can't stress this enough
you know it comes to measuring the
engagement of your instagram post you're
definitely going to need a social media
tool so you're also going to need it if
you do a lot of
you know posting on instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com so if i go to later here i can
see you know i can use this to upload my
images to my profile so here you can see
it's scheduled throughout the day of the
week so that way we're not overlapping
you know we're scheduling based on the
times of the day that people are gonna
look at this so
you know here i could see you know
particular stories if any stories are
posted okay i can look at it from a
weekly or monthly preview i could see
what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool i can
also see the analytics i could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing i want to be able to see what
posts perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by
location so again i can look at it by
post performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags that this become a
particular company is using on instagram
so here you can see how many posts with
this hashtag you know and what and kind
of engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job i like this
platform especially for instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from best practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown here in later.com so
remember these tools place an emphasis
on automation okay enabling you to
automatically post at a scheduled time
so you want to lock it in at a certain
period of time and i have to worry about
it so it allows you to really hone in on
that particular time of the day and day
of the week so that you're really
maximizing your chances of getting good
engagement okay so develop your own
signature styles to set up a style and
content theme so that you're able to
stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza and but this is their
style this is who they are you know
they're not a particular brand they're
just you know people who like pizza okay
and they're having fun with it okay so
that's their style you know they're
posting really good shots of all this
different types of pizza different
styles different toppings and just to
give you an idea of how popular pizza is
and what you can do with it okay so
again this is a good basic example um of
what you can do
with something as simple as pizza so
don't be afraid to experiment you know
try something different with your
profile you know do something different
you don't always have to follow what
everybody else is doing that's the great
thing about instagram it allows you to
be free and creative in fact if anybody
has any styles that have worked for them
you know feel free to put something in
the comment section we'd love to hear
your thoughts so tip 18 use user
engagement to your advantage so i just
mentioned that using the later example
so we want to be able to
learn from what's working and not
working so user generated content shows
off your brand to be authentic and
improves your relationship with your
followers so you know you want to be
unique with the content that you're
posting so
if you do that you're likely to build
that relationship and you know increase
your followers and you want to be able
to see of that user generated content
that ugc which is performing which is
not performing okay so basically your
followers and your audience are telling
you what's working and not working so
take advantage of that remember going
back to hashtags you could set up your
own unique hashtag and ask your users to
post images or videos relating to that
which you can post in your brand's
account so just like the whole pizza
thing they're saying hey look you know
use daily pizza for a feature okay
that's a good example of something you
can do as well so you could set up a
unique hashtag and say hey use this
hashtag and that'll help you gain some
followers that'll help you gain some
notoriety and some visibility on your
platform tip 19 use high quality images
and videos just like on youtube just
like on facebook instagram is no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original i mean again one
more time go back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality i
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational without causing
the user to lose interest so you know if
you're going to create a video you know
go ahead and you know make you can make
it short make it fun okay you can see
here these guys are just showing you how
pizza is made doesn't take a long time
they're just going through the motions
they're not boring you with details
they're not talking really quick and
easy just to give you an idea it doesn't
have to be as serious it could be fun so
video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you could do that you're likely going to
hold the user's attention so tip 20
promote your instagram page and other
social media channels so facebook and
instagram are part of the same family so
this seems like a natural but you know
don't be afraid to
promote it on other channels like
pinterest or or youtube the whole idea
is to get users to your instagram page
and encourage them to follow it so you
know you can always put that url in you
know other platforms like youtube
nothing wrong with that at all okay you
can also promote your page offline with
print ads and during other relevant
events and then i would even take this
to further is you'll probably see you
know
an instagram logo on a webpage along
with other social media icons so you
always want to help promote instagram on
your web page as well but you can do it
for offline with print ads so you can
simply just put you know whatever your
your slug is for instagram whatever your
id is whatever you're using on instagram
that's what you can use don't be afraid
to promote it offline or online today
we're going to talk about how to
increase twitter followers so welcome
and let's get started so with twitter
it's all about tweets it's actually a
verb now uh when you do something on
twitter you actually tweet and there are
a lot of people out there tweeting in
fact twitter has over 1.3 billion
accounts so
a lot of tweets going on in the world of
twitter so as of the third quarter in
2018 last year twitter had 326 million
global monthly active users okay so
active meaning every day using the
platform on a daily basis so a lot of
people using twitter it's very easy to
use as you'll find out and what you're
going to find out today is how to
increase followers on your twitter
account so they can see more of your
tweets okay a little bit more about
twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information being
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so twitter does allow
videos as well as images attracts ten
times more engagement than other forms
of content so
if you watched our youtube videos and
some of the other videos we had out
there regarding facebook or instagram
you'll know that videos do perform
better twitter is no exception so if you
have a video even if it's done on
youtube or if it's not unpublished on
youtube use it with twitter you're going
to get more engagement so twitter has 75
of its users use the platform for news
okay so people go to twitter to get
their news that's where they go they
don't go to a regular website content
based website they get their news via
twitter it's just very easy to digest
because it's so few characters 75
percent of b2b businesses market on
twitter so not only is it a b2c or
business to consumer platform it's a b2b
business to business platform so a lot
of businesses are on twitter
basically promoting either a product
service or trying to establish
themselves in the industry using the
platform so let's take a look at twitter
and let's take a look at some of the
ways in which you can increase your
followers it all starts with your
profile you always want to make sure you
have a complete profile your name
obviously the twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a keyword friendly bio okay
a link to your website and a picture
that represents your brand always helps
so make sure it's complete you can even
take a step further by customizing the
color scheme of your profile you can add
a header image that sticks to your theme
that will help your profile stand out
and so let's take a look at an example
here so if i go to twitter here if we go
to simply learn twitter account okay
their handle is simply at simplylearn
okay and they've customized the header
they use their logo now if you're an
individual you probably want to use a
nice profile pic here where they're
based a little bit about them so just a
you know customized complete profile
goes a long way you don't have to go
overboard with an elaborate design so to
speak but just make it stand out make it
associate with who you are as a person
and a brand those are best practices in
getting that profile up and running you
don't want to use something bland and
generic you know take the extra step
create something unique make sure your
profile is unique you have a good image
okay make sure it's complete with you
know telling people who you are and what
you're all about that's really the first
step on really any social media platform
so
you want to promote your twitter profile
to drive users from other social media
platforms so when you actually get that
twitter account set up and you actually
do have your handle go ahead and share
it that's the first step in getting
followers if you're already on facebook
if you're already on instagram then use
those platforms to announce that you're
on twitter you can also take that a step
further and you know send out an email
to friends or family or like i said if
you're on facebook go ahead and set up a
post say hey guys i'm on twitter you
know come follow me so you could also
use business cards advertisements
marketing materials events to put that
twitter profile on okay so it doesn't
have to be within the social media
sphere it could be even on your website
it can be even in email so you can
basically promote that profile again you
want to make that profile that handle
easy to remember so totally real person
is the profile in this example we're
going to use that profile every way we
can whether that be offline or online
you don't don't be afraid to use it on a
business card especially if it's easy i
can just simply go to twitter and type
in that handle so you want to stay
active on twitter with regular retweets
replies and favorites and that's just
it's just so easy to retweet and reply
and add favorites so let's take a look
at that on twitter so you could just
simply i'm logged in as me and if i want
to retweet something that simply learn
did i can just simply click on the
retweet button and i can add a comment
if i want to and then i'm going to
retweet it's that simple so now that
tweet is going to show up on my profile
my handle and i could simply like it if
i scroll down here okay top 10 it trends
shaping 2019 notice a simple tweet
supported with an image so i'm just
going to like that so i can even comment
on it i can click on the comment and
click a reply here okay and that's going
to show up in this tweet here just like
if i click on this i'll be able to see
what other people have written and so
it's that simple if i want i can just
click on the email button and even send
a message to somebody right from that
tweet the point is i can do everything i
need to do right in the platform but to
get started if you don't have any tweets
you know go and find other companies
similar to you look at their tweeting
and you can always retweet that that's a
good way to get going with tweets that's
what i started doing when i started on
twitter in 2008 i didn't know what to
write particularly and i didn't know how
to write it particularly well so i
looked at what other people wrote and
and tweeted and just retweeted those
that's a good way to get your twitter
account started okay so engaging with
users is a great way to get more
followers so on simply learn i retweeted
one of their tweets i liked another one
of their tweets and it's probably gonna
get their attention somebody at simply
learn is gonna say okay rob sanders
went ahead and liked us and you know
what we're gonna go follow this guy he
seems to be
somebody who's an audience member who
likes what we have to do likes what we
have to say like what we're tweeting
let's go ahead and follow him and so
that's a good way to get going with your
twitter account is to
really start retweeting and liking other
tweets from other users so you can find
an appropriate time to post your tweets
to increase exposure retweets and
followers and you want to do this you
could do it within twitter or as i'll
mention later you can do it in a social
media platform like sprout social or
hootsuite or later or buffer and there's
plenty of social media platforms out
there for you to schedule tweets point
is you want to be able to schedule those
tweets when it's the appropriate time so
you don't want to do it in the middle of
the evening because what's going to
happen is
likely by the morning other tweets are
going to bury your tweet so you want to
be able to find the appropriate time to
post your tweets so according to a
survey conducted by hubspot the best
time to post is between 12 and 3 p.m and
why is that well most people are usually
on lunch checking their phones yes
twitter has an app and in fact most
people use the app just like on
instagram just like on youtube the app
is very popular on twitter so it's very
easy for somebody to check tweets
especially during the lunch hour and
then from 5 to 6 p.m that that in
between time when when people are
wrapping up work or heading home okay so
weekdays have shown to have the maximum
amount of engagement so during the week
when people are working highly engaged
with whatever they're doing depending on
what industry you're in they're likely
going to
check the twitter and react during those
times okay so that was a a survey
conducted by hubspot but really what you
want to do is you want to be able to use
one of these social media platforms like
a hootsuite or later and find out
exactly when are people engaging with
your tweets when a what time of the day
what day of the week are you getting the
most retweets or the most likes okay
that's what you want to do so you can
use this as a starting point as a best
practice but eventually you're gonna
have to cater to your audience based on
when you're getting your tweets engaged
so you want to increase followers by
following more people it's that simple
and so it really is that simple let me
rephrase that so it really is that
simple so if i go back to twitter you
know twitter is always going to
recommend somebody for me to follow and
normally those are people that are
similar as myself okay so they're not
just going to choose random people
they're going to choose people who are
following people you're following so
there's going to be a connection to some
degree or they could be people who use
similar hashtags tweeting the same
content so
you want to go ahead and
follow people the rule of thumb on
twitter is if you follow somebody on
twitter chances are they're going to
follow you back you know i was once told
when i was using twitter that hey you
want to give somebody about three days
to follow you back so that's always what
the rule i stuck to you know wait about
three days start following people
you can see here 833 people that or
accounts twitter accounts that simply
learns following and over 10
900 followers to simply learn's twitter
account so for me i don't mind having a
nice balance myself i have just as many
followers as i do following and that's a
good thing so because you want to be
able to keep up with what people are
tweeting and so you can retweet at the
same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are followers of your
followers and you can use twitter's who
to follow list and upload your email
contacts to twitter okay since they know
you they're more likely to follow you
back okay so you can use twitter's who
to follow list and so if we go back to
twitter here's the who to follow list
and so this is what twitter's gonna
recommend but you can click on this link
here find people you know okay so if i
click on find people i know then i can
upload my contacts from outlook or gmail
and they're going to find people who are
already on twitter based on who i'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers is to connect with people you
know by the way i'm going to follow
simply learn because i wasn't following
them prior so now i just clicked on the
follow button now i am following so now
i'm going to see simply learns tweets in
my feed so let's take a second to look
at a brand okay so it's time for brand
watch let's have a look at some of the
best tweets of 2018. now remember there
are a lot of active users millions of
active users that's a lot of tweaks so
what we did was we scoured twitter from
2018 and we went ahead and picked out
some tweets that we thought were pretty
good and so the first one is wendy's now
i don't know if any of you have actually
eaten at wendy's i used to eat at
wendy's a while ago i know their
frosties are pretty good so
what they've done is they incorporated
that frosty as part of a giveaway okay
so basically they're saying hey grab
yourself a free frosty with any purchase
in our app so they're encouraging people
to use our app and then they're
following that up by saying hey and then
join us on twitch from two to five
eastern as we unlock all that frosty
goodness so they're promoting something
that's going to happen on a specific
point in time this is last january
they're encouraging people to use their
app and they're using that frosty as
kind of a carrot if you will okay it's a
catch it's a giveaway so they were able
to you know basically wrap a bunch of
things into one so get encourage people
to take part and i'm sure a lot of
people went ahead and took part of this
but we could definitely see that 206
retweeted this tweet 302 basically
commented on it and over 3 000 liked the
tweet so the tweet was good and it
basically engaged with users who doesn't
like a free giveaway especially free
frosty so that's why this particular
tweet really does some justice for the
target audience their audience they're
they're giving something away to their
audience just by allowing them to you
know use their app okay so this tweet
combines a lot into one and i like it
apparently a lot more people than i did
3 000 plus also like this tweet and so
moving on to how to increase your
followers on twitter you want to mention
other people in your tweets to increase
engagement so what do we mean by that so
let's look at twitter so go back if we
look at simplylearn just take a look at
some of their tweets what they're doing
if we scroll down here they have
hashtags so they are mentioning specific
hashtags but you can also mention
handles as well so the hashtag is always
going to start with you the pound sign
but if we scroll down here if you use
the at symbol you're actually mentioning
somebody so in this case we're
mentioning matt bailey so matt bailey
says is matt bailey's handle and so if
you get a shout out to somebody they're
gonna pick up on that and then they're
going to probably follow you okay who
doesn't appreciate getting recognized
for something especially something as
small as a tweet okay notice i can go
ahead and click follow if i want to
follow them out bailey but it's not a
bad idea to add people into your tweet
and you simply do that by just using the
ad symbol and using their twitter handle
it's a good way to get recognized by
that twitter follower it also increases
engagement because it's adding validity
to the tweet and it definitely catches
the attention of the person mentioned
remember if you use that person's handle
they're going to see that that you
mention them okay and what it's likely
going to do is start some type of
twitter relationship okay they're going
to then follow you you're going to
follow them and chances of them
retweeting you in the future or
mentioning you in the future is probably
going to increase and overall that
increases engagement so another
important thing you want to do is find
and use hashtags that are relevant to
your brand and audience so this is a
must this is mandatory on twitter you
need to use hashtags twitter's all about
hashtags every tweet that goes out
should have a hashtag okay so what you
can do is figure out what hashtags are
trending so here what twitter does is
they trends for you so these are all
specific hashtags that are trending it's
mother's day happy mother hey sunday
morning whatever works for you these are
trends that happen to be moving meaning
a lot of people are using them clicking
on them okay so you can use a popular
hashtag what i would also recommend is
using a unique hashtag the rule of dumb
is usually about two hashtags in a tweet
but that's a rule of thumb but rules are
made to be broken do what's best for you
if you want to include more than two
hashtags go for it the only thing i'm
recommending is include a hashtag so
find out which trending you could just
look right in twitter or you could just
create your own unique hashtag it works
both ways but when you have a hashtag in
your tweet and somebody clicks on it
then they're going to go to that
particular handle that hashtag and so
when they look at the hashtag gonna see
all the tweets with that hashtag in it
so that's the idea behind hashtags you
want to have hashtags okay so if
somebody clicks on a hashtag that you
used then they're likely going to see
your tweet in that hashtags feed okay so
that's how hashtags work you want to use
hashtags okay but you want to use
hashtags that are relevant to your
branded audience that's really the key
so hashtags help your tweets to be found
through twitter search thus improving
your reach and increase the visibility
of your post so that's another benefit
twitter has search functionality so
somebody can simply go in and start
searching on twitter so if i go back to
twitter i can just do a hashtag and
start typing in something like spanish
and i'm gonna get some of the most
popular spanish hashtags or hashtags
with the word spanish in it and so this
is an idea for me that if i want to use
a hashtag with spanish in it these are
some ideas but they're certainly
searchable on twitter okay so if i just
click on spanish okay i'm gonna be able
to see all the hashtags with the word
spanish in the hashtag so definitely use
hashtags it's the most beneficial
feature of twitter bar none so some
reasons why using hashtags also a good
idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team and the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know i work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if i wanted to be just like
simply learn well i could simply just
go to their twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtag see what kind of tweets
they're implementing and see who's
following them so i can simply just
click on the 10
900 followers that they have and what i
could do is i can go through and start
following the people that are following
them so just mimic your competition to
some degree or mimic others in the
industry you know look at what they're
tweeting again start out by retweeting
some of the stuff they're retweeting if
it's good stuff if it's a good tweet
don't be afraid to retweet even your
competitors tweets okay use unique
hashtags use the hashtags they're using
look at who's following their brand so
you can really learn a lot from
others in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people who's
following them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have the frequency of their tweets what
their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets get some sense of what they're
doing and again when i say mimic i mean
what i'm saying is pull best practices
from that twitter account this will give
you an idea what you need to do to get
more followers so it's always a good
form of flattery when you can mimic what
somebody else is doing just like every
other social media platform following
twitter influencers who belong in your
industry is always a good idea so if
you're in the food industry and there's
these star chefs out there probably not
a bad idea to follow those star chefs
you know if you're in the technology
industry well probably not a bad idea to
you know follow bill gates or elon musk
or richard branson or somebody else and
that's a big influencer has an influence
on a lot of people okay but make sure
they're in your industry that's the key
if you can make sure they're in your
industry and you follow them chances are
if they look at your twitter account and
see you're posting or maybe retweeting
some of their tweets they're likely to
follow you and if they're following you
your tweets are gonna show up on their
handle on their feed and so don't be
afraid to go out and connect and follow
those influencers it's a good way to
boost up your followers so again this
will help you gain followers since you
can replicate what they've done with
their profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mind so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their post so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from simply learn so
if i click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that matt bailey was at so it was a
retweet from matt bailey as a matter of
fact but you could see what simply
learn's doing is they're including
either a video or they're including an
image in every tweet and so that's
likely to boost up engagement so
according to buffer which is a another
social media platform adding a relevant
high quality image in your tweets can
help you gain more than 150
engagement okay videos are six times
more likely to be retweeted so if you
have an arsenal video or even one video
don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is trying to use images
as much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so it's a
snowball effect just by using images
okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay pizza always my
good example to use on these webinars i
like pizza here this just says it all
you know they're talking about art and
they're using pizza in the form of art
so they didn't really have to say much
else here this pretty much says it all
and they did get some retweets to get
some to some likes so sometimes you
don't have to say a lot to make your
point sometimes just the image itself
will do the job this was actually not
from 2018 this goes all the way back to
2016. so still holds true if you use an
image that image is going to get
engagement okay so on twitter just like
most other social media platforms you
can promote your tweet so you can use
twitter ads to do that so you can
promote your tweet and what you do by
promoting it is putting it up above so
that most people will be able to see it
okay so see if we can find an example if
i go here i could see this person is
promoting their handle but if i go down
here i can see a promoted tweet by
constant contact so they're promoting
their tweet here so it's not a bad idea
if you have some media budget to go
ahead and either promote your tweet or
advertise on twitter so what that's
going to do is put you in a more
prominent position
and get your tweets out there and the
whole idea for that is to get people to
engage here you can see a call to action
from constant contact so if i click on
that i'm gonna go to
probably a landing page on their website
and so the whole idea when you advertise
on twitter is really just like any other
social media platform you want to put
yourself in front of the right audience
and so twitter's no exception so with
twitter you could put yourself in front
of the right audience so what you could
do is you could promote a tweet you know
do promoted trends or you could do
promoted accounts so you have a number
of different advertising options on
twitter what we just looked at was you
know looking at promoted accounts and a
promoted tweet so when you do advertise
there are advantages you have to pay
only after achieving your marketing
objectives so that's a benefit of
twitter the cost per click it's a cost
per click model so it tends to be fairly
low you could tell your audience so
again you're picking and choosing who
you want your promoted tweet or trend or
account to be in front of and targeting
is based on either engagement or it's
based on keywords i.e hashtags so really
you can tailor who you want your tweet
or your handle to be in front of and so
that's the really the benefit of twitter
if you have a lot of active users on
twitter you can really put yourself in
front of those active users if they're
your relevant audience at a low cost per
click so it's definitely worth the test
so you want to offer twitter support to
your users okay so i can't stress this
enough okay so what you want to do is
when users have questions about your
product they're more likely to tweet you
for support hence they're likely to file
your account so don't be afraid to use
the messaging option as well so we go
back to twitter okay chances are
somebody might have a question for you
here you can look at bing ads it's great
connecting with ppc experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is you're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your twitter
follow account these bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying of twitter
followers you want to build your twitter
following naturally twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shut down shut down by
twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices and organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve bots
and adding thousands of followers to
your twitter account because chances are
it's just going to lead to no engagement
so create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet what somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweet
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories i mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things i do is i'm definitely one
for industry news so if i'm in the
industry of digital marketing if google
did a recent algorithm update i'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it i
also am a blogger so on my particular
website if i blog i'm going to make sure
that blog gets over to twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so i'm in digital
marketing i deal with pay-per-click seo
but am i going to just do pay-per-click
and seo no i know that analytics i know
that you know google tag manager i know
that av testing all of those are
elements of digital marketing so i'm
going to branch out and talk about some
of those things that support digital
marketing so that's an example of
bringing a variety to the type of
content you share so don't just stick to
one thing you know feel free to reach
out a little bit shake things up by
sharing other forms of updates like
engaging quotes and questions these work
best when complimented by an image and
an act as a great discussion starter so
good point here even if you want to
branch out of your industry and just
throw in a nice useful quote it's always
a good way to gain some attention and
get some engagement okay let's look at
another brand and see what they've
tweeted about so we're looking at
forester here so think about emotional
qualities and their implications so
here you can see customers that feel
surprised or grateful or appreciated
they're sharing that insight with you
and so this was interesting when i saw
this so what i did was i simply you see
the hashtag here for digital basically
if you want to look at this particular
study i just went to twitter and i typed
in that hashtag and now i'm going to be
able to see you know some of the other
studies that they've done here you can
see top 10 i teach friends shaping 2019.
so i'm just following the twitter handle
that they used so forrester does a lot
of good research a lot of good insights
and so what they've done here that makes
this tweet look so good is they've
actually put an image of the results in
the tweet so they used an image to help
gain engagement or increase engagement
notice they also gave a shout out to
somebody as well as use some good
hashtagging so good tweet this was back
in 2016. but again a good use of the
image with the tweet so you want to
organize tweet chats to interact with
your users and bring in new followers so
you know you basically want to be
organized when you're dealing with with
chat so tweet chats enable you send out
tweets on a particular topic using a
designated hashtag so during a certain
time to interact with your your
followers and other users so you could
do it at a specific time to really get
out a specific topic but you want to be
able to stay organized so that you know
you what you're chatting about is
reaching the wide audience and you're
getting the right following and the
right engagement okay you can also pin
your best updates and tweets to your
profile so you can just use that pin and
what that's going to do is pin it to the
top and keep it there so that you know
people who go to your twitter handle are
going to be able to see that best tweet
that you've done so what you want to do
here is use the one that's most engaging
so pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of engagement meaning retweets and
followers and likes you want to do that
you want to pin that to your profile and
that will enable first-time visitors to
see it and if they could see something
that other people engage with and that's
going to encourage them to share and
probably follow you so and
and that's always what you want to do
you always want to put your best foot
forward so pin your best tweet to your
profile so i mentioned this earlier use
tools to schedule when to publish your
tweets so here are some of the most
popular platforms you know i use sprout
social so if we take a look at sprout
social here i'm in sprout social i'm
connected to my twitter account i can
simply just start tweeting about
something here so you can see it's gonna
let me know how many characters i have
remaining so to 180 to start out with
when i'm done tweeting notice i can add
an emoji i can upload media i can tag a
specific location okay i can even you
know call out a specific twitter profile
now i can schedule this myself or i can
use the schedule below i can pick and
choose a time to schedule the tweet now
again you want to be able to use the
sprout social whatever social media tool
you're using to figure out when the best
time of day and the day of the week to
actually tweet when are you getting the
best engagement so ideally that's what
you want to do you want to tweet when
you're likely to get the best engagement
when those eyeballs are actually going
to look at that tweet okay but you also
want to separate out your tweets so
they're not on one on top of another
because if you actually tweet back to
back then those tweets are just going to
get buried so if you spread them out a
little bit then you're likely to
maximize your number of impressions or
eyeballs on that tweet so if you
schedule a tweet multiple tweets in the
same day then post them a few hours
apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you and not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just sprout
social hootsuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule posts to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaged
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine-tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with wendy's is run
contests or giveaways remember randy's
gave away that free frosty you don't be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contest can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so what's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if i just go to my website here if i
scroll down we actually have your
twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see i just retweeted the simply learn
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what i retweeted and that's
going to help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely to get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot then hey that's
gonna show up on your website and it's
gonna show that hey you're fresh you're
engaging you keep up to date it's just
going to make it look good and make your
website feel fresh and not stale so
embedding your twitter updates will help
you add new followers as well because
it's people who are coming to your
website that may not even know you have
a twitter account so you can also do
this in a blog post and a newsletter and
other forms of communication media so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just your
website but i would definitely recommend
it because it will give a boost to your
twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention and this is from playstation
so playstation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on apple tv today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with playstation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happened to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
apple tv so you never know what's going
to happen with a tweet when you tweet
good things are likely going to happen
whether that be somebody liking it
retweeting it or somebody adding you as
a follower something good is going to
come out of tweeting twitter is an easy
platform to use and if you take into
account all these best practices you are
going to increase your twitter followers
thanks rob with that we've reached the
end of this video stay tuned for part
three where we'll be covering topics
like content marketing strategy
affiliate marketing digital marketing
career and jobs and digital marketing
interview questions and much more thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from simply learn